e
sh I'm state representative John cluder
from Sullivan district 10 which
comprises the entire city of Claremont
and and and I'm here today as the prime
sponsor and in favor of House Bill 1237
and I have distributed a copy of written
testimony that I gave earlier to the
Commerce Committee but it was given
January 19th but it is still very
relevant I realize your charge is more
the revenue uh and briefly I introduced
this bill
frankley um at the behest of a
constituent who's very concerned about
the current Cigar Bar law which was
acted in
2009 uh and basically he was concerned
about the the revenue imp packed and I
submitted a bill which changed that was
going to try it for two
years uh and I introduced it to the
Commerce Committee uh represent
Stapleton and I who's the
co-sponsor and he he was concerned that
this well-intentioned law from 2009 has
adversely affected certain cigar bars in
the state and forced to modify their
business in order not to lose their
license and he started this you we had
started this convers
September of last year and he mentioned
even though he's from claron a specific
nashille cigar bar to support this
assertion and he also said
the ongoing covid-19 pandemic which as
all know has negatively impacted many
bars restaurants and hotels he believes
our state government should be
considering revising some of the
provisions of House Bill 392 which was
the original bill in 2009 so as to allow
Cigar Bar to compete with other drinking
and eating establishments also he
believes revising The Cigar Bar law
would allow our constituents to more
easily to gather in places to socialize
he is very concerned that because of the
pandemic and the restrictions that a lot
of people have been offsite gathering
places where they
shouldn't basically one of his in fact
concerns about reducing roadside litter
and I know some people might think what
how would that reduce well that people
have been going in the woods and
drinking uh and I realize that's a
that's an ongoing problem since the
pandemic but he feels that something
should be done and he also feels that
constituents should be able to gather
and establish their
choice uh you know reduce the roadside
litter as well as generate a little more
Revenue in cigar and liquor sales which
is I know the reason this committee has
has this
bill um basically my original intent the
intent with the original bill was to
reduce the revenue for two years only I
realize the amended law which I am in
favor of makes a few different
changes and even though I thought I
voted for this law in 2009 and I thought
it was a good bill I think from time to
time we would should look at the laws
that we pass and see if they could be
improved see how they're working first
of all and if they're working fine but
if they can be tweaked to make them
better in principle I believe this what
we should do
uh and I just want to be clear
this constituent came to me he was very
persuasive because for readers
information I'm not a user of cigars or
other tobacco products of any kind I
don't frequent bars I haven't since I
was in college including cigar bars on a
regular basis generally I I just do
light consumption of alcohol beverages
at home this isn't the type of bill that
I normally would sponsor but I believe
my constituent raised some important
concerns about our present Cigar Bar law
and so I would urge you to pass this
bill as amended an amendment that was
approved by the Commerce
Committee uh and uh and that's it as far
as my testimony I'm willing to take any
questions try to answer them if I can
thank you for your testimony represent
C representa Aly followed by
representative ABY okay all right yes
representative Aly thank you uh we need
to see see what the fiscal notes doing
this fiscal note is based on the
original bill I tried to F get the
original bill online and it came up
blank it wouldn't let me in so can you
tell us what on What has been changed is
it just this business about a two-year
pilot that seems to be involved the okay
as the intent and and the intent uh
basically would be
okay no no no the changes that Commerce
made the Commerce made
okay um quickly here I need to turn to
the bill this is a bit of a complicated
subject for me too so bear with me
um all
right um I
believe okay it would allow them
to generate okay in the
209 that they it would allow them as I
understand I think the committee
Commerce committee's intent with the
amendment is to allow cigar bars to
generate additional revenue from things
other than cigars other tobacco sales
including cigarettes and loose loose
tobacco it takes out that provision of
the original
Law um
and basically that's that
was as I read the amendment of for 1237
I'm reading it from the house record
excuse me on no the original what did
the original Bill say okay the original
Bill not the original bill and I worked
with legislative services on this uh the
original
Bill yes the original bill that I
introduced the one that was introduced
to the house the introduced I was going
to cut ital note is BAS okay let me I'm
basically I was going to cut
the
okay just now okay does anyone have it
the 60
okayl computer it online it's yeah okay
I cut the percent yeah M wasn't it's in
the first paragraph to I reduced it to
30% but I made it only
good for two years to use it see it on a
trial basis that was my intent uh you
could argue whether two years but uh
after talking with legislative Services
they thought that would be a better way
to go rather than making it
permanent um so and M I think he in fact
wanted to re to eliminate it entirely
from 60 to zero after talking with
people at legislative services and
conferring with my
co-sponsor and he finally I he was
agreeable to lowering it to
30% having it for two years and seeing
how it would affect Cigar Bar Revenue it
was also an intent to see because I know
the pandemic and hopefully this pandemic
will soon be over but nevertheless it
has affected a lot of cigar bars bars
restaurants and other eating and
drinking establishments so our the
intent of the original bill was to lower
it from 60 to 30% for two years only
that was my intent when I filed the
original bill that was heard before
Commerce on January
19th so I don't know if that helps you
representative excuse me was that the
only
change that's as I right I don't have
the original bill in front of me I I
have what was amended by the house but I
believe that was that was the only
change to the current Cigar Bar law all
right represent Lang you have that yes I
do have the the original bill as filed
would have changed the percentage in
section one down to
30% and and that was for a two-year
period and then at the end of the
twoyear period it would go back to 60% y
that was the original Bill and then what
they did is then they added the instead
of doing that they added cigarettes and
lose tobacco correct they they took away
the two-year provision they left it at
60% and they added in under the
amendment uh loose tobacco and
cigarettes to get to that 60%
are you all set represent El me yeah I'm
going to have to process the fiscal note
comment and I'm sorry representative Al
you there's not not an updated fiscal
note there should be I mean I understand
you need one probably before you passed
this bill there hasn't been time okay
all right representative browny yes just
to make sure we understand what we're
talking about um first because we we
deal a lot with smoke shops which is not
what we're talking about here yeah cigar
we're talking about Cigar Bar here we're
talking about cigar bars okay because I
saw yador mentioned
here I mean the way I read this is
related from sale of of uh cigar related
products so it's always cigars now we
added cigarettes and
tobacco it wasn't your original bill but
that's was the Compromise the bill it
was a comp that I mean the the chairman
uh the Commerce chairman and I think a
lot of the committee felt that this the
present law was working work they were
willing to look at tweaks but they
didn't think my bill as I had submitted
it originally was the right type of
tweak right and that's the 60% and then
the what's non-tobacco products which is
I would imagine they sell some food and
they sell some alcohol is that correct
is that what we're that's that that's
the part that's been a problem they're
not selling enough food in or selling
too much food or not enough cigars but
too much food
and and uh and alcohol is that an
assumption or no I'm asking the question
is that the problem is that the basic
problem understanding cigar bars their
main purpose was to to sell cigars they
weren't bars as we we know them I'll
admit I don't know if anybody from
Commerce could clarify that or anybody
else here but I think my my their intent
I mean the intent of this amendment is
to increase Revenue tobacco
Revenue uh period as the way they have
amended it I and I'll admit I cannot
answer the question whether Cigar Bar my
understanding is I I'm not sure whether
cigar bars are allowed to sell other
stuff like alcohol their main purpose is
is cigar
bars follow followup yeah so I mean um
my recollection and please others and
Ways and Means help me out here but or
anybody else in the audience is that the
cigar bar is it's a social place you go
you smoke cigars I'm assuming premium
cigars for the most
part um and then but along with that
they're going to sell beverages they're
going to sell probably alcoholic
beverages or other Beverages and some
food but the way we categorize it as a
cigar bar not a
restaurant is by saying well 60% and
this is current law
60% has to be cigars that are sold and
not the other is the way I interpret it
so all this bill does now is it says wow
in that 60% were adding well let him
sell cigarettes and let him sell loose
tobacco uh to help meet that 60%
Target uh and uh I mean is that what you
see or I I think I think so yeah it's a
complicated subject and as I said I have
learned a lot about cigar bars in the
last few months uh and I almost my
prescrition constient was very
persuasive I mean I think the law was
working fairly well but you persuaded me
that we could maybe we should do a few
tweaks of it and you can argue what
tweaks are better than others i s he
suggested and I go went along of one
tweak the Commerce the majority of the
Commerce Committee uh suggested another
tweak okay the constituent by the way
seems he's not here seems to be happy
with it so I mean I I would urge this
committee to pass this bill in some form
but preferably is amended by Commerce
but if you need to add stuff that's fine
too because I think the constituent
wanted the US to be able to increase
revenue from cigar part that was one of
the intense uh you know and I mentioned
that as I said it in my testimony on
January 19th well follow up yeah I mean
the bill before us is the bill amended
by the house so that's the bill we're
dealing with not the original bill first
off and um I guess the question for us
is do we want to add cigarettes and lose
tobacco I'm trying to understand the
motivation how's that going to help it's
I I guess it's going to help them hit
that
60% right I is i that's my understanding
yes and I think not if we don't do this
that some of these are going to go out
of business is is that safe it could I I
mean I'm not I you I would say they
could I mean I I'm not I can't
categorically say if we didn't do this
they such cigar bars would go out of
business but it's possible all right
thank
you I I have a question for us is that
what
percentage have they been have they have
they been
making how far off from the 60% are
they I would I think I don't know
representative State he's my co-sponsor
I don't know if you could help answer
that he he's one of the co-sponsors
would you if I know he has to fill out a
pink card maybe or can come up or I
don't know what the procedure
is all right thank you representative
Stapleton
I I would assume it's a problem
otherwise we wouldn't be filing this
bill so I'm Walt Stapleton a co-sponsor
and uh board three Claremont
representative Sullivan County District
5 um in the last hearing we had uh and
also when I talked to the attorney in
the department relative to that there
were a couple of
concerns um and and the attorney uh s
said that they were having two or
three um of these establishments having
difficulty meeting the threshold of
qualifying uh to continue to qualify for
their license at the
60% so we suggested that they lower the
percent uh to something that would uh
reduce that
barrier um and uh at the same time I
also says why you know you got cigars
but you can't use pipes and pipe tobacco
or cigarettes I mean a smoking
environment uh doesn't matter what
you're smoking and so I think they took
that to heart and decided and I'm sure
they looked at it decided that adding
the cigarettes loose tobacco pipe
tobacco Etc was uh would be enough to
attract the clientele to put the um to
put to enable those two or three with
difficulty to meet the
threshold and that and that's my
understanding of uh you know why they
came to this uh adding the cigarettes
and loose tobacco instead of reducing
the overall qualifying
percentage
okay representative ha hacken Phillips
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representatives for taking my question
I'm just looking at the RSA chapter
178 colon 20-a right now and under
subsection Roman numeral I guess it's
Roman numeral 2 subsection a where it
defines what a cigar bar is um this is
you know the relevant section that
you're attempting to to amend here but
if you drop down to section subsection D
of that same definition it mentions that
the seabar would not allow cigarette
smoking or the sale of food on the
premises so my question is if the intent
is to allow greater C Cigar Bar smoking
to widen that from you know the premium
cigars that we're speaking of to also
include loose tobacco by pipe perhaps or
um cigarettes in this instance um but
it's still not permissible to smoke
cigarettes in a cigar bar um is it
really going to be that much of a help
to increase that Revenue percentage by
also selling cigarettes and loose
tobacco if they're not able to use it in
the
location and that section 178 you say
yep section 178 col 20-a this is the
relevant section for the definition of
what a cigar bar is and that's a
Prohibition it does explicitly say under
subsection D that a cigar bar does not
allow cigarette smoking or the sale of
food on the
premises that may very well be another
section of law that has to be amended to
enable this particular bill to have a
useful effect yeah I would think that if
that was the intent that you would need
additional changes but I would still
recommend um acceptance and passage of
this as a first step and then we go to
make the uh technical correction on 178
on another Bill thank you Mr
chairman representative
Jian followed by represent thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um
it sounds like this mainly developed
during Co um as Co impacted a lot of
establishments and with the rapidly
decreasing numbers I think lately in New
Hampshire they were they were we were
down
to uh maybe about a thou a little over a
thousand Active cases and and less than
100 hospitalizations so with the with
with the Way co is going with the
reopening of of many um establishments
and just ease of op operation is this
bill potentially becoming moot thank you
for the question um I would say no and
the reason is is that Co has really
disrupted our
lifestyles and our usage of outside
establishments for food and
entertainment and now we have uh the
Ukrainian war and gas is going up even
as we speak and heating oil and that's
going to inhibit uh people use of
automobiles for social and pleasure um
usage and so I think this is more
important than ever to keep this to have
this uh allowance on on the bo thank you
represent yle Follow by
represent thank you Mr chair the
question is setting the the threshold to
qualify for a a cigar bar I I'm sit on
the planning board in Hudson we have a a
place called Al Toro in town that move
from one side of the street to the other
side of the street changing you see know
the whole typical BS that goes with uh
relocating your
property his testimony in the planning
board was that the anciliary products to
meet meet his 60% threshold to qualify
as a cigar bar were sold off permit to
the guys going they went in they had
their drinks they had a a sandwich or
something they took their and put it in
the uh uh bourbon so they could have a
nice soft taste to it as I don't know I
don't call the cigar bars but he
explained the whole thing um and that
they needed that extra money or that
extra
percentage so they can get the
qualification under law as represented
hackin Phillips put it out as a cigar
bar so why are we eliminating it would
it not eliminate the cigar bars in their
entirety or am I misreading
this thank you Mr
chair yeah okay representative I I
mean I think there were some problems
with some now whether all cigar
bars uh have been hurt by the pre
present law been
struggling
but I I think this bill just aims to try
to help them I mean with all you know
and that's at least from the perspective
myself and represent of
Stapleton so I mean I cigar bars may
vary I I realize that some cigar
probably are doing better than others
throughout the state depending on where
they're located okay represent El
followed by represent
Nunes thank you I think we've got two
separate problems here one of them is
whether this actually helps and I wanted
to remind those of us who've been on the
committee for a long time time that
there is a cigar bar a
cigar
group very active in talking with us a
number of years ago and that they aren't
here and it might have been useful if
unless you're here for them uh uh to
have their perspective but also we don't
have the Liquor Commission here unless
the woman who I know at the Commerce
Committee representative they someone
from the I believe was some enforcement
people they had some concerns about the
bill as written there there if I could
just finish this uh there are two things
in the fiscal note that are well three
of them that are still valid
uh on but the addition one of them is
their concern about monitoring
additional licenses with the idea that
there would be a lot more cigar bars
which doesn't seem terribly likely
actually uh the other one is that they
worry that
reducing um the percentage of revenue
for that they have to generate from
non-premium cigar sales which
um including the other products in there
would actually do still uh is likely to
reduce tobacco related tax revenue and I
do do not understand that statement at
all but I think we need to learn from
them
both on what they're if they're going to
have think they're going to have
additional costs and whether the pre on
that's a question yes that's a
question uh because this is you're
referring to the fiscal note from the
from the B that is on this Bill yes I'm
trying to interpret it as under the
current
situation I I'm not sure what I can't
speak for the gler commission if they're
not here here I mean I I understand it
does look a little bit strange to be
honest with you rep I would agree with
you and I would say probably I would
suggest you contact somebody from The
Liquor Commission and ask them about it
and maybe yeah I think we have to have
them get their testimony from it if you
are you are concerned as well as of
course we you need it the committee
needs an updated fiscal note which is
very important um as for the trade group
I don't know why they weren't at the
Commerce Committee hearing and they knew
about this bill and I so I can't speak
to it I'm
sorry thank
you thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
for coming to see us today um I I went
back and looked uh last year HB 171
passed that allows for food service
inside a cigar bar but not sales so
that's sort of setups like the Billiards
Halls are where they can sell alcohol
and you can come and play Billiards if
they have so many tables but they'll
allow you to order food to be brought in
uh so that you know if you had a little
bit you can have some food uh but um
having that food service available are
we just saying that we're going to be
opening up smoking restaurants is that
what this is because if you add
cigarettes and you add loose tobacco and
you have cigars and there's food service
Avail available where basically in my
mind saying we're opening up smoking
restaurants uh thank
you okay and thank you representative
for the question is not my intent in
filing this bill to open up a lot of
restaurants to smoking because I think
we had that debate some time ago and I
think we decided that we would ban
smoking in in in restaurants per se but
bars and cigar are sort of was a is a
different category and but my intent was
not to open up food sales in all
restaurants you know just to make that
clear thank you may I continue with that
thought this bill is narrow and focus to
the qualifying to enable the qualifying
for the license for the two or three of
those establishments were close but no
cigar pardon the pun in making the
qualification and as we heard from the
other representative on
178 uh no um cigarettes or or food well
um the food is opened up now and it's
probably a good practice where you're
serving alcohol to uh have some snacks
or food there even insurance companies
recognize that in covering um bars and U
and drram shops and so forth to require
certain amount of availability for food
or snacks but to the point of your
question uh this does not extend and
overlap into uh public areas restaurants
to enable smoking in restaurants
thank thank you um at first on the uh
smoking of
cigarettes uh it's smoking of cigarettes
that's prohibited not the sale of
cigarettes so this has some meaning this
phrase here uh as counting cigarettes
because cigarettes could be sold in a
cigar bar just as long as they're in a
package
yes um thank you um that that is the
enabling part of this to open it up to
the cigarettes and loose tobacco pipe
tobacco as well right but there was some
under some misapprehension I think in
the prior discussion
about uh the prohibition on smoking of
cigarettes that's all it is it's a
Prohibition on smoking not on sale of
cigarettes just to be clear uh and then
I I wonder uh if commer didn't do some
kind of
analysis uh to ACC company their switch
over from a movement from the 60% to the
30% that was in your original Bill to
these uh additional Revenue sources that
would be uh counted into the calculation
and uh you know that would help a lot of
some Anal analysis was done they they
saw a tradeoff apparently and um was
there any math behind
that I I was surprised as representative
cloer was at the outcome from um the
department I would have thought that uh
maybe if they would have considered the
50% or
45% uh then that would have done the
same thing but uh I'm sure they studied
it and uh and maybe realized that they
could attain the same goal with
expanding to cigarettes and pipe tobacco
that's my assumption I can't speak to
that beyond my assumption and an
additional information there was a
proposal one member of the Commerce
Committee wanted to amend the bill to
make it 50% but in the end the rest of
the committee did not want to go along
with that but I think representative you
raay a a you and the other
Representatives have raised serious
points you can would sell this allow the
sale of cigarettes but I guess if you
can't smoke cigarettes in a cigar bar I
don't know I'll admit it doesn't make
much sense to me and I I can't I don't
if anybody from Commerce is here I don't
know what their intent they were
thinking but yeah it's something and
maybe it's not a the a purview of your
committee I know you're dealing more
with Revenue to to deal with this issue
but you know it does uh it's bit
inconsistent just one other comment if I
may follow up it's uh that on liquor is
the other way around you can sell liquor
for consumption on the
premises but you can't sell liquor
otherwise um and now on cigarettes
there's a Prohibition on smoking
cigarettes in the establishment but but
there under current law apparently is no
prohibition on selling
cigarettes you
figure well once again I I think that we
need a technical fix on 178 and any
other place in the law where we conflict
of uh intent against uh current
statutory provision I mean smoke is
smoke if you're going to have a pipe a
cigar or a cigarette you're going to be
breathing smoke um or enjoying smoke
however your outlook is and uh so I
think the bill is valid but we need a
technical fix where there might be some
conflict with other
statute representative spelsbury thank
you Mr chairman um this is confusing
without the clarification of why the
Commerce Committee ultimately did what
they did but from a revenue
perspective isn't uh a pack of
cigarettes taxed at the same amount
regardless of where it's sold and so
wouldn't this be Revenue neutral to the
state uh it's it's it's possible but the
assumption is that more cigarettes would
the sale of cigarettes would increase if
they you're allowed to be sold in cigar
bars I think that's the intent I mean I
um but it's possible that the revenue
could stay the same as you seem to be
implying there could even be an increase
of tobacco tax revenue but I doubt it's
material I I think that um this is
trying to enable a business to make it
in a tough environment and those two or
three having problems with the threshold
it's so it's a business orientation Aid
um as well as providing a place uh where
smokers can congregate to have company
and enjoy what they like to do I gave up
smoking 40 years ago but I understand
the U Affinity to uh wanting to collect
in a in a friendly environment have a
drink have a
smoke okay we have some things to Maul
over to
clarify uh any other questions for these
two because we do have one of the card
represent L quick question or at least I
hope it is so I'm trying to wrap my head
like representative Aly I don't
understand the fiscal note about the
reduction but um in in tax revenue but I
guess my question for you is the goal
here it seems like is pretty simple it's
adding a new Revenue stream that they
could use to get the
60% and in theory if you add new Revenue
there's gross new gross revenue which
changes the percentage under the 40%
that we haven't talked about that they
could sell it increased liquor now
because the the numbers bigger the
percentages are bigger they could sell
more without violating is that the goal
is just to help businesses either
generate more Revenue um and and thus
we're talking about you know especially
loose tobacco and cigarettes and we're
talking about uh liquor that we're also
increasing the revenue on that side as
well for the state is that was that the
goal was has two two components to this
was the purposes and I'm more addressing
because of your your as your committee
what's your is revenue yes so the one of
the goals was to increase the revenue of
course for there are other issues but
goals as well which we talked about in
Commerce so thank you increase Revenue
y represent Aaron thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative cluer for
taking my question so C can you tell me
what was the um
objection to lowering the 60% um
threshold from the Commerce Committee do
do you recall
that I I think one of their concerns
that they and Frank they thought overall
I think the majority of the Commerce
Committee thought the present law was
working uh and I I can't I mean I know
the chairman of the committee was one of
the Prime sponsors of the of the 2009
law and I think he thinks it's working
and I see his point they also didn't
like the fact it was only going to be
for two years it was going to be a
temporary trial uh and I think those are
the main objections that they had to the
bill the way I submitted it the original
version thank you I don't know if that
helps any further questions not thank
you um I'm going to
call Chris Barry from
okay thank you for I can't read it
Association It Was Written in haste I
apologize and are
you testifying in support or opposition
neither Mr chair um so first for
introduction uh my name you're
representing who the cigar Association
of New Hampshire okay so uh good morning
um my name is Curtis Barry I'm here
representing uh a group called The Cigar
Association of New Hampshire which is
primarily uh a group of five owners who
between them have about a dozen retail
cigar shops in the state of New
Hampshire among those four of them have
a cigar bar license out of the roughly
dozen Cigar Bar licenses in the state
and Mr chair hop to provide a little bit
of clarity on at least a couple of
points one of which has been touched on
touched on represent hacken Phillips
representative Ames more recently about
the second part of the statute that's
relevant um but first I'd like to
address representative nunes's uh
question about the service of food just
to make sure we everybody understands um
the previous statute before the the
referen legislation was passed
prohibited the service of food so so a
cigar bar could not simply just put you
know the traditional bar snacks on the
bar and I think represent nunas or
somebody referenced it's a probably a
good idea if you're enjoying an adult
beverage to have something in your
stomach and that was the premise the
legislation changed one word in the
statute it changed service to sale so
the sale of food is prohibited within
the cigar bar but the service of food
free snacks uh is allowed um that was a
very simple change under a very simple
premise
um and now I I'd like to back up to at
the very beginning of the statute the
sort of the philosophy around the
statute um it was put in place under the
understanding that a cigar bar would
first and foremost be a retail cigar
shop you're a shop first and then you
get your bar license not the other way
around and I believe the um the
philosophy at the time was similar to
liquor licenses in establishments that
serve food there was a minimum
requirement that you had to do other
things for a restaurant in order to have
a barer license you have to have a
certain percentage of your um Revenue
stream as food similarly the statute
currently is 60% is the sale of cigars
and humidors and related U items so I
want to make it clear please uh that the
folks that I represent um have no
position on this bill either as amended
by the house proposed by the Commerce
Committee or is introduced um the folks
are operating fine under the under the
current statute um I'm not aware of any
current problems in fact I am aware that
the Liquor Commission can confirm this
um there's a new licy license
application for a cigar bar in Littleton
um so some of them are growing um so I
just had hoped to to provide some some
clarity Mr chair uh and I can answer
questions to the best of my ability but
you know uh the association has no
position on the bill as as currently
before you um I'm not sure that that
would be the case if there were a move
to um eliminate that prohibition on
smoking which was the the the other
piece the the statute is specific um the
exception to the Endor smoking act for
cigar bars is for cigars only currently
in the statute um and you know I'd have
to asked them if they had an opinion if
if there was a move to to eliminate that
prohibition as well so thank you
thank you for your testimony uh
questions representative Bry so from you
U thank you thank you chair thank you
for your testimony glad you're here
actually um so the way I read this is
that this is just a way to get hit help
hit the 60% I mean I I don't see it as
wanting to generate more revenue for the
state or anything like that I don't I
don't see that I mean is is that your
what is your take on this is it really
helping them to hit the 60% and number
one and number two your four clients or
your your
Association is this an issue for them
hitting the 60% to answer the the second
question first no it's not um and the
the the first question my observation
and following the Commerce Committee
proceedings was that that statement is
accurate uh there were a minimum number
of establishments I'm not sure if the
one or two that were at issue are still
in business
um The Liquor Commission would would
have that information
um hitting the 60% again my observing
the the Commerce Committee proceedings
hitting the 60% was the issue and
allowing the sale of other items other
the tobacco type items to count towards
the 60% was the goal I don't recall
Revenue being part of the discussion you
know and I just may not have may not be
recalling it follow up follow up so the
in the four
40% what is what makes up the 40% it's
basically alcohol s yes sir yeah that
that's the balance correct it's nothing
else to your knowledge basically the
alcohol part okay so the liquor
commission's
testimony during either the hearing or a
subcommittee was that sale of other
you've got adult beverages then you have
Cigar and cigar related sale of anything
else counted actually against the 60%
for what it's wor one follow so who
testified from L was it abanian uh it
was Chief armaganian and um there was
another person along with I think the
chief um one of the other enforcement
people I'm okay if you mention a name I
might recall it I'm I'm not sure okay
I'm just trying to figure out who if we
want to ask them who to okay thank
you further
questions say none thank you thank you
nope oh representa El thank you just for
the committee and uh I think it's very
different for your or four who are quite
uh quite heavily into the business and
some of these others that are just
starting up by themselves but um the the
cigar uh retailers make most of their
money I believe on the
internet um I'm not sure I could
characterize each and every one of them
um if I could list the the location
and you know represent you've been on
the committee so you've seen the
information um among the members that I
represent there are locations in seabook
plastow Salem
NASA uh Brookline uh just to the west of
NASA all On the Border uh exit 5 on
93 um hookset so you know I think you
get the picture that you know a great
deal of their sales uh come from out of
state some of them do sell you know for
remote sales um but I know that their
foot traffic from Route
395 93 is quite
robust thank you so New Hampshire
residents of course for most of the
people involved in cigar bars they
aren't uh involved much in internet
sales um I'm not I'm not sure I could
say either way truthfully
thanks any further
questions um representative
Gala um just for clarification they are
allowed to sell cigarettes right now
correct yes oh uh some of the the retail
stores do they sell loose tobacco you
know pipe tobacco just that it's not
counted toward the revenue correct
towards the 60% right one more question
um on the
uh the blurb from the Commerce uh they
said a well it was in the minority
actually um it was stated that The
Liquor Commission claimed that all the
cigar bars were meeting the 60% Revenue
requirement with the exception of
one is that true do you know that's my
recollection of what the Liquor
Commission told the Commerce Committee
okay thank you thank you any further
questions or
comments saying none anybody else wish
to testify for or against House Bill 12
1237 say not I'm closing the hearing on
12:37
okay I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill
1288 and act relative the terms for
certain offices and the names duties and
funds of certain divisions within the
department of administrative
Services the prime
sponsor not
here anybody representing the the
sponsors anybody representing the
executive department and
administration
[Music]
all right um and I do have a pink card
that's for the next
bill Mr chair I introduce House Bill
1288 for your consideration thank you
representative L that card is for the
bill after this oh I have no pink cards
for this bill Mr chair can we have a
little discussion about this
though yes um represent
yly why is this before our committee the
question the if you look
at I got two the bill there's a part in
there that has to do with financial
reportings and the uh which is
responsible for the revenue Focus so I
assume that's
why page page two lines 33 to well 30 to
36 someone thought that we should well
they're talking about changing the the
number from 20,000 to
100,000 Mr not exceed so that's Mr
chair I'm I'm a little confused does a
revolving fund already
exist it does yes it has a cap
so this would then just be a uh cost of
living increase if you would if you will
accept that terminology is is that
correct quite a quite a cost ofing don't
thank you Mr chair I appreciate it it's
probably been around for a while Mr
chairman represent El me I had a
separate question about item four what I
think was no no not about item four uh
where have they put dedicated funds now
that with this reorganization I couldn't
figure out which division it was
supposed to be
under because that's affects us quite a
bit right if if they put it into a
division that
doesn't deal with
this obviously
um and anybody that had anything to do
with this
bill isn't here
today right so there's no concern
anybody
has representative BR so when you when
you look at the two prime sponsors
Maguire and Reagan Senator Reagan uh
probably chairs of uh the committee that
oversee uh Department of ad uh of
administrative
services so to me this was a
housekeeping bill that they submitted it
passed the committee Edna 18 to nothing
and was on the consent calendar the only
thing I think before we act on it we
just have to understand why they want to
increase to 20,000 to 100,000 and we we
have to find somebody who can answer
that for us I think thank
you Mr chairman representative Aly I
want to know what they've done with
dedicated funds and whether they were
thinking about it but on before we pass
it but also on I think yeah I I went and
last night and I looked up the RSA for
what that fund is supposed to do could I
read off
what what um they're training they're
they're supposed yes to do um they
charge fees for this and that's why it's
revolving but uh Municipal and state
staff training training materials for
those uh a program for certified public
managers within state
government and uh and yeah that's it but
that's quite a lot of people that
they're talking about that need to be
trained and um we' we'd want to know how
much is being lapsed every year because
they laps at the end of the year uh I
think it's at the end of the year they
lapse the
money so um they would
not they would be operating on 20,000 a
year to do all of that
training I did not receive a call
from the committee or represent Maguire
or Senator
Reagan uh normal procedure is if the
bill is
important they would at least let the
chairman of the committee know what's
going on so I will hold this
bill and we not do not hear then
probably take no
action so I'm not going to guess what
they want to do
yeah so is anybody here to testify on
House Bill
1288 and I'm closing the public hearing
on
so so if the clerk was so not
noticed there's nobody here to
testify did get in introduced by
representative
lion are we have to wait six minutes
before we can open the next
bill
yes and while we're waiting this
afternoon we're going to be hearing
House Bill 1598 which is the marijuana
bill we we will be joined by three
members of the finance
committee and represented hunt who
chairs the Commerce
Committee has an executive session going
on and then he then he will join us
because the part that we're interested
in on that bill only because the policy
has already been set is the banking part
and the revenue
issues not the policy because the policy
has been approved by the Full House to
to one so
so I can't hear
you I looked at the testimony that the
um police Chiefs Association sent us yes
and
I I thought most of that had to do with
policy so since I presumably the police
Chiefs know what they're doing and I
don't know what I'm doing so maybe you
could or have
someone on the
committee explain really what the
difference is that is appropriate for us
to be considering that's Revenue versus
policy maybe my maybe my understanding
isn't correct as to what policy is but
did you look at the material that the
police chief sent us I took took a look
at what they Prov graphs and yeah I took
a look at what they provided there is
some uh in there relative to the revenue
and that but but a lot of it was all
that has all that that has to do with
policy we're not considering good
because it's already been passed and
will you interrupt people who are
testifying and say that
because it is hard to remember that we
just I will remember them thank
you Mr chair I will let them
know represent
Aly thank you I think we all also should
be looking at costs because the revenue
has to be net from our
perspective net of net of the costs of
administration of this program that is
correct that's why on what the police
she sent to us has has an awful lot to
do with with cost
all I figur but anything that has to do
with revenues and costs that's why we're
having three people from the uh
committee sit on this us
Mr representative Lang over here
representative Lang so I'm assuming
we're going to be focusing around page
eight when we're talking about the
Cannabis control fund and all of the
funds because this is you know I always
I always look at Ways and Means as the
taxes fees and funds committee yes um
and so we'll be looking at that fund and
and how that how that fun is be fund is
being administered and how it's being
controlled correct thank you anything to
do with funds
revenues we will look at the policies
been set thank you Mr chair Mr chair
repr
jie does that include making money off
of arresting people yes all right that
was wise crack so Mr chair yes Brown I I
spoke to the lobbyist for the police
Chiefs I just ran into her in the
hallway yesterday when I was here and
that they aware that they what their
focus has to be I reminded them so they
know uh
and as far as I think I mentioned some
of you earlier that I I I've been in
communication with the Liquor Commission
and I said you know we need to see the
other half in the fiscal note we only
have one half we have what their
estimates of what it's going to cost to
run the stores but I asked them well
what's your estimates of how much
revenue you're going to produce so that
we can get the net because we're talking
about the net here the Net's what what
goes into the fund it's it's the it's
just like the liquor model so they're
going to come in today with uh with
their best
gu estimate of that so um they were
going to try to do it ahead of time but
they were still fine-tuning it so it'll
be handed out when we're in the meeting
methodology methodology yes we were
hoping to have it by yesterday
but it's not here
yet
we still got three
minutes two more
minutes so we have someone to testify
ask
okay
thanks
yeah i' I'd just like to point out that
this is within our fund
mandate that we're just looking at it as
a dedicated fund that I presume that's
why we got
it okay I would
assume thank
you
it's close enough
right
okay then
10:30 I'm going to open the hearing on
House Bill 1339 relative to the winaki
River Basin control replacement
fund uh I have no pink card so represent
a line
Mr chair I give you a house bill 1339
for as introduced and we have somebody
here from the wiip saki Basin Authority
who will be happy to testify about the
Bill thank you representa
lion if there is somebody here have you
filled out a pink
card oh thank you
so we have Wesley Anderson and
Sharon McMillan turn your microphone on
and then move it to the
okay and Shannon McMillan from the dees
correct
sir and Wesley Anderson
represents the wiip River Basin
Advisory Board
okay
okay closer that closer got it that
better that's much better now who's
going to go first I will okay Mr
Anderson my name is Wesley Anderson and
I'm the chairman of the Win basaki River
Basin Advisory Board the board consists
of 10 municipalities and organizations
that send their sewage to the programs
Regal sewage treatment plant in Franklin
the regional collection system and the
treatment plant is operated by New
Hampshire's Department of Environmental
Services The Advisory board's main
function is to review the capital
Improvement program review the contracts
to plan design and construct Capital
Improvements that require approval by
the governor and executive Council and
review the program's budget the 10
member communities pay all costs
associated with the operations and
maintenance of the system there have
been no major changes to the uh excuse
me the only state funds the program
receives are from Grants and loans that
the sewage treatment can receive such as
any other sewage treatment plant there
have been no major changes to the
system's operations cost distribution
plan since the 1980s when the system
began operations the board its member
communities and the program
administrator have been working for
several years on changes to the funding
model so that more closely represents
current usage of the system by the
member communities and its organizations
this is necessary as the actual
Municipal growth do not align with the
predictions that were made back in 1980s
the water consumption changes due to the
more efficient fixtures in buildings and
maintenance of the municipality system
itself the member communities are buil
to support cost four excuse me four cost
functions the methods for updating the
distribution of costs for three of the
four functions can be updated without
any changes to existing laws the fourth
the replacement fund can only be updated
by the legislature the replacement fund
is the account that department
environmental services uses to fund the
cost of repairs for unanticipated
failures that cost more than can be
funded from the operations and
maintenance account but yet is not
costly enough to bond to fund the
repairs presently the cost of repairs
funded through the replacement fund are
distributed to member communities based
on their use of the portion of the
system that failed the impacted
municipalities are required to pay back
the fund for the cost of those repairs
over 10 years the proposed change
approved by the member communities will
have the impacted communities paying 50%
of the cost of the repairs and 50% of
the cost of repairs will be distributed
to all 10 member communities based on
their respective use of the
infrastructure all other aspects of the
existing law are unchanged except for
some clarifying language regarding the
proportional assessment of the fund that
was identified by the Attorney General's
office during their review of the draft
leg legislation their member communities
ask for your support to change the
existing law on the wiip saki River
Basin programs replacement fund thank
you for considering our
request thank you for your testimony Mr
Anderson
now did you want to testify before we
ask questions sir I'm just here my name
is Sharon McMillan I'm the uh
environmental program administer for the
wiip pasak River Basin program uh in
Water Division Department of
Environmental Services I'm really here
to answer any questions the committee
members may have not to offer testimony
oh thank you questions from the
committee representative brahney this is
really a question but you said it and
I'll make sure all 10 of these
communities have agreed to this language
is that
correct it's of the 10 member
communities uh eight have agreed to the
language two disagree uh but the
basically the way The Advisory board set
up it's a majority of the Quorum which
is six and so we had eight that favored
the vote so eight of the 10 do agree
with this change uh can you can you
follow up follow up can you explain why
the two have exception to this
change uh personal opinion in one case
and I don't want to go from that
standpoint the other is very close to
the be where the plant comes into the
system so it increase their costs a bit
more okay the other one is is personal
guess I'm not willing to all right but
when but must follow but when they but
but when they entered this agreement
they understood that this was a majority
roote changes correct okay thank
you Mr
chair thank you so my community samton
is one of the towns that use your use
this uh program and as I understand this
bill what it's going to do is it looks
like if you have a breakdown basically
of the system and it affects one
Community only or or a portion of you
know only a segment of the pipeline so
to speak um that that cost of repair
will now be borne by anybody Downstream
of that repair as well as um the other
uh 50% is born by Downstream the other
50% will be born by all 10 Towns as a
maintenance of the system as a whole is
that General concept conceptually you're
close so for a repair on a certain
portion of the line 50% of that cost
will go to all the municipalities based
off a respective distribution plan the
other 50% of the cost goes to the
impacted
communities uh the best example I can
give you was a recent one that happened
in lonier and Guilford where a force
main broke only two communities were
impacted by it Guilford and lonia
Guilford had 90% of the flow through it
so they're paying 90% of the costs and
lone had 10% so in that case 50% of it
would be distributed 90% to Guilford 10%
to lonia and the other 50% would be
distributed among all the communities
based off our respective formula thank
you very much further
questions represent BR so we're talking
sewage here right right so so the do the
communities pay or is it is it uh
allocated through the sewer bills the
bills who gets billed for this are
I it really varies between the
communities I can say the bill comes to
the community or in one case it's a it's
a sewer district and then that Community
has the option of how they build it to
their customers in the case of lonia
which I'm most familiar with it's a it's
basically a sewer charge based off water
consumption okay all right thank
you represent Aly thank you is is the
city of Franklin in this District yes it
is it is okay uh it's I can give you a
fast list of the
communities I
got want to make sure Bay District
that's Molton burrow Center Harbor area
Belmont Franklin Guilford Laconia
Meredith Northfield sand Borton uh
Department of administrative Services
because they have the Lakes uh region
property the old former school and
Tilton those are the member community
ities and
organizations further
questions oh that's pretty
easy I see no further questions thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you anybody else wish to testify for or
against House Bill
1339 seeing none I'm closing the public
hearing on House Bill
1339 now let
me
explain the rest of the
day we have scheduled at 11 o'clock
hearing on House Bill
FN establishing Capital Improvement
grant program for the benefit of state
fairs and agricultural
affirs I've received a call from the
Commissioner of Agriculture Sean
Jasper he will not be here this week
because he's uh scheduled place other
places the prime sponsor uh which is
represented lad lad recck lad he's not
available this week they asked if they
could put this off so when the time
comes at
11:00 I will open this and reassess
it um
and and reconvene
[Music]
it Mr chair next
week I believe representative the Pearl
the chairman of Agriculture environment
is planning on being here for that bill
oh he is yes he he just messaged me and
asked me if it was going to be on time
for 11:00 and I said yes okay then uh we
will because uh I'm honoring the request
for both representative lad and the
commissioner so we can hear what per uh
representative
Pearl has to say and then uh then you're
going to recess the B and then I'll
recess it until next
week so if you want to be here at 11:
I'll take just a couple of us to open
it and so then you would really be off
until 1:00 when we have the marijuana
bill or I should say house bill for
Okay
so
let me take a straw
pole you
heard
you heard the testimony from
the on
1339 relative to the wiip pasak River
Basin Advisory
Board there's nobody here to oppose it
uh so I'm going to ask
you who would be in
favor of
executing the bill now as ought to pass
if you if so raise your hand I think
this I
think raising okay everybody's in favor
of
it so uh
then I will go into executive session on
House Bill you want to get um we have
one representative who was here Mr chair
there's just a few Representatives that
stepped out I or just one Edith Tucker I
think stepped out should we wait for her
to return she was pulled out by Finance
she's probably down the hall oh
okay you want to see if we can get her
she wants
to no why don't you give I'm gonna try
to
get you go down the
this will take care of one of
them
and what is
this
oh
of
okay
oh
um it's been introduced and we've had a
discussion and I took a straw poll and
um people that were here indicated that
it's fine with them it should ought to
pass and
so did you Mr
chair okay so we're all
set Mr chair be recognized for a
motion I open the executive session
and on House Bill 1339 and represent L
Mr J I move a to pass on House Bill 1339
represent L second moves a to pass on
1339 who second it represent Al
Aly I would like to make a request
though can we ask maybe it's too late if
they had any problems they wanted to
discuss
it's too late too
late there any other issues then go to
the
Senate um any further
discussion on house belt
1339 represent Lang want to address this
motion I I think I I don't I think we
heard everything we need to hear I think
the motion's clear so I'm all set the
vote any further
discussion hearing no further discussion
I'll ask the clerk to call the vote
thank you Mr chair the bill is House
Bill 1339 the motion is ought to pass we
will begin the voting with
representative abami
yes representative olry yes
representative duet yes representative
Lang yes the clerk votes yes
representative janigian yes yes
representative Nunes yes representative
spillsbury
yes representative tutor yes
representative Aaron yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames
yes Southworth is not here Maloy is not
here shamberg is not here representative
Tucker yes representative garlo
yes lofman is not here gorg is not here
representative hacken Phillips
yes representative Murphy yes chairman
major yes this was a real
nailbiter
17 the vote been 17 to zero the motion
of ought to pass
passes and without objection go on
consent I see no objection so appear on
the consent calendar
we still got 12
minutes right we still have 11 to 12
minutes just a
comment this particular bill was a good
example of why New Hampshire is
considered to be a Dyan R
estate if it
were like the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts the towns could have just
done this themselves but since we're a
state like we are it has to come
here
right
okay listen
closer
[Music]
saying your
microphone right you know people
actually are watching the streaming I
have people's mentioning to me that they
have heard me speak or that they watched
Ways and Means so so when we're I can
see the little blue light is on the that
camera and so thank you representative I
appreciate the REM uh reminder thank
you
e
okay I'm going to open
the hearing on houseu 1584
dfn establishing a capital Improvement
grant program for the benefit of state
fairs and agricultural fairs and
representative Howard Pearl is going to
introduce the bill good morning members
of the waying mean committee for the
record my name is representative Howard
Pearl I from Lowden representing miramac
26 which includes the towns of Lowden
Canterbury bosin Northfield and Ward 3
of
Franklin I am not the prime sponsor on
this bill representative lad is but he's
not able to attend today so I'm going to
uh give you just a brief introduction I
am a
co-sponsor uh I'm also the chair of the
environment and agriculture committee
and we had this as a first bill and uh
there since there's a money component it
was sent two ways and means and you
folks of the second committee on it but
from a policy standpoint the members of
the environment and a the majority of
the members on environment and
agricultural committee supported the
passage of this bill just as a policy
that it was a good idea for the State of
New Hampshire to support its
agricultural Affairs for a a few reasons
because there's a a strong educational
and economic impact to that these 13
fairs bring to the state of New
Hampshire they uh they these fairs had
passed uh support and they lost it in
the late 70s and it was tied to the
paramutual racing at the time that was
occurring down in Salem and when that um
industry kind of went by the wayside the
funding mechanism for the support for
these fairs did as well and they're
they've U some of really suffered since
then they they have a lot of
infrastructure needs that they're trying
to address and some of the fairs are
doing well and some are not so the what
was presented to us was a a grant
process that they would put in place to
that the commissioner would oversee
Commissioner of Agriculture excuse me
would oversee and they would uh figure
out a way you know in rules to uh to put
together a program that would be able to
assist the uh the members of these these
different Affairs that needed within
their Community there's some specific on
it uh it has to relate to infrastructure
and I apologize I don't have the number
right in front of me I believe it's a
$250,000 amount that they were looking
for so that's kind of what I wanted to
come up cover was just come in and uh
and support the bill from the uh
majority position of the environment and
agricultural committee and you'll um
you'll get a lot more background
information from uh representative lad
and commissioner Jasper when they are
able to address the committee on U many
things they they're much more historians
in this area than I
that's all I'll have for you today and
I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you for your testimony
representative Pearl uh representative
Bry so thank you Mr chair thank you uh
representative Pearl so so just bill
does two things it creates the fund
which is really ways it means and then
then it spends then it there's an Ask of
250,000 a year it looks like from the
general fund to be transferred into it
uh but in addition to that is was it
anticipated that other grants and other
sources of revenue would also flow into
this fund not that I'm aware of but I
think honestly that'd be a better
question for commissioner Jasper he's
kind of this was more of his bill and
and representative lad was working with
him on it okay I don't recall that as in
testimony in front of our committee but
I ask you to put that question to okay
thank you you're welcome thank you
represent
elme thank you Mr chair chairman on
represent Pearl do uh do you have some
thought
on uh two questions that had come up in
your committee I was subbing that day uh
one of them was that oh This only
affects the town that the fair is in and
the town ought to be paying the cost of
this uh and whether that would really be
true in terms of the economic impact of
the fair
uh on New Hampshire and then I'd like to
ask the second one
separately okay I'll respond to the
first one thank you for the question so
my understanding from testimony received
that these fairs really have a regional
impact much greater than just the actual
town that they reside in and they
certainly do a lot in hosting um
agricultur related um events outside of
the actual Fair itself for uh 4 and um
FF F but I believe it was mostly 4
events that many of these
Fairgrounds assist in hosting events and
in several leine events I know like in
the situation with Deerfield Fair they
have regular ecoin events that occur
there so they they serve a greater
purpose within the agricultural
Community certainly on a maybe not a
year round basis but the the months that
it's appropriate to be there on site
does that answer your first part yes
okay and the second one was about on the
possibility of a revolving
fund so that it could be onetime money
and maybe come from
ARA I I know we did have that discussion
uh quite honestly I tried to keep our
committee from staying out of the
finance side of it as much as possible
and stay more on the policy portion of
it knowing that it was at the time it
was going to either you or Finance I
wasn't sure at the time and we had
requested it come to Ways and Means and
and the speaker was kind enough to Grant
it so I guess you've you've got this
bill upon my request and and uh I hope
you'll do good things with
it thank you further questions of
Representative Pearl represent J thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
Pearl for taking my question um you
mentioned that um some of the fair
grounds or fairs are doing fine but
others may need help um why why is it
that some need help what are the ones
that don't need help doing what is the
difference between the two sure that's a
great question I don't know that I can
answer that with any specificity only
basically my observations from attending
these fairs uh certainly location is is
one part of it the the the further south
that the fair is the the more access it
has to the markets of people you know U
folks will come across from Boston
perhaps and go to Deerfield or or
Southern New Hampshire more than they
would drive to Lancaster or or Cornish
and and the size of the fair as well
some of these fairs are much larger than
than others and are able to you know
offer more in the Midway and and things
like that different attractions that
would bring people in so ticket sales
are certainly a big part of
it representative Bry just thinking here
so is is the purpose of the fund to help
it's Capital Improvement projects is
that pretty much where it's not supposed
to offset operating losses but to help
them keep the barns up or whatever else
that's correct that my
yes thank
you further
questions represent
gal does this include county fairs I'm
assuming it does but don't want to so
this was targeted to the 13 fairs that
were specifically part of I apologize I
don't have the language right in front
of me that were part of the New
Hampshire fairs Association if I
remember correctly and um they are
there's there are 13 that were
registered with them I guess I don't
know if you'd call them a county fair or
a state fair and we we into the little
bit of that terminology ourself but it's
specifically for those fairs that are
registered with the state fairs
Association you're
welcome representative alme that gives
me another question how do we find the
county fairs Association I the the sorry
the the New Hampshire fairs
Association that would be a great
question for commissioner Jasper and I'm
certain he'd be able to to provide that
for you I I believe that I I believe
that falls under his purview under the
Department of Agriculture but he could
certainly provide that for
you thank you Mr chair I'd like to
suggest that well maybe I should do it
uh try to call him up and get him to get
someone to come to talk about it because
the commissioner didn't seem to know
much about some of not quite a few of
the
fairs at least at the one I was
at okay um further question
representative L just to answer
representative alies it's New Hampshire
fairs.com is the website and that covers
the New Hampshire farm and forest garden
expo the stratum Fair the north hail
Fair the Cheshire Fair the bellnap
county 4 Fair the Cornish Fair the
Lancaster Fair the hopkington fair the
Hillsboro County Agricultural Fair the
Granite State Fair the Deerfield fair
and the Sandwich Fair are all the fairs
that are covered on underneath that
right
now I'm
sorry uh I don't see that one on here
North ail oh I'm sorry North April sorry
I missed that
one further
questions saying none thank you
representative bro thank you appreciate
your
time I have one pink card uh from Cheryl
is that pu
or hi I'll introduce myself my name is
Sher Duty I'm a state representative
from Nashville ward 3 Hillsboro 30 and
you're testifying in opposition and I am
right okay and I will hold this up
because if I put on my reading glasses
they'll kind of fog up so
uh I am here today to speak against HB
FN although I support the intent of this
bill which is to modernize and improve
the infrastructure of regional
agricultural Fairgrounds I disagree with
the idea that taxpayer dollars should be
taken from the general fund to support
the private nonprofit organizations that
run them as a member of the environment
and agricultural committee since 2019 I
have witnessed many good programs die
due to lack of funding a bill to support
an animal abuse fund was voted down
because it would have increased dog
licensing fees by 50 Cents a year it was
deemed a tax by my colleagues across the
aisle in New Hampshire right now we have
a recycling municipal waste crisis after
Decades of defunding New Hampshire Dees
we have a waste management plan that
hasn't been updated since
2003 we have not met recycling goals
that were set for
1995 we lag all the other New England
states in this area New Hampshire Dees
is funded through the same Source the
general fund as the request for hb1 1584
FN without the necessary funds to create
plans and staff for implementation and
oversight in a vital area like Solid
Waste Management and
recycling how can we justify taking
$250,000 a year for Capital Improvements
to Regional fairs that attract only a
small portion of the
population right now I am trying to find
$380,000 to fund a one-time setup of a
testing program for CBD
labeling this bill has passed both the
house and Senate but without funding it
will go nowhere improper CBD labeling
due to no oversight or testing in New
Hampshire cost consumers thousands of
dollars uh yes what is your point of
order have we gotten off of this bill
onto another bill Mr chairman I've been
wondering
myself I'm
sorry his question have we gotten off
from this Bill H House Bill
1584 one of the things is that the
policy has been decided by the
environment and agricultureal committee
and we're dealing with the revenue
aspect of
it so correct if you uh and and my and
keep your testimony okay and my point
being is that in the past funding has
not been
appropriated for bills that have been
passed um that uh are
effective e effective for a vast
majority of the people I'll conclude
with 13 Regional fairs and a
$250,000 annual request this amounts to
less than $220,000 in Capital
Improvements per Fair per year if the
economic IC benefit to a region hosting
the fair is so great as the sponsor has
indicated then businesses in the area
should be able to raise that amount of
money for their own benefit thank
you thank you for your testimony
representative um would you have a copy
of that you leave with the committee and
I can uh the clerk sure I'll I'll hand
it to you thank you uh question
representative Abney
so thank you for your testimony so my
sense is that you're not necessarily
against the 250 but it wouldn't be your
top priority in terms of other
expenditures that you feel are more uh
important than this is that did I say
that right yeah I think that's fair to
say I mean if we're if if there are
other needs greater needs that uh Solid
Waste
Management um you know consumer
protection and those are not priorities
why should we make this
$250,000 which is an annual
request okay um you know I've been
looking for money for a one-time request
and we can't find it um so I would say
why would we want to make this a
priority now I you know I I
recognize you know I recognize that
there's always trade-offs and we have to
you know there there there's pros and
cons um
but I think you know we we need to look
at this in total uh you have 13
fairs uh we were the testimony that came
before our committee was strongly
slanted towards the economic Boon that
that these um fairs are to the region
and I guess you know as a for former
businesswoman I would say uh if it's
such an economic boom then why wouldn't
the business businesses in the area uh
want to uh contribute and I mean really
when you think about it $20,000 less
than $2,000 a year uh to support a fair
that is an economic boom to your area it
doesn't seem to me that that's that
unreasonable to a ask for business from
businesses and B to look for Grants um
as a chair of the Nashville Conservation
Commission I've been doing a lot of
exploration
lately on what Grant programs are out
there um you know to help our um city
and there's a lot of them out there but
it's a lot of work you know you um
there's there's no one place you can go
to and say oh here's all the money you
know that you want you have to find the
grants you have to uh recognize what
their qualifications are you have to you
know match that up with what what you
want it is a lot of work but the money
you know is out there and I question
whether or not these associate you maybe
what the association should do is in
terms of instead of operating as 13
individual maybe they should come
together look at Grants um that they
might be able to apply for so they don't
have to come um and and request money
for the general
fund further
questions represent lion thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I I guess my question stems
around the finance side of this
conversation when I talk about Finance I
don't mean the 250,000 I talk about the
overall impact to the state of New
Hampshire just in my quick calculations
while while you were talking I was
looking about attendance it looks like
between these 12 fairs we have over a
half a million people have attended
these fairs and do you think that does
that that doesn't have an impact in the
Hampshire as a whole through either our
tax revenues through bringing tourism um
and and and helping our state you know
as a as a destination right to go let's
go and hang out the Hopkin Fair let's go
hang out the Deerfield Fair the the
North havil Fair it's funny I was
reading about 1983 report for the uh
Sandwich Fair and it says 3,000 people
attended there was very little
drunkenness in uh that happened so I
guess it goes all the way back to 198
1893 and and we have a a long history in
New Hampshire of supporting these fairs
and and and and encouraging these fairs
and I guess my question goes around is
as we look at this as a big picture for
namp
right do you not think that these that
that supporting these kind of programs
that bring tourism and bring you know
increased revenues to to the spending
you know consumer spending is isn't that
important for us to
consider uh representative Lang I think
you've underscored my point and that is
is if it brings such an economic Boon to
the state of New Hampshire then maybe
then then the businesses that profit
from that economic boom should be
putting some skin in the game also I
mean you know aren't there isn't there
money that comes from the tourism are
there grants available through the
Department of Tourism that we already
fund that might be available for this
all I'm saying is is this really
something that the general fund a fund
that over the decades has defunded New
Hampshire Dees that affects everybody in
this state okay uh is this something
that the general that we should be
funding through the general
fund and I think you know that's
something I can't I can't make that
decision that's I believe Ways and Means
from what I
understand further questions represent
elmy thank you uh I think I agree with
you with the general fund that doesn't
mean that the state having a lot of
extra cash at the moment couldn't help
on this on one time on
would
you agree that
Nashua and on other fairs that are close
to the Massachusetts
border uh and very large in size
themselves would have an easier time of
financing their Fair including their
businesses would have a very much easier
time financing their Affair than um
North haal or or even Laconia which is a
tourist Mecca I think for longer periods
than North hav all
is well nsha doesn't have a fair and we
I mean we don't have a regional fair I
think the closest one may be Deerfield
but yes representative all we I I mean I
agree with you and you know and and to
be fair I don't
have you know I live in Nashua so I
don't have a
good um a a lot of experience with the
difficulty in
funding um things you know in the rural
areas and and I would certainly you know
look to my fellow representatives to
provide me with that that understanding
I mean that that's clear and you know if
we have a lot of money at this point in
time and we can ask allocate that to
Capital Improvements so that it's a
better experience for people in New
Hampshire you know I don't think that's
an issue I guess the issue that I have
is that making this an annual a um an
annual grant that comes from the the
general
fund you know I I guess maybe we can
rethink you know maybe this is a time to
rethink the whole
thing
saying no further question I thank you
for your testimony okay thank you
anybody else wish to testify for or
against House Bill
dfn not I'm closing the hearing on
1584 and we will
be you're recessing I'm I'm I'm sorry
I'm recessing the hearing on
1584 until next week on
Wednesday at
11:30
okay we're all set until 1:00 when we do
the house bill 1598 the marijuana
bill
all I know is a stratum because I'm one
of those fairs I guess my
town we have warrant articles fix the
fix the barn for the fair we pay for we
pay for it I don't know I don't it's a
lot of it's 250,000 every yearo it's
going to
be it's really a finance this really a
finance it is they have to decide we
gonna We have to stick with
the the ring part I guess the only part
ring was the
250 oh I have a feeling mu is here from
me
you I've got your the excerpts from the
record and stuff together but do you
want me to hold off for for next week or
did you want me to go ahead and P that
together for today no
I very
good
than
e
for
okay I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill 1598 dfn an act legalizing The
Possession and use of
cannabis um representative abbis is
going to introduce the bill then step
aside for his one of his colleagues that
needs to go an executive Bill representa
abis good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the weights and Means Committee thank
you for having me I'm uh I represent
Rockingham County District 8 and I'm
here to introduce uh House Bill 1598 and
I will step aside to let my colleague
offer some
testimony oh yes okay thank representa
abis and we'll call you back in just
about two
minutes uh next is representative Max
abson from Rockham 37 in support of the
bill uh thank you Mr chair members of
the committee uh representing the towns
of Hampton Hampton Falls and Seabrook um
I did um I'm here in support of the bill
um although we did try to table the bill
and and send it back to committee um I
did go through the bill again and even
talked with legislative services and a
number of other people it is definitely
a compromised bill um and I uh disagreed
with with quite a few parts of it of the
bill legalizing um I agree with the
legalizing personal amounts um that Rel
legalizing marijuana makes sense because
we've had so many we've spent so much
time on medical marijuana already um but
I having gone through the bill I think
that it overall is is a a step in the
right direction so hold on one second I
forgot to
mention this hearing is ass soci is on
House Bill
1598 but not on the policy the policy
was set at Full House they voted out two
to two to one and we're here today to
look at the revenue and the
appropriation piece of this so if you
stick to the remarks dealing with those
two things thank you right so that that
was exactly what I was about to say say
but much better than I could have said
it um so on the the revenue question
there's a the the question is how active
should the state be involved in the sale
and the administration of uh of this
program if the committee is to amend it
um uh you do cover the structure of the
revenue portion of this so I would ask
that uh if if the committee is willing
to amend the bill to amend the bill to
reduce the state's involvement and and
prefer Private Sales rather than State
involvement um and with that I I I would
like to take questions but I'd have to
take them by email because I have an
executive session in a few minutes thank
you thank you represent a representative
abis the floor is now yours and
concentrate on the revenue and the
appropriation thank you Mr
chairman so if you if the fiscal note in
HB
1598 there it was indeterminable what
the re actual Revenue could be where
some of the numbers I I use to just kind
of come up with a ballpark was I
referred to HB
237 which was a bill that involved
recreational Canabis as well uh it would
have entailed a 5% transfer tax and a
14% uh uh excuse me a 9% sales tax and a
5% transfer tax I do have a print out of
that fiscal note I can hand out to the
committee if the members wish to take a
look at it and that was a bill that the
criminal justice Public Safety Committee
had in uh before the committee this term
as well
okay Jennifer could you help
out and some of some of the estimates
inside that fiscal note included the
gross uh market
sales and what I what I found very odd
about the not odd but unique I guess
is the gross legal sales was going to be
a
gross illegal sales can be $311 million
that was the high high range estimate so
as you see that a large portion of the
market share could have been lost to the
illegal sales I believe with this bill
would do when you say the gross sales of
$360 million
that's not the profit is it it it is not
the the point that I was making is that
a large market share is lost to to an
illegal Market about 40 to
45% and that has to do with how the
revenue is is uh made by the states that
have allowed this and one of the
problems that you've constantly seen is
the over Taxation and overregulation
what I believe 1598 does is that it
doesn't actually have any tax and you
can actually what would be done it would
model exactly how revenue is made
similar to that of liquor where the
state is not taxing the sale of liquor
the revenues made off the retail sale
itself the advantage with cannabis on is
that the markup is much higher on
cannabis than it is with liquor so there
is a chance to have a competit stay
competitive with the illegal Market but
also SE make a lot more Revenue than
what the 14% tax would have done done
the anticipated revenue from the sales
tax and transfer tax version on a low
point was 14 $14.4 million on a high
point was $36 million so that comes to
an uh an average you in the middle is
about $25 million and I don't believe
that that was a win for the state I
believe under this proposal if you
considered what the markup is on the
wholesale price it would be seven eight
times the amount of potential revenue
for the state also hb2 237 did not take
into consideration a significant out of
state market share the liquor
sales on average is about 40 to 50% out
of state so whatever numbers these
estimates come to is is actually very
conservative considering the a ofate
market is not really being Tak into
consideration with those figures the
retail industry Beyond just cannabis
in New Hampshire thrives on oate
consumers coming to this state to
purchase products to avoid a sales
tax so there's no reason why we
shouldn't consider those Market
principles in the with the Cannabis
industry the reason why I would oppose
any type of actual sales tax or taxation
on cannabis is I feel that
would create a situation where the
illegal Market would continue to Excel
and you've seen a lot of states have
made that is made that problem for
themselves so I I would not support
going down that same
path as what to do with all that
Revenue uh it was my anticipation that
any of the revenue earned one any money
that was drawn from the general fund to
help facilitate this program should be
repaid essentially the state would be
taking a tax-free loan from the New
Hampshire taxpayer and I think the right
thing to do would be first to pay that
back but as to do with the net
revenue the first $25 million dollars
would go towards drug abuse uh alcohol
abuse treatment any type of substance
abuse treatment also mental health
treatment that's related to substance
abuse uh in my line in my uh line of
work I interact with a lot of
individuals who suffer from substance
abuse issues and many of my clients
without getting into the
specifics uh suffer from untreated
mental health issues that I often
contribute to what leads them down on
that path to substance abuse so
investing the first $25 million in net
revenue to help address that in our
state I thought was the very important
thing to do after that the uh 90% of of
the net revenue would offset the
Statewide education property tax I when
I talk to constituents both in my
district and then people throughout the
state the two biggest complaints I hear
are energy costs and property
taxes although this doesn't address the
energy
issue this is this is addressing the
property tax issue there's only so much
we can do with the state level the
property tax rate is often set at the
local level same with the local
education tax very limited what we can
do with the county this is a real
opportunity for us together to actually
address the Statewide property tax issue
and deliver that relief for the people
in New Hampshire and I felt that if the
state's going to get into this industry
and
and get into the retail side of it my
thought was that we should try to use
that revenue and give it back to the
people and this is one of the ways to do
that and I've heard a lot of people talk
about property tax relief I've been
hearing it since I was a
child and now I have children of my own
and I no one this is our chance to
actually do it and deliver on it it's
not it's not just one person we have to
do it together so I think this puts us
in a very good position to do that
as for some of the
expenditures one of the issues that I
would point out is the advertising
expenditure was listed as a million
dollars I would hope that the
advertising for cannabis would be
relative restrictive uh when you drive
through Massachusetts you see these
bright Billboards promoting
cannabis I I think we don't really need
that in this state I think the consumers
are smart enough to know where to find
it if they're looking for it if they're
coming here they'll know I'm sure we'll
get media coverage but we don't need to
spend a million dollars on that so uh
part of the appropriation that's set one
big portion of there's about $7 million
of that would be actually for the
inventory cost to start up the retail
side so I believe that's an important uh
that's a kind of a going to be an
expenditure that's continues but it's at
the same time when as you're earning
Revenue you can always uh you'll have to
replace your inventory in respect to
some of the other uh expenditures I know
there's been a lot of conversations
about the potential for a State chared
Bank the philosophy of that provision is
and the way I I read the the language is
that the Private Industry will have
every opportunity to address the banking
needs of both the state as well as the
private cultivators the private
manufacturers and the private testing
facilities however if a private
institution is unable ble to fulfill the
needs of the state the the second option
the plan B as I call it would be the
state Chartered Bank uh from what I've
heard and conversations I've had with
many people that there's financial
institutions that are available that are
willing to to uh accommodate the state's
needs so I don't see Plan B being a
problem but I don't understand why we
wouldn't want a backup plan we don't
want this being a cash industry we keep
talking about the revenue revenue
revenue I mean do want to keep it in a
in a a lock box or a
safe that that doesn't seem that doesn't
seem how it should be done so I would
hope that we keep the plan B available
but I really hope a private institution
does step up and handle that u in
respect to some of the startup costs as
well I know we have a u we already have
an industry for medical cannabis there
was some conversations about whether the
medical industry would ever be able to
help sell their products to the state
State uh one advantage of that is that
they're already up and running and
there's some they would be less less of
the startup cost in the oversight cost
because they're already established
Enterprises so I wouldn't have any issue
with that
provided the integration that may be a
little more difficult and I just made it
sound but that seems like something that
could actually make it easier for the
state to get this up and running and at
the same
time there when it comes to it's not
just the cultivation side it's also the
manufacturing side testing side they
have that industry somewhat they've
mastered their business plan so that
would actually be beneficial to the
state at least take into consideration
that policy as well may save us some of
the startup costs that we're concerned
about and I'll answer any questions
anyone has thank you represent
abis representative Bry actually I got
three initial questions I actually more
than that but we start with the three um
first you clarify this right up front
our Ed edbl in this bill or
not so what are you talking about the
edible products well we we have I mean
there manufacturing all throughout this
so you're going to license companies to
manufacture which assumes that they'll
be edibles but then when I look at when
I look at page three under possession
limits uh page uh go to line 19 on page
three it says cannabis infused products
contain containing THC purchased from
retail cannabis stores which I'm
assuming the state stores which shall be
limited to medical use
only for which the the purchaser
presents documentation printing use of
cannabis for medical purposes and which
shall not contain more than two Gams of
THC so I'm confused by why this is even
in here I mean we have seven stores we
have seven
atc's um that are uh you know that they
do all three things they they produce
they grow they they create Edibles they
manufacture and then they also sell
retail so just answer my qu I mean
please let me know are Edibles in here
because it's a very important part of
estimating revenues is is Edibles going
to be in is Edibles in this spill or
eliminated from The Spill as written
Edibles would be sold through the state
retail store but however it would still
be limited for medical use only wow that
was and that that restriction was part
of a a bigger compromise uh there was a
lot of a lot of compromises made
throughout the 17 pages of so so what
we're saying is that the only I'm not
quite sure how that's going to work in a
store um I'm I'm here for recreational
use we see the product on the
shelves that are Edibles which you as
you know are very popular a lot of
customers are going to buy edibles but
we're going to say we're only going to
limit that edible sales to people who
have a medical card is that correct
that's that's my understanding of how it
how it is written all right and that's
about a 30% market share and my concern
with with eliminating Edibles completely
is there's also I don't know if vaping
is the right term to use when but in
order for The Vaping side of the
industry to survive you may need to have
the Edibles to I think it's a you you
may need those for in order for that to
work otherwise that's kind of a product
but and the markup on Edibles is much
higher than the flower right so this
this brings us back to revenue estimates
Mr chair so follow up on on um so most
most States Edibles are sold at all
states Edibles are sold in stores so
going back to your your Revenue estimate
I mean first off I mean you handed us
this uh do you have an actual number
that you want to throw out for what we
because this is what we have to try to
understand how much what's the net going
to be for running these stores Just Like
Liquor we get the net
the profit of of the after all the
expenses so so the number I when I was
talking about uh if you can the markup
can be seven eight times an amount I was
I'm strictly referring just to the
flower I'm trying to keep the numbers as
conservative as possible I I don't want
to misrepresent or explain something
that's going to be much say it's going
to be you know half a billion dollars
and it and all of a sudden if it comes
in below that it it
seems but my understanding the markup on
on the Edibles is close to 150% to 200%
depends on the volume but it can be much
higher I don't know the markup on The
Vaping version of that but it is higher
than the flowers so the numbers I gave
are relative they're very conservative
numbers and I use everything against
against the my own interest in trying to
sell the revenue okay just on your what
you just hand it out I'm trying Mr are
we talking the 13 million to 30 million
is that what what we're looking at what
what I'm trying to understand what your
what you think the Net's going to be
if if I had my own estimation I think
once the if there's 10 retail stores up
and running not counting any of the
revenue from from the cultivators and
Manufacturing because they those
entities will still be private and
they'll be paying the business profits
tax and uh business Enterprise tax
that's not included either I would
anticipate it would come in around 250
to 300 million at a low point and again
that that's it's really difficult to
estimate what the
offset from the illegal Market would be
because that may take some time for that
to
slowly uh dissipate and I just I'm I'm
using conventional knowledge here that
if you can buy a product off the shelf
that's clean and labeled for a
competitive price it wouldn't really
make a lot of sense to go buy the same
buy a product off the in the illegal
market right is that just the marijuana
without the
Edibles so 250 to
300 I'm I'm basing that on just just the
flower markup again I did not count the
edibles but the the fiscal note from 237
didn't distinguish
between a flower or it didn't it didn't
distinguish between the flow the Edibles
or any manufactured products what that
was basing it on was the the sales a 14%
tax it would have been a 5% transfer tax
and then a 9% sales tax so on that
transfer tax and sales tax it didn't the
number didn't distinguish one or the
other but if we're not taxing it and
we're basing it on a markup from the
wholesale price if the markup on Edibles
is 150% it's going to be
you're how how many times you're
doubling 14% right off the bat follow up
I got one more and then and a lot others
um so you you mentioned advertising uh I
agree we shouldn't be advertising but
the Liquor Commission does big- time
advertising and other states especially
Massachusetts I talked to the
commissioner about
this uh to to draw those customers in
and it's fine because you can advertise
because you can buy the product here and
take it across back across the border
but the state's not going to do that the
state can't advertise across the border
because technically it's not a bit good
look for the state to do that because
you're saying to customers from
Massachusetts come here and take it home
but that's illegal to do that Crossing
back across the border
so I I think in our
estimating the numb is going to actually
we're not going to get the same out
ofate I mean there still be some out of
Staters are going to buy here if the
price it's all going to be price driven
that they're going to come but I don't
think the state can advertise that way I
mean would you agree with
that good whether that's a good decision
or not is not a decision for me myself
to make I think what I this bill does is
puts the trust in Judgment of that into
the The Liquor Commission I will say
that Canabis is against federal law and
I've taken the position we're either
going to abide by the federal law or
we're going to ignore it and what I am
recommending is if we're going to go
down this rout we just ignore it
including how we generate the revenue
how we Market
it and that's how that's how it works
the federal government has completely I
would say failed the entire country on
this issue they've sat on it and let it
become what it is today where you can't
interstate commerce it's a come of cash
industry for tax filing purposes they
they for a while I'm not sure if they
can even offset their expenses the way
so unfortunately there's a lot of
problems with the federal government but
I'm recommending as if since that
they're in action I'm going to assume
they're can to continue their in action
okay thank you thank you for answering
my questions appreciate it before we go
on another question essentially what
you're saying is since the federal
government hasn't been acting we just
ignore federal
government well cannabis is against
federal
law it so and it's against federal law
for medical use so if if we do
this and the federal government doesn't
step
in and let's say i' help us if somebody
dies because of the product that we
sell and they take it to federal
court now the courts different
would the court ignore federal law in
their
decision when when it say goes to court
are you talk about a criminal
prosecution or or a civil case both well
look at it this way if it's for a civil
case if you make the comparison to
alcohol you can then if there's
negligence or whether someone's over
served or it was distributed to a
minor in that case there still can be
civil liability even though the product
is legal so I would assume a there would
be a civil case whether in state court
or federal court as for the criminal
prosecution yeah I mean that's up to I
don't want to I don't want to tell
someone they're not it's not going to
happen but you can literally go on your
through a Fidelity account on your cell
phone and buy shares on a cannabis
company on the New York Stock Exchange
so if the federal government decides
that we're going to now prosecute this
New Hampshire is not going to be the
only state that's going to have issues
there's a lot of that's going to be a
very large trickle down effect and the
government has sent out memor
randoms to different agencies advising
them to not enforce cannabis laws so I
think the preemption argument in the
Supreme Court made that decision just to
touch on that subject that's back when
they were still the DEA was still
shutting down the retail stores when you
when you send out a memor memorandum
saying to not enforce the law well that
shows an intent to no longer control it
so that I would I would say that whole
case is right for review from the at the
federal level but I I'm predicting that
the federal prohibition will
eventually uh go away I know there's a
bill right now being held in in the
United States Senate but it hasn't been
acted on
yet thank you uh questions the committee
representative
elme sorry I'm trying to oh on I have
been B blissfully ignoring this whole
argument for quite a while except for
when I had to vote on the floor um what
do you mean by the markup is based on
the flower do you mean the
markup as from when the farmer picks the
flower when I was trying to figure out
that what what the markup is when the
farmer or the cultivator takes the
flower and then it's sold in a retail
store what is the markup in in price
I've been given a lot of a lot of
different numbers the range I've gotten
has been from 80% some say 60% it
depends on the volume but I've heard as
high as 120% it also depends on the
strain which I'm not as familiar with
that that the scientific side of that
but it really there's a lot of depends I
just been using the number 80 to 90%
because that's kind of the middle ground
so again trying to be as conservative
I'm not taking the 120% because I
again could I follow CU I still don't
quite understand so so what the farmer
sells the flower
for versus what the product at the end
is which sometimes is just a bag of
flowers that have been dried but
sometimes is a very complicated edible
or the liquid for
vaping and those Transformations cost
considerably more
so in the industry there's the
cultivation side when I say use the term
manufacturing that is the entity or
individual that's making the the Edibles
or The Vaping products
so in the medical industry what we have
here the cultivator the manufacturer and
the retails really the
same
entity in depending on which state you
look at some some states follow that
some states they're
separate I have no the way this is
written that I don't see why a
manufacturer and a cultivator has to be
separate but they can be so when I'm
talking about the flower being sold it's
now being sold at the retail level so if
the cultivator sold it to the state to
sell it when I ask how much is the
markup but when I'm given those numbers
part of the issue is is that sometimes
the cultivating the retailer even if
they're a separate entity it's still the
same owner so how those numbers are are
come up with sometimes has to do with
the fact that the industry is somewhat
marginalized by the federal restrictions
or due to the inaction of the federal
government to actually remove the
federal
prohibition but that's where I got the
that's where I got that number from but
in sorry follow up follow up on in most
cases isn't there what you're calling
the markup a considerable part of that
is the the transport shipping drying
modifying packaging Etc the costs of it
and and it would depend on what when you
say flower form you can buy it I mean
you can buy tobacco right now just in a
pouch you can buy it in a in a smaller
poch that's meant for chewing tobacco
you can buy it so you can smoke tobacco
out of a pipe you can buy uh cigarettes
that are already pre-rolled cannabis is
following I don't believe there's many
chewing products
but you can buy cannabis products that
are already rolled and again there's
those are those markups so again it
really it really depends on what you're
buying so when I say 80% it it's again
that's just kind of a rough estimation
because each product is going to have
its own individual markup and then it
also depends on the strain the quality
the reason why Edibles is higher is that
Edibles are from what I understand when
they make those handrolled products what
happens is
the waste product is is actually used to
make the
Edibles so sometimes with something that
you wouldn't normally be able to sell as
a flower you then can now use that in
the manufactured product so that's one
of the benefits of allowing that side of
the
industry represent
yearly thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question Mr
chair um I got a a couple here um the
taxing process I'm I'm unclear on this
is this a vat type tax so if there's an
excise tax or a sales tax on every stage
in the process or
not there are no taxes that are in this
and if there was any taxes I I would
likely withdraw my support for it so you
so it's only the retail the followup
follow so the retail sale
is to the benefit of it so there's no
tax for uh uh other than the license
fees for the manufacturer for the
transportation for the uh um uh transfer
to uh pouches for retail sellers
no there there are no taxes but the the
manufacturer the cultivate they would
still have the be subject to the you
know bet in the business profit STX they
would still be taxed just like they were
any other business operating in the
State uh thank you on that another
question Mr chair follow up thank you um
so the Cannabis control fund or a board
would be setting the price for sale is
that
correct I I believe the when you say the
sale you're talking about the retail
sale retail yeah that would be something
that I would I would believe the Liquor
Commission would set just like they do
with liquor sold in the liquor store
they would need to use their expertise
on really what is the price point to to
affect the sale to make it affordable
and to deal with all the other potential
mitigating problems such as the illegal
market and to attract out of state
consumers okay so another followup sir
follow up so the Liquor Commission sets
the price to
sell
and of that a certain amount and you're
you're saying here on uh page 8
uh line 26 $25 million of that has to go
to the Cannabis control fund so the
question
is if $25 million isn't made where is
the $25 million dollar come
from to fund the Cannabis control
fund and on page eight uh line 26 the
sum of 25 million annually uh
so if before that that section it's
referencing the net revenue so you would
need to that would need to be they would
need to be a net revenue in the first
place if and I pray this doesn't happen
but if there wasn't a net revenue then
that money would not you would not
invoked that
paragraph
So follow so if I follow up Mr chair
follow up so if I understand what you
just said was the funding for the
Cannabis control fund is contingent upon
sales first so the first dollar would go
into the Cannabis control fund and after
the Cannabis the 75% to 25% and and all
the things that follows are set across
then every other dollar would to go to
the um general fund or for as as a
profit is am I saying this correctly so
all all the money would go into the the
Cannabis control fund from the sales it
all goes into to the same fund but
there's there's operating cost there's
oversight cost there's cost for
employees there's there's cost for doing
business so the net re when I'm
referring to what to do with the net
revenue that's that's where when I and
where I came up with this as an
important side is I remember in my first
term last uh last term I read through
the citizen counsel ARR
and yes the overwhelming majority of of
uh the people from New Hampshire who
participate in the survey support
recreational Cannabis a lot of comments
were for the revenue purposes and that's
where I I I said that to me the biggest
part of any recreational policy is the
revenue side of it because that's what I
hear from the people of New Hampshire
are concerned with so the net revenue
that is the first 25 million in the net
revenue will be paid to DHHS to deal
with drug treatment substance abuse
treatment
prevention to try to in intervene and
really focus on drugs that can lead to
overdoses that lead to that lead to
Deaths we still have an opioid issue as
well so this would at least try to take
as many preventive me measures as
possible and mitigate some of the
potential negative impacts uh on society
that a recreational policy could bring
with
it represent L followed by represent
thank you I'm I'm going to stick with
this money theme because I want to I
want to it's really the reason we're
here which starts on page eight in this
Canabis control fund is while you're in
front of the ways and meanss committee
um and and and I guess I'm going to ask
a really long-winded question which
isn't uncommon for a politician but I'm
going to ask a long-winded question try
to see if I understand the money flow to
make sure we're clear um so I understand
the bill so the first thing that happens
is the state the the money that goes
into the Cannabis control fund is really
differential it's the profits right so
it's the it's the net profits of the
sale from the state liquor from the
state Cannabis stores um after uh would
go all of the money would go into the
Cannabis fund is that
correct all the all every dollar from
every penny from every sale right is
going it will go into that fun yes so
the followup so if I can it's going to
be kind of a series to walk through the
money to make sure I understand it
correctly cut you off cut me off one if
you want Mr chair you usually do
um uh so there's there's an initial uh
appropriation in this bill of $14
million to basically to get the the the
stores and the and the hiring and all of
that kind of stuff off the ground is
that correct correct and then the first
thing we pay back because that's general
fund money is out of the Cannabis funds
is that $14 million we pay that back
because that's basically coming from the
taxpayers so the first portion of the
funding after we've netted out the
profits right we've paid our
administrative cost as we pay uh you
know for all of our employees that may
be needed for this we would pay back
that $14 million to the state taxpayers
to make sure there was no impact for
starting this program correct thank you
once we've done that and we've corrected
the for we've we've paid the $4 million
the secondary next set of funding that I
see in here goes to Health and Human
Services for cessation programs um a
again we're talking about after we've
paid off we take the administrative
costs out we've now paid off the $4
million firsttime funds and we're now
just to the administrative costs and the
net profit from that would be go to the
first bite of the Apple would go to HHS
for cation
programs that that's correct um the next
thing that happens after that if we have
net revenues and net profits beyond the
administrative cost beyond the $25
million the next set of funding is
broken up into two pieces if I'm not the
way I read this um the first set would
go to um
would go to offset the Statewide
education property tax is that correct
I'm sorry three pieces the first one
would go to
the there there is three three so the
first 90% of the overage after we've
taken care of the Statewide property tax
and and paid that off 100% um the the
money would then go to to um I'm sorry
the money would then go to the property
tax after this after DHHS that's correct
and then we have two more segments of it
5% of it would go to uh law enforcement
to help with training
programs that's correct and then the
next 5% toal equal 100% of the overage
after Statewide property tax didn't care
would be would go to or after uh the
money would go to Children's behavioral
health programs is that correct as part
of
DHHS that's correct
okay again all of this funding though is
contingent Bond the sale price right so
it's a differential between the
wholesale price the sale price the
administrative cost to to manage all of
that and it's the profitability so to
speak that pays for all of that funding
there's no tax so to speak into it it's
about
profitability that's correct thank
you represent hat thank you Mr chair if
I may I may have a followup or two um
Contin continue dialogue and my concern
is just towards the uh amounts of money
being asked for okay so um thank you and
thank you for for taking my testimony I
guess I guess to start with the
beginning
um where was the $25 million where was
that figure derived from or how did how
was $25 million determined to be an
appropriate amount of money to be
appropriated um for this
purpose it was debated
heavily and I just when I call it the
Brain Trust that's not an official club
by any means but when we El kind of
talking about what to do uh we felt that
the and one of the biggest concerns that
people have had and expressed about any
type of 1598 aside any type of
recreational canas policy there are a
lot of people that believe it's still a
gateway drug and they believes that this
leads down a path where of substance
abuse issues and we thought that it was
important that really make put a make a
conscious effort to try to reduce that
the extent that you believe that to
reduce that that from happening but also
even if you don't believe that there's
still other drugs that are causing over
that people die from in their overdoses
and that people are physically addicted
to uh such as an opioid where your body
has physical withdrawal symptoms that to
address those situations so we really
that was the number we came up with and
I haven't heard uh any any the only
objection is every want to know how we
kind of came up with it some people had
a higher figure I felt that if that
number was going to be any higher that
DHHS would uh they would need to
Advocate and convince the legislator to
go any higher than that but I think that
when it comes to drug overdoses and Drug
prevention we really want to do
everything we can to to prevent that
from happening especially to our youth
so if any May Mr I I don't disagree with
that at all but then again we're talking
about a sum of $25 million which is
substantial in this state and don't
misunderstand me I'm not saying I'm
opposed to this but we're asking for an
appr roation we're from finance and we
need to
understand why that amount of money is
being asked for is there is it was it uh
suggested by an entity that deals with
this uh were there considerations for an
example the state currently has a
alcohol
fund which a substantial amount of that
goes towards the prevention of drug
abuse and use and etc etc etc so um
I just need to have a better
understanding of this $25 million figure
and I'm not U necessarily expecting you
to give me an answer today but um I just
just need to know where it came from did
it was it suggested by
HHS and then was it considered the other
uh multitudes of monies they have for
the same purpose because we are
duplicating an effort and that sometimes
concerns Us in
finance thank you Mr if I may
and what the way I Would S I would
direct that and I'm not sure if there is
a representative from DHHS
here so I don't want to speak out of
turn and explain that this this will
cover all the problems or this is too
much not enough but if you look at when
you're talking about the the related
education prevention treat I can't hear
you I'm sorry when it comes to the
education the uh mental health
treatment uh the uh Publications I mean
it mentions safety risk involving
alcohol and tobacco we're talking far
beyond just cannabis and one of the
reasons that inspired me to even get
involved as a state representative was
the opioid issue you know I and for me I
rather be in a situation that we're
doing everything we can and I just I
want to make sure that it's adequately
funded because for the resources to be
available because you have when people
are have substance abuse issues there's
a lot of collateral that goes along with
that for example a lot of your breaking
enterings your robber those are all
related to substance abuse as well not
all of them but there's a portion of
crimes than thank you I me I I I don't
disagree with any any of that but um
typically what we would be looking for
again this is a substantial amount of
money um how these monies might be
allocated how they might be spent and
why is it necessary to have that amount
of money I mean again this is this is
asking for a large appropriation and
these are the kind of things that we
typically have to have uh before they
get a positive vote for that
appropriation and I would think again
considering the amount of
money aside from the subject matter
there there should be some sort of idea
of how what and where this money's to be
spent and if that could be provided um
that would be a great thing and it must
exist somewhere because it's on paper
and I'll tell you I'll tell you this
that is the responsible thing for the
legislator to do and if you're going to
improve the F especially from a finance
perspective talking to the mic if you're
going to look at this on the financial
side I I will say that if if an inquiry
is made at DHHS as whether this is a
sufficient funding and how would it be
used and if they're unable to justify
the expenditure I would I would support
reducing that I think it it's something
that it should be easily presented why
this figure is supported not there was a
lot of behind the scenes that this want
this number doubled and I I was not
supportive of that because again I
didn't see any information to make it
any
higher so so if I may if if um if I may
Mr chair what what I think I would need
here is somebody to come in front of
this committee with some sort of
accounting of where what and why this
money is being spent and whomever you go
to and I suspect it to be somebody at
HHS to do that and um ask why this is
necessary and again I'm not saying it
isn't but why this is necessary in
addition to what we already appropriate
for this same purpose those are very
important questions I believe that need
to be answered before I could consider
this thank you Mr chair thank you
representative hat next is
representative Murphy followed by
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh my my question is
really about the the pricing and is
there a potential for a pricing
competition with the medical cannabis
program and my concern would be if there
is um the medical cannabis program is
obviously they have other issues with
education and um and treatment in
counseling would this in any way
undercut the pricing for medical
cannabis program and how do you protect
against that kind of competition in the
pricing thank you for the question I
would the price point at the retail
would be controlled ultimately decided
by the LI by liquor The Liquor
Commission so how that would impact the
medical
industry my observation is if someone is
using cannabis for for legitimate
medical reasons I don't see any reason
why they wouldn't continue to purch
cannabis from the medical facility the
the people working in those facilities
have a a knowledge or an expertise on
the medical
side at at when it's purely for retail
or recreational purposes you don't
necessarily need that same knowledge so
I don't I don't I don't understand why
someone would all of a sudden stop going
there if especially if the product's
being sold aren't identical but the
other side of the medical industry the
way to perhaps Preserve the medical
industry to the extent that uh we're
concerned this would have a negative
impact on it is the the concept of
allowing the medical industry to they
already have a cultivation facility
they're already growing plants perhaps
those can be integrated at some point
that's not in this bill but I would I
wouldn't object to that
policy just to follow um follow your
question was why would anybody do it I I
guess my answer would be if it costs
less and you are in a treatment program
where they are getting the counseling
and they have overheads that are costly
they're more costly than a retail or
recreational Cannabis um uh product the
answer to me to that question to me
would be if it's cheaper they're going
to go there for that so that's my
question is how do we Safeguard and
protect the medical cannabis program and
the counseling they give to people to
make sure that the price point is not
such that it's in direct
competition what I'll say it again if
someone is using cannabis for legitimate
medical reasons I don't understand why
they're going to a retail store yes it's
cannabis is cannabis but some of the
medical products that they use are
specific for a medical condition where
Recreation is not quite as uh specific
to that point if someone if if people
just are if the medical industry people
just getting the medical card simply to
buy it for recreational purposes you can
make an argument that they're Abus the
the medication that being prescribed I I
don't have I I have not heard of any
reason to believe that that's happened I
I have no basis to say that one way or
another so I would presume they someone
who's working with a counselor or
psychologist or doctor would continue to
do so because it's for legitimate
medical
reasons thank
you represent Li thank you I'm just
going to sorry I'm going to dump back to
the last questions we were asking
talking about the 25 million million
doll um would you be amendable I I I'm a
little concerned about that number
especially as a startup number and as a
percentage of Revenue would that be a
better way of going that with a Max cap
of 25 million is that would that be
something you would entertain if we did
it as a percentage of the revenue with a
maximum cap of 25 million do you think
that is that a reasonable as the program
grows the money to DHHS grows until it
reaches a
cap I don't I don't have a
that's not a deal breaker for me however
I guess if we weigh the concerns we have
of some of the issues with a rolling out
a recreational policy I still think the
high the biggest concern I hear is is
still substance abuse I know not
everyone agrees that it's a gateway drug
I mean I'm not saying one way or another
but there the concerns of the the
collective population that's what I
often hear so for me I would I would
hope that at a minimum we we at least
address do everything we can to mitigate
the negative potential negative social
impact so I I have some concerns about
not by changing that so they don't they
don't get the net amount but at the same
time that's not a deal breaker for me
because they're still going to be
getting significant funding in addition
to what they're already getting thank
you and Mr chair just to let you know I
did reach out to DHHS and ask them for
their funding on cessation programs
because you as you know we have alcohol
cessation programs we have gambling
addiction cessation programs and I asked
them for the funding of any those cation
programs what the source of those
revenues are how much money they collect
and how much money they expend and how
many citizens are helped by those
programs and I'll be happy to share that
with the committee when I get it thank
you uh representative spillsbury
followed by representative
Brony thank you Mr chairman I have three
questions if I can keep them brief
perhaps I'll get to all
three uh thank you representative abis
you're being called upon to cover a
pretty broad Arena of questions it's no
problem you know in criminal justice I
didn't get asked one question my my
first question is I just want to be sure
that I understand correctly the bill
only calls for the legislature to make a
single upfront uh appropriation from
General funds of $14 million essentially
a startup
capital and that would be repaid and
then all other uh expenses and uh
distribution of profits are
self-generating that's that's the that's
how how it's written and that's
certainly was my
intent when I help put this together so
the initial capital investment we need
to consider is the 14 million my second
question um switching uh
considerably I like very much uh the
idea of
90% of the profits after the initial
costs rep payment and 25 million for
treatment of going to education and I
suspect that that could be a
motivator uh for many legislators my
question is if I'm understanding it
correctly this specifically States 90%
to offset the education tax imposed on
all persons and property taxable
pursuant to RSA 76 d8 without looking it
up I believe we're talking about the
swept the Statewide education property
tax that's correct and uh that's a
considerable
figure um but instead of then
redistributing as is proposed on page
nine lines 3 through
14 why would we not just if we were so
fortunate as to have covered all of the
swept why would we not just continue to
put 90% into the education trust fund
and stick with that particular
purpose
I'm not saying that I would be opposed
to such a such a policy my concern was
is that if you if you offset the the
sweat my concern was that in the next
budget they may increase that number but
without having a steady line of
consistent Revenue you want to make sure
you don't want to then raise that the
amount that you make I get the feeling
that the legislator would consider
raising the swep thinking it wouldn't
have any impact on the
taxpayer well it and all of a sudden if
you fall short maybe there'll be a big
russan sales and maybe may drop down it
can we're dealing with somewhat UNP
unpredictability I would hate to see the
taxes be raised and then that that's not
property tax release could be so
fortunate to generate 263 or 363 million
there are different mechanisms for
continuing to steer the money into
education and my third question again
switching dramatically uh the banking
services I think that there may be uh a
number of people who will testify that
there's problems with setting up this
banking mechanism as a statun uh uh and
and I I don't
know what the FI financing challenges
would be to startups who don't have
access to such a fund but if if we came
to the conclusion that we didn't want
the state in that particular function
and took out 318 F16 do you think that
in any way compromises the
bill well I'm only one vote it wouldn't
compromise mine but I will tell you
this if the this gives the private
sector every option to handle the
banking side of this every option is
available to to them to demonstrate to
The Liquor Commission that they can
satisfy the the needs so that a private
institution can handle the banking side
of this if a private institution is
unable to make that demonstration to The
Liquor Commission I don't understand why
we don't want to have a a spare
tire and have a backup plan because then
what we're going to have is we're going
to have a lot of cast sitting around
we're not going to have a place to put
it that is the ultimate Plan B and I
hope that plan a works so taking that
out I understand some some uh some
people the banking industry don't like
to see the language at all but if their
if their clients or if their if that
institution is so willing to take on the
states need Plan B won't be an issue but
I'm surprised people want to take it out
if if they're able to satisfy plan a
plan B is never going to come up so I'm
just curious why it's such a problem so
I may be U missing some of the intent
here
but where are the funds coming from that
would capitalize this state banking
facility and aren't they competing with
the funds that we're thinking maybe are
going to be steered
towards um treatment abuse abuse
treatment and
education so the the $14 million
appropriation does not take into
consideration the possibility of having
the state Chartered Bank we wouldn't
just the way the bill is written that
that issue wouldn't be realized until
approximately six seven months after
this be would become law which we're a
few months away so in all likelihood
from the way I see see this is that
we'll probably be in the year
2023 so that 10 Mill that $10 million
may have would have to come from the
following
budget but
again if if we're going to roll this
plan out without a financial institution
to put money into that's a huge problem
and by having a financial institution
that would benefit the cultivators as
well the uh manufacturers would benefit
and then that would I know there Private
Financial financing options but again
that's that's private financing not
everyone that's tough to come by if you
were if the people can get financing for
a business like
cultivation uh that would be benefit to
allow more people to actually get into
the industry right now the majority of
the cultivators they're using startup
cash you know I he estimates $57 million
in liquid cash is what it takes to get
in so that's not really a you hear the
term Equity thrown around I don't if you
have 5 to7 million in and in liquid cash
sitting
around you know the equity issue is not
really something that's affecting you
that
much
okay representative BR yeah thank you Mr
chair um I got one followup to
representative Murphy's comments and
then one new issue that I'll bring
up related to the atc's I have been
getting calls from the atcs concerned
about this
bill
uh there's seven of them in the state
just FYI owned by three companies
they're vertically integrated they do
they grow they manufacture and they
sell now when I look at page 12 of the
bill it says on uh let's go lines four
to six it says this has to do with uh
the quality of the Cannabis such
cannabis shall be free from adulteration
and misb banding within the meaning of
the provision of RSA 146 all cannabis
sold for medicinal use shall conform to
the standards and tests for such
cannabis under New Hampshire law at the
time of sale so the bill itself
contemplates medical people with medical
cards coming into to these State stores
and buying
cannabis that's the why I read this I
mean this bill itself is saying that
what represented Murphy was saying could
happen the bill also anti anticipates
that that occurring would would you
agree with me or am I misreading that
you're not misreading that the the use
of Edibles that are sold in a retail
store in order to buy it those you would
still require a medical card even if
you're buying it from the state on
retailer so for that purpose there there
could be some
overlap my own personal opinion on that
again if if you're going to allow a
recreational
product I'm I'm I'm a little that was a
compromise that I made when we put this
together uh I I would support the idea
of removing that provision but from what
I understand that that may be a deal
breaker with a lot of individuals and
that this might not make it over the
finish line if you change it I'm just
being honest again the way I read it
represent follow that provision is a
little awkward I will it doesn't talk
about Edibles here it talks about all
cannabis so I just wanted to to let you
be aware of that so this my second
question
is um has to do what the ordinance is so
this bill I would call it an opt out
ability for communities on page seven
lines 7 through 15 uh for those who
haven't read this yet um so is it safe
for me to call us an opt out for a
community that's correct right and to to
my way of here's the reason I'm bringing
it up in relation to
revenues I think it'll be more difficult
for the Liquor Commission to convince
communities to sell
cannabis than alcohol I think alcohol is
more uh accepted still
uh in the state than Matt cannabis so
that I anticipate that there'll be more
communities opting out assuming they
know about this opt out provision uh in
the ordinances
so and the reason I mentioned that is
that it's it's going to be more
difficult if it's more difficult to
locate store locations in Prime
locations uh that will affect the
revenues indirectly or directly actually
would you would you agree with that or
not
if I would agree if they're limited on
the locations or town if enough towns uh
opt
out it's it could create a problem I
think it would take a lot of towns or
communities to opt out but the benefit
of this plan was that you don't have 10
12 retail stores in in your community I
where I hail from is Salem if there's 10
stores in Salem and then you know Derry
or Windam decides to opt out well
there's 10 stores within
you two two miles from you so some of
the optup provisions I'm not sure that's
going to be necessarily beneficial the
idea of this I don't
foresee uh The Liquor Commission opening
that large volume of stores the idea is
to have a limited amount of retail
stores in the first place like similar
to how liquor sold but can we follow up
then so the bill talks about 10 stores
right I'm not missing mistaken right it
talks about a limit of 10 stores so for
in the fiscal note it operates on the
assumption that there'll be 10 retail
stores there's actually no language in
the bill to limit 10 retail stores the
issue is is that in order to come up
with from my understand come up with any
type of fiscal note or estimation on
what needs to be appropriated they need
to have a a base to work with uh I
didn't see the reason why we would maybe
limit the amount of stores because this
my own personal opinion if we have to
pass legislation every time we want to
open a store we I don't believe we
really want to you're doing that it we
have to take into consideration that if
we have private cultivators and private
manufacturers that you those business
businesses need to also succeed and if
the 10 stores isn't is not enough to
meet the market
demand there's no reason why we we
shouldn't expand but I think that's that
in my opinion that's a decent starting
point and if you just kind of think in
your head some of the major cities
93 Salem I mean you you're at 78 just
just thinking about that right now so
then one more followup then then you're
also saying that I misread the fact that
there was only
15 uh
cultivators so there there would be
that's for for licensing purposes they
would limit it to 15 licenses that's in
the license section that's that's for
that's for cultivation
specifically so how do so we're g to
have 15 cultivators
feeding first I thought it was 10 stores
but it unlimited number of stores unless
we change the language or change the
bill down the road change the law down
the road to create more cultivators to
feed these
stores well for someone I'm not into
cultivation industry but if they when I
understand that when plants are
grown there's going to be a market order
submitted to them this is what we're
looking they then grow to try to fill
that market order there's no reason why
the facility itself can grow as does the
market as does the demand for the
product if if the 15 cultivators can't
meet the retail
demand I would hope the state would have
the uh wisdom to expand that number okay
thank you that this this been actually
helpful to understand thank
you representative Petri yeah thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um you talked about State Banks
is that to avoid the Fed the Federal
Reserve and how would you how would they
clear the checks and whatever how would
they have to have a third party or how
would that
work I'll uh I'll respectfully admit
that I am not an expert on the banking
side of this but from what I understand
uh there's still a lot of fear of
crossing over state lines and there a
fear that the federal government could
intercept that I don't I I don't think
they will but then again that's a if if
there's $50 million being transferred
over that you who wants to take that
risk so the reason why say that again I
can't imagine someone wanted to take a
risk with $50 million transfer
transferring it over state lines it is
still a un necessary risk so the idea is
to keep the Bank located in New
Hampshire so it would have to be either
be a private institution but any private
institution that as long as it's located
here in the state of New Hampshire would
be able to actually fulfill I don't see
why they wouldn't be able to fulfill the
state's needs um and then plan B is that
if there is no financial institution
willing to take on that take on the
state as a customer then the state will
have to handle it
themsel follow follow up yeah well the
when you the Clearing House for checks
in other words when you write a check
here it probably goes into the Boston
fed and cleared through there and that's
you know that's the way it works now and
and of course credit units not part of
the FED but they do work through the fed
you know to clear if you write a check
at a credit unit off off a credit unit
it works so it it's kind of interesting
you know we got to make sure this going
to work because you know the the FED
it's against the law federally
so to be honest I'm not I'm not clear
how the I'm not sure if the medical
facilities now would accept a check and
but the mere Act of using a check in of
itself is a federal crime to purchase it
it
so although cannabis is illegal you're
committing other Crimes by simply the
method of which you purchased
again another reason why I think the
federal government has really failed not
just New Hampshire the entire country on
this
subject further questions represent
urle thank you Mr chair following up on
the banking question of Representative
Petri
um what is to prevent the fed from just
saying that's our money because it was
done with drugs I mean the DEA does it
all the time they just walk in and take
it
well if they did that to just New
Hampshire and nowhere else that sounds
like selective prosecution to me
and I mean think about it how many
states have medical policies how many
states have Recreation
and they going to just Target the state
of New Hampshire
only just the state retail stores
they're not going to Target the medical
side are they going to go after the
companies that are are they going to go
after Fidelity and seize everyone's
retirement accounts because because they
own shares in the Cannabis company are
they going to come in here and
arrest good portion of the people in
this
room I'm not even sure that the federal
government has the resources to do that
if they want wanted
to but is could could that could it
happen yes but I would find it odd why
New Hampshire specifically was targeted
as opposed to some of the other states
thank you Mr chair any further questions
representa Aly followed by representa
Ames thank you uh the basis of this
whole bill for us
is where's the revenue coming from and
how much much is it and I'm still maybe
I'm just dense but uh The Liquor
Commission authorizes these retail
stores the retail stores then decide how
much they're going to charge who's
setting the price for these things and
where do we get enough information to
figure out what the cost basis is we
need the profit we don't need the markup
so so there is someone from The Liquor
Commission here that that can answer
that but my understanding is that the
Liquor Commission just as they sell
liquor sets the
price so when it comes to what will the
profit be we we're talking about an
entity that doesn't exist yet there is
no cultivator strictly a private
cultivator to sell to the state so to
tell you give you an exact number I
would be I'm using rough estimates but
to give you a specific figure would
would not be genuine so it would depend
on how much it would depend on how much
they're growing and what the market
order is the more and more they grow
that that's going to affect everything
so and then some states have put some
real restrictive regulations that end up
costing a lot of money for the
cultivators so if I would hope when the
rules are established and some
regulations come down the line that we
don't make that mistake by making
unnecessary burdens on the Private
Industry
so but it's hard to give you an exact
number yeah I think I missed a CR
critical part of that last piece of the
answer but uh some states make what kind
of
regulations California is a good example
of overregulation and over
Taxation and the problem out there right
now is one you have the legal Market
that's completely taken off and
apparently doing better than the private
sector and then there there's there's
petitions going around pleading with for
the state to reduce the taxes and reduce
some of the regulations so they can at
least come close competing with the
price point of the legal market so the
injuries the the industry is somewhat
oversaturated as as a result of
that could I just follow up follow up uh
we have the 2020 Dr attempt to answer
this question which which you started
from and and they looked at the
estimated number of New Hampshire
residents aged 20s 20 and older uh using
cannabis now and the ounces is used per
year per person to try to get uh if we
got the entire Market what uh would we
be getting out of it at a tax rate which
is irrelevant here
so that you're also expecting there'd be
some people coming across the border but
that depends a lot on the
price so um and their
estimate of Revenue seems well it's
quite low I think it's very very
conservative but uh yours seems awfully
high and I don't think that the Liquor
Commission I think has just started
thinking about this because they've just
given us some basic uh the revenue the
percentage tax and the
sales uh and the revenue per capita
which is really important to us that's
where I started from years ago right we
will be going over that but on it
doesn't look like
they've considered this from we need to
consider this from a bunch of angles I
think and
and but what you're saying is the Liquor
Commission would decide what the price
should
be and then I guess I need to ask the
Liquor Commission how they do that so
part of the my understanding the role of
the Liquor Commission is to sell liquor
and make make revenue for the state and
they've done an excellent job doing that
I I the figures I have from
2020 the gross sales for liquor in New
Hampshire was $765
Million yes they've done so I and what I
understand is about 40 to 50% of that
those sales come from out ofate
consumers so the re and the reason for
that is very obvious and it's not it's
no secret if you want to buy a bottle of
liquor the cheapest place in New England
to buy it is New Hampshire if you look
at New England as if imagine if we were
just one state and New Hampshire was a
County we're surrounded on all sides by
other counties selling a product with a
high tax rate if we are right in the
middle perfectly
located and we what we're doing with
liquor is we sell it for a lower price
without a tax and it's been a model that
has worked since the 21st amendment was
ratified by the country we've been do
and I looked in a book for the history
of Salem town I live in and had a
picture of the liquor store in Salem
from 19 19 40 and there's cars parked
all down Route 28 before it was heavily
trafficked like it is today and everyone
was buying liquor at a discount price
it's been going on for generations and
there's no reason why we they could not
do that and mimic that effort with
cannabis and that's to be honest that's
where I came up with this idea is that
because of the job that the good job
they're doing with liquor I'm hoping
they can do that but
ultimately they need to figure out the
price point that would make incentivize
a consumer to come here and to purchase
it from the the retail store not from
the legal market and not from to get
consumers to come here to New Hampshire
to buy it and when they come here to buy
cannabis they fill up their gas tanks
they eat at our restaurants there's a
lot of other benefits we can derive from
that as a
state I represent
ases hi you're almost
done um so I think this is fairly simple
stuff that I want to just make sure I
understand
um unlike
liquor which The Liquor Commission can
procure from all
over the world basically and then resell
um cannabis which under this bill The
Liquor Commission will have a duty to
have in its
possession and uh
sell
um can as I understand it only come from
the cultivation facilities that are
licensed and uh the manufacturing
facilities that are licensed in New
Hampshire um am I correct in thinking
that the sole source is New
Hampshire uh
cannabis it's it's kind of a complicated
answer the way it's written
it doesn't exactly state that
specifically but if the state wanted to
purchase cannabis from Maine
Massachusetts California wherever and I
really hope regardless of the federal
prohibition we still support our local
businesses but you would be violating
Main's law and California's law and
Massachusetts law if we purchased
cannabis from those States because those
States as part of their licensing
requirement at least that I'm aware of
they're not allowed to sell it to any
entity outside of that state so we
wouldn't as much as we may want to
purchase from out of state we we could
not do that but I still Envision at some
point in time that the federal
prohibition will be go away so the way I
I this is I thought the way to draft
this was was to anticipate that that
would happen and we wouldn't have to
rely on legislation to then remove that
restriction that would be become extinct
but but again because the other state
restrictions there's not much we could
do about that anyway
so that could be an issue down the line
but it just I didn't see the reason why
we would put in there right
now okay so at least at the start the
source is going to be New Hampshire and
it's going to have to be developed
because we don't have product at that
level that this bill assumes at this
stage in New Hampshire is that
correct that that is correct and that's
why it's it's critical to to keep the
incentive for a cultivator to actually
want to invest in New Hampshire and grow
here because if you make it too
difficult for them to operate their
business and they need to make a profit
too the problem is is that we'll have
these retail stores without necessarily
A cultivator so we it really needs to be
a a fair partnership for everyone
involved I guess I got one follow up on
that uh follow up so what of uh our New
Hampshire cultivators get going under
this new umbrella new new Arrangement
and
uh and are very successful in growing
the stuff and uh now they've got more
than the Liquor Commission needs are
they able to sell it
anywhere that's an excellent question
and that's one of the questions I've
been asked I've been asked so many times
about that problem there's a lot of
concerns with that now the way from what
I understand is that if the state is in
is going to purchase from the cultivator
there would be a certain
order amount that they're requesting so
I would just presume someone would not
grow more than what the purchase order
is is asking for now I I suggested other
ways to address that for example let say
a cultivation facility sold their own
product on site that would be one way to
mitigate some of the potential losses
but again Rome wasn't built in a day and
I think there's a lot of what if we do
this what if we do that what if we do
this I think this is this is a program
that we need to kind of get it going get
up and running and will there be changes
to it I can I I foresee that
happening so I also don't think there
will be 15 cultivat is opened
overnight and as the stores expand so
will the demand from the I didn't hear
as the stores expand no before that you
said you think that there will not be 15
cultivators to start with I don't I
don't think on day one I didn't hear you
that's all when on the first day that
the first retail stores open I I would
find it hard to believe that there's 15
right cultivators up and running at Max
Max Capacity I understand
that okay I want to remind the committee
we have about 14 more pink
cards and it looks like we're definitely
going to have
to continue the hearing if we run out of
time
today representative Aaron thank you Mr
chair and I don't know if this is going
to be a quick question or not but I'm
interested to know is there an any
estimate for the revenues that we would
get for licensing for these
manufacturers or suppliers and and are
those licensing fees going to be
annual I'm drawing a blank I don't
believe that the revenue projection
takes into consideration the licensing
fees and application fees um and I don't
recall if the bill reserve the right for
liquor to have Annual fees that that off
the top of my head I don't I don't
recall the answer okay thank you but
that should be if it's not in there then
should certainly be addressed thank you
any further questions
answer want to answer a question Mr
chairman if it would please the
committee I can I don't mind taking a
break and coming back answering more
question question maybe perhaps let some
members of the public one more question
and then we'll do that it's me
again so I think there's there's
provision for licenses you know licenses
but you you left all of that to the
rules that appears in this bill license
what the fees would be the whether they'
be annual fees initial buyin fees that
that seems to be pretty Broad in the
bill that it's a a rules thing uh
although I'd like to see that in the
bill myself um and I forgot what the
other thing was I was going to say oh
again back to the back to the
atcs
now the atcs there's three manufactur
there's three growing sites in this
state already that are make could be
more but three the three businesses that
own these current atcs in our state 7
have growing
sites is there any reason to think that
these
nonprofits can grow and sell to the
state as well
I I I I don't know the answer to that I
don't know if you know the answer to
that either I I don't want to speak for
all three of them I I'm not going to
name any companies by name I don't want
to give anyone an official endorsement
but the two of them have confirmed that
they could in increase their production
now without knowing this what the state
would demand could they fill it I mean
they wouldn't be able to know the number
but a lot of them have the facility
already in place there are some the
integration is difficult because they're
not for profit also they're not
regulated they're regulated by another
commission already so the integration of
that is would be difficult but I
certainly would have no objection to
that okay the final one representative P
thank you Mr chairman and uh thanks for
the uh great answers to the questions uh
we're we've got 376 million
approximately request for new
money 100 into that is uh the YDC
settlement uh and what are you
requesting
actually I heard 50 million is it or is
it 14
million are you referring to the initial
appropriation to start up yes the
initial startup appropriation would be
$14 million half of that is actually to
buy inventory to
sell and then all that money as written
would have to be repaid back to the
state followup now these yeah thank you
uh these 10 stores would they be rented
spaces or I heard that they were uh I
heard rumors that they were building
these
buildings it in the appropriation
estimate it does discuss rent and leases
and it discusses build outs so with what
you see with a lot of commercial
properties you know the the tenant often
pays the cost with some of the buildout
that's that's in that's on a Case by
case base that's part of the lease um so
it says the lease portion but I don't
believe that they would be necessarily
restricted to only renting longterm
perhaps purchasing would be better but
at the same time R wasn't built in a day
so thank
you well thank you for now repr
AB thank you Mr
chairman
uh what I want to remind
everybody as you have heard we're
concentrating on the revenue and
appropriation part of this and anything
associated with the banking not the
policy because it's already been settled
so the first one is the next is
representative Tim Eagan from
Grafton number
two and in support of the bill and you
have written
testimony have you passed out your
written testimony I can send email I was
prepared to email that testimony to the
entire committee Mr chair
okay thank you Mr chair and committee
members of ways and means for hearing me
today to speak on behalf of House Bill
1598 1589 excuse
me um I represent the towns in Grafton 2
of Franconia Lisbon Lyman Monroe and
Sugar Hill I serve as the chair of the
house Democratic caucus for cannabis and
I serve as a Committee Member on the
environmental social and governance
committee for the National Organization
called the Cannabis certification
Council they promote sustainability in
the industry Nationwide I'm here to
support this bill but I request that we
improve the bill because we're leaving
revenue on the table that is driven from
our Local Economic Development
opportunities and awareness of a current
market Direction
first you should know that sales of
regulated cannabis products in the US
are expected to top out at $27 billion
in 2021 that's up roughly 25% from 2020
according to Leading cannabis marketing
analysis firm bdsa 2020 sales came in at
17.6 billion making it a banner year for
the Cannabis industry for dispensaries
that were recognized as essential
businesses during Co pandemic just like
state liquor stores were
and bdsa expects the market to reach $41
billion by 2026 just four years from now
but the bill leaves out our helded New
Hampshire small business community and
one way to remedy that is amending the
bill to allow for the selling of th
infused products or what we call Edibles
to allow it for sale to adult consumers
that way this could be done via an
amendment and I'm actually prepared to
file that Amendment if need be but what
concerns me in this bill is the reason
why this needs to be done it defines
possession as
limiting cannabis infused products
containing THC purchased from the retail
cannabis store which shall be limited to
medical use only for which the purchaser
presents documentation permitting use of
cannabis for medical purposes and which
shall not contain more than two grams of
THC this is hard to understand because
basically what it says is adult use
has no access to Edibles yet
medical users can but we're going to
allow medical products to be sold in
adult use store and not
allow medicinal stores which we already
have to sell that so this bill has a
little bit of an inherent problem there
and we're leaving money on the table
because what this does
adult use access to Edibles continues to
draw our consumers in the United States
70% of cannabis consumers turn to
Edibles and 34% prefer Edibles over
inhalables or topicals and most
importantly these Edibles would be
required to be designed manufactured and
distributed within New Hampshire
improving our Local Economic Development
opportunities Edibles occupy recently
National nationalwide 133% of the total
cannabis dollar
by volume and that growth is changing
rapidly it's outpacing the industry they
expect Edibles to make up to up to 15 to
18% of the market by 2025 from 133% just
in 2020 the end of- year data for
cannabis analytics by The Firm headset
shows that in 2020 sales of all adult
use medical Edibles grew by 60% across
seven states to 1.2.3 billion from 2020
from
676 million in 2019 that performance
meant Edibles outperformed the total
cannabis Market which grew at a hefty
four 54% alone so it outgrew its own
flower market and the seven states
focused on obviously were California
Colorado Massachusetts Michigan Nevada
Oregon and Washington where adult use
has been in existence long enough to be
able to assess uh how these numbers can
be of of valid use lastly um adult use
access to Edibles would allow
entrepreneurs within the state to make
take their culinary skills and turn them
into a larger margin business anyone
that's ever had a conversation with
someone that runs a restaurant knows the
low margin that restaurants or catering
offers and being able to enter into the
edible Market could allow those
businesses to maximize their margin um
and we'll also be able to generate new
agricultural
Industries based sorry agricultural
based Industries which helps diversify
New Hampshire's business structure and
Local Economic Development will take
place in areas of the state that want
the Cannabis industry to be there so
they can
create Market areas that are similar to
what we've done with the craft brewing
industry and the winery
industry Edibles are a viable business
for New Hampshire because consumers turn
to Edibles to help them sleep better
relax from social anxiety help relieve
pain consumers are shying away from
inhalable products we've all seen folks
understand the that what they consider
maybe the dangers of of cigarettes so
they might not be interested in hailing
their cannabis but they would want it in
an edible form consumers are looking for
more discrete options as we know a lot
of the rules around legal adult use
cannabis require it not to be smoked in
a public place therefore Edibles allows
them to consume their product without
impacting their neighbor the
overall Insight of this ex overall over
excuse me the oversight of all of this
could take place from the existing
infrastructure that is already put in
place in this bill so the fact that
there is a a commission there all the
security all the understanding that is
put into this bill by um uh
representative filed it and did and did
that quite well would all be existing
that allow Edibles to then be integrated
into this process and lastly they would
all oversee a more increased Revenue
possibility for reducing property taxes
increasing Revenue support of mental
health care and education funding two
things that our governor recently noted
in his state of State address which were
Paramount to the state of New Hampshire
so I thank you for letting me um speak
today it's important for me to note that
unlike most other legalization States um
this bill does no way change the
penalties for the use of personal
cultivation which would remain a
jailable offense um if we are going to
move this bill forward it it should
legalize the secure discreet cultivation
of personal cannabis and take into
consideration the incredible economic
impact that the edible industry uh can
provide to our state so I thank you for
your time and your
attention thank you for your testimony
representa again take
questions I gladly take questions
representor BR thank you Mr chair thank
you for your testimony um real quick I I
missed the number you you current use of
Edibles what percentage did you
use so I right now Nationwide it's 133%
it's going to go up to between 15 and
18% by
2025 and and what's the source of that
do you know that is um an organization
called headset they're a National
Consumer analytics firm and I that is
those links to those two organizations
that I referenced in my testimony and
you're going to send that to us I am
going to email that to you all with the
embedded link so you can access this
data and one one followup on well
another question so you mentioned
somewhere in there that that that our
atc's or our medical marijuana stores
don't sell Edibles I mean they do sell
Edibles right yeah they I'll defer to
they believe me they do so they do what
it does what it what it oddly does is it
allows Edibles not to be sold to adult
users but only to Medical users which
basically would drive that's dis spill
dis spill does that that's what I'm
saying so this it would drive oh I agree
with edible user edible those that want
edible that are medical patients it
would actually drive them away from
medicinal shops that we've already
developed and Fir and and built in this
state so it's just confuses me I agree
with you 100% thank you thank you
further
questions thank you for the testimony
thank you again for your time
today the next is representative Sue
hola from Hillsboro
County District 27 and opposition the
Bill thank you Mr chair thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to testify
before I I get into my comments I'd
actually like to make a word a little
couple comments on Edibles in the
medical marijuana field it is documented
that approximately a THC level about 5
to 10% in an edible is appropriate to
alleviate symptoms that people seek uh
relief for through
marijuana right now in in the state
sanctioned alternative medical
facilities there are Edibles that are
upwards of 80% THC level so when we have
a conversation about Edibles I just want
everyone to keep in mind that if we
can't control or have proper oversight
of the THC level in Edibles in the
medical marijuana field good luck in the
recreational that's all that's all I
just wanted to say about that um I do
want to say there are many singularly
important issues wrapped up in this bill
and I've expressed those already on the
house floor uh when we had floor debate
and obviously I won't cover what I have
already spoken about even though I
consider them to be very fundamentally
critical to this discussion and the main
concerns about this bill I'd like to
address are the revenue expectations of
this legislation in the level of detail
regarding the fiscal analysis of the
bill the primary selling point of this
bill appears to be the expected revenues
from legalization in this bill's unique
proposal to enable the state to execute
a business model for marijuana
distribution it's important to note that
in every state which has legalized
marijuana the revenues from such sales
have come in below projections and they
usually represent a small portion of the
state's budget in Massachusetts the
first year of tax revenue for marijuana
sales was less than half of the
anticipated amount as rep abis has
discussed when uh speaking about
California in 2020 those Revenue amounts
failed to meet their projected Target
and it resulted in the industry um
proponents pressuring legislators to
reduce the sales tax on marijuana
because the business was quote on the
brink of
collapse an overall analysis of how much
marijuana Revenue actually contributes
to a state budget would show The
Following that in Colorado and
Washington it's just over 1% in
California Alaska Oregon Nevada is a
half percent or less and as we discuss
revenues it's important to to kind of
consider the two statements made by two
people in Colorado uh one of them former
Colorado governor John Hickenlooper who
said 2018 we get 200 million a year in
tax revenue which you know we're a 30
billion budget so it's a drop in the
bucket it's not going to pay for early
childhood education or solve any big
social ill Andrew fredman who's a
marijuana coordinator director said in
2015 he's the Colorado drugs on Zar in
2015 you do not legalize for taxation
it's a myth you are not going to PVE
streets you're not going to be able to
pay teachers the big red herring of the
whole thing is that tax revenue will
solve a bunch of crisises but it won't
it's important to note that in Colorado
for every uh dollar gained it is also
spent four $450 cents to mitigate the
negative effects of legalization has had
on its citizens as we know the
proponents of this bill have crafted the
bill so it avoids being considered a tax
and allows the state to be a business
stakeholder of marijuana sales revenue
regardless of how the revenue is derived
actuated Revenue history shows that the
anticipated dollar amount will fall
short
adding to this is the fact that New
Hampshire will also be on the hook to
support the entire business model for
these sales which is a whole other
benefit cost analysis factor that other
legalized states are not encumbered by
with regard to the fiscal analysis this
bill appropriates 14 million for startup
costs as we've already discussed to run
these stores the 10 state run stores at
the outset as any business owner will
know as knows that projected startup
costs never equate to actual costs it's
important to note that this $14 million
figure does not as we've discussed here
today it does not clearly factor in a
thorough analysis on how much funding
each of these stores will need to
operate from a facility standpoint or a
complete real estate analysis on the
size of each facility as compared with
market value rates for commercial
property more importantly there's little
information provided on the cost of the
contracts the state must enter into with
the marijuana producers so they can
supply high concentrate THC product to
the state
stores from a fiscal uh perspective this
bill appro Ates an enormous amount of
taxpayer money before $1 of Revenue is
realized and the amount of the
appropriation has not factored in some
of the most critical costs it merely
throws out a number without proper
valuation an appropr appropriation this
large for business model that has never
been tried in any other state needs a
more thorough evaluation before we jump
in with both feet and no safety net
Canada Canada has in fact tried a state
uh provincial run model and that effort
failed at Great cost to their taxpayers
the Canadian government gave the
provinces two options provide private
retail sales for marijuana or state or
set up a state run option both Quebec
and on and Ontario uh set up state run
options Quebec is still struggling but
Ontario is already given up according to
the Canadian broadcast Corporation news
report in 2019 the Ontario retail
Corporation racked up $106 million in
expenses but only made6 64 million in
sales resulting in a loss of 42
million the Ontario government also set
up growing sites costing tens of
millions of dollars and then squandered
a total of $80 million trying to figure
out how to operate them it got so
honorous that they gave up and let the
contracts go to private companies and
meanwhile the grow sites produced a a
huge amount of marijuana with no shops
to sell it
in it's not clear from the Press reports
where they stand exactly now but the
roll out in Ontario with their state run
stores was
disastrous also a recent Canadian
government National survey found that
despite the government sanctioned retail
effort 40% of marijuana users still buy
their marijuana illegally through the
back black
market perhaps we should examine
Canada's risky experiment before we jump
into uh jump into our own in closing I'd
like to add that the more that we dig
into the specifics of this bill the more
questions are raised about the fiscal
soundness of The Proposal
it's clear from other legalization
efforts and some of the discussions that
this is a complex public health issue
and a business model and it has not been
executed as expected in any
location instead of rushing headlong
into the experiment perhaps a more
apprpriate step would be to consider an
interim study so that we may at the very
least fully understand the fiscal
implications uh to taxpayers and in Off
Script I'd like to add in one more
comment but if we make a decision to
legalize marijuana on the promise that
it
will get take away uh Statewide property
tax it'll be a huge benefit to people
it'll reduce property taxes then we've
already lowered the bar and said
that basically any drug if it's worth
the cost is beneficial thank you well
thank you for the testimony
U
and you'll answer questions yes sir
representa BR yes thank you and thank
you for your testimony uh the 64 million
that first that that was for cbec uh
Ontario I guess Ontario Ontario that was
the gross number gross sales uh uh
according to the data I looked at it
said 64 million in sales so I'm assuming
that means that's the net can you
provide us the uh the source of the
Canadian experience so what I did is I
emailed you all uh about two hours ago I
emailed you my testimony and in that
testimony there are reference links to
the data that I provided so you can
click on all of those and and look at
the reports that I looked at I'm glad
you did that thank you thank you
appreciate it for other
questions saying none thank you for your
testimony next is John Brun CL frosi
from the Bedford Police from the New
Hampshire Chiefs of Police Association
speaking in opposition to The
Bill Good there we go okay um thank you
Mr chair and thank you for giving uh the
New Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police the opportunity to speak before
you I we emailed you the testimony and
I'll just briefly discuss um the final
section of that testimony with respect
to the costs that we estimate will be uh
incurred if commercialization of
cannabis is approved in the state of New
Hampshire based on the estimate which is
again based on open-source data
regarding the cost of substance use
disorder both tangible and intangible
costs in the United States we find that
we expect that the state of New
Hampshire will incur an increase of of
approximately $88 million in both
tangible and intangible costs related to
the legalization the commercialization
of
cannabis uh in uh the state of New
Hampshire now again you just her
testimony with respect to the Canadian
experience both in Ontario and Quebec
which I think are uh very much on point
with respect to a discussion regarding
the revenue and costs related to the uh
commercialization of cannabis in Canada
the study and the information that the
Chiefs Association produced also relies
on the Canadian experience which
arguably probably has produced the best
data uh that um we can use in
extrapolating what would likely to occur
here in the United States and in the
granite state the Canadian government um
has calculated that approximately 7%
um of all the substance use disorder
cost related to uh the use of cannabis
uh in Canada um which equates to the $88
million based on the total cost of
substance use disorder um cost uh in the
United States that's extrapolated down
um here to the state of New Hampshire so
that's where uh in general and again the
data and the reference point and and
it's footnoted uh in the testimony that
was sent to you
we also looked at material and
information from the Journal of American
Medical Association who has calculated a
um the cost of cannabis as well as other
drugs in terms of total Hospital costs
looking at projected increase which
again varies between 8 and
12% uh if uh commercialization is
approved in uh the granite state we're
looking at somewhere in the vicinity of
approximately 170,000 to $ 200,000 um
dollars of an increase just that will be
borne by uh New Hampshire hospitals
treating both inpatient and outpatient
cannabis related emergency department
visits when we look at the potential
impact on our roads we see that in
2021 we had 116 fatal crashes uh here in
uh the granite state using that data and
using uh National Data that shows um
approximately 4.7% of operators uh have
admitted to operating while under while
impaired by cannabis in the United
States that's uh equates to somewhere
between 51 and
65,000 operators based on the total
number of operators licensed uh in the
state of New Hampshire using a a figure
of approximately
22% of all the fatal crashes which uh by
the way based on the National Highway uh
traffic safety administration numbers is
quite low perhaps 50% lower than what it
should be using a a 22% figure that
equates to around 25 crashes directly
related to cannabis if we look at a 12%
increase uh that will lead us to
somewhere in the vicinity of an
additional 55 crashes uh per year that
are caused as a direct result of
commercialization of cannabis that leads
us to an additional
$230,000 in costs born by New Hampshire
law enforcement uh municipalities like
my department based on a calculation of
the total cost of investigating a one
car fatal motor vehicle accident at
around $110,000 so that number is is is
very conservative when we look at the
total cost and so we're looking at
somewhere in the vicinity of an increase
of approximately 1 half million of cost
by uh New Hampshire and law enforcement
organizations uh and agencies to
investigate um cannabis related motor
vehicle fatal crash these are just fatal
crashes by the way these are not just
all
crashes uh in in addition um when we
look at the cost of investigating
allegations of illicit uh manufacturer
growing uh in distribution which I must
say uh is a critical piece in your
determination as to how much revenue
this particular bill is expected to
produce for the State of New Hampshire
because the experience in most other
states throughout the country is that
the in including Canada by the way as
you just heard from the previous uh
speaker uh has continued to proliferate
uh legalization commercialization of
cannabis has not uh pushed the Market uh
into Oblivion in fact in Most states it
expanded exponentially uh and as a
result uh commercialization has
essentially turned law enforcement into
21st century revenues because we are now
or would be charged with investigating
illicit grow and Manufacturing and
distribution operations that are in
direct competition uh with the state and
we estimate conservatively the cost to
New Hampshire municipalities
particularly the law enforcement
organizations somewhere between 2
million and $2.5 million which if you
look at the money that the legislature
has uh allocated in previous years for
just Granite hammer and granite Shield
um that's a relatively uh short sum so
in looking at the costs um involved um
in in relation to the commercialization
particularly the cost uh that would be
imposed upon New Hampshire law
enforcement um as you all know and I'm
sure if you're talking to your own
Chiefs uh they will tell you that each
and every uh New Hampshire and law
enforcement organization including the
state police uh and County Sheriff's
Office are wildly under resource um we
are underst staffed uh and this
imposition and the increase that we
anticipate conservatively conservatively
estimate um would not be able to be
borne well if at all by New Hampshire
and law enforcement so um I urge you to
take a strong look at um the uh cost
involved in uh approving this bill uh
because that is essentially what we're
facing and I think that ultimately uh
using uh and again the representative on
sponsored this bill is a good friend of
law enforcement but I think that the
estimates for
Revenue uh discounting the cost of
Regulation um legal regulation of it is
a is akin to an episode in the Shark
Tank I think that's what we're looking
at here thank you for the opportunity to
speak to you
today thank you for your testimony Chief
uh would you take questions
yes representa
Almy thank you uh it sounds like you're
working from an estimate of how much the
Cannabis Market would grow legal and
illegal inside of New
Hampshire uh if it is legalized here but
all of our neighbors have
legalized and uh I'm pretty sure that
we've got people going to the
neighboring states to bring back legal
marijuana in at least some cases on how
did you decide how much you figured it
would
grow that's based on my experience as a
law enforcement officer for 43 years and
um particularly based Bas on my 27 years
working uh with the Drug Enforcement
Administration in various places
throughout the country and uh my
experience in dealing with the illicit
market for controled substances
including uh marijuana and I can tell
you explicitly that the uh illicit
Market uh doesn't go away precisely
because they don't pay taxes they don't
pay um Social Security they don't pay
Medicare um they don't pay those costs
uh and as a result uh cannabis and
marijuana um on the black market is
extraordinarily um uh um High Revenue
producing in fact it produces more
revenue on par than uh cocaine
production does and in addition it's
been our experience that uh ilic illicit
producers generally uh produce somewhere
in the vicinity of around 250 to 300%
more than what the market demands so
there's never a shortage of Supply so
that number that I arrived in direct U
relation to your question is as a very
low estimate 100 investigations based on
a general cost of experience based on
the number of hours of surveillance uh
and again it doesn't include the
prosecution County attorney cost or the
court cost none of these figures include
court costs so 100 investigations
throughout the grite state based on
commercialization um relative to illicit
grow operations is relatively small
there's no data from uh Vermont Maine or
Massachusetts reg relative to the
numbers of um illicit um growing
operations although there have been a
number of them from what I understand
anecdotally representative Murphy thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for your
testimony and taking my question my my
my question is maybe without a real
answer uh um but I'd be interested in
your thoughts about this my
experience in hospitalization and care
of patients is that the great majority
of the accidents that we see are alcohol
related uh some may have you know
cannabis but I'm wondering if the
numbers that you have when you address
the increased cost of hospitalizations
is as a result of an increased use now
of cannabis versus those that would
choose cannabis over alcohol and the
consequences of their action
um because if you do have and and I also
ask because if you have cannabis
regulated and without any uh poisoning
so to speak with fentanyl or other
illicit substances might the um rate of
injuries and accidents go down as a
result of that so I'm wondering if you
have any sense about whether or not it's
a net gain in cost for hospitalizations
and care of these patients or um are the
same people would choose one of the
other and then get behind the wheel of a
car the the data and the increase in the
number of cannabis related crashes and
these are again our fatal crashes and
their resulting Hospital costs are based
on a couple of assumptions um they're
based on data provided by national
highway traffic safety administration
regarding the number of operators um who
admit to driving um while under the
influence of cannabis as well as data
from states that have Comm
commercialized cannabis and have seen um
about 120% increase in the number of
fatal crashes um the hospitalization
cost is uh derived from uh an averaging
if you will uh from the journal American
Medical Association report in
2019 that calculated the cost of both
inpatient and outpatient uh marijuana uh
Ed visits um the high end being 8,000
the low end being about about 2,000
using a $4,000 average that puts us at
around
$165,000 uh increase just in
hospitalization costs borne by the
hospitals themselves so um in in every
state that has commercialized Canabis
there has been a complimentary increase
in fatalities and crashes um
attributable or or involved with drivers
uh operating Under the Influence and of
course here uh in the state of New
Hampshire ladies and gentlemen there is
no per se limit uh for uh intoxication
by THC and so it is absolutely
impossible and I speak from experience
having two fatal crashes in the town of
Bedford New Hampshire uh both of which
involved operators that were operating
under impaired based on the toxicology
reports but yet the county attorney's
office was hamstrung uh in its inability
to prosecute uh uh both of those
operators who who killed two people and
uh again while we're talking about
dollars and cents I have to make sure I
bring everyone back to faces of people
we can't put dollars and cents above the
cost of human
life represent Aaron thank you Mr chair
thank you for your testimony today um
and for taking my question so I'm
interested to know
if you've been in contact with other
police Chiefs associations other police
Chiefs in other states that have
legalized um to see what their
increased law enforcement costs are or
have been since
legalization I haven't personally had
any contact we've uh talked uh certainly
amongst uh our our colleagues here in
the grand state with respect to our
experience with uh our current
experience with marijuana related uh
crashes as well as fatalities the
information that uh is uh contained in
my testimony um and written testimony
and and my spoken testimony today is is
derived from uh open source material um
Quebec um recently produced an article
that showed the qpp the Quebec
Provincial Police uh
having experienced a substantial
increase uh in operators impaired by
cannabis after legalization there was a
recent article that attributed a
significant increase in the number of
operators arrested in the state of
Vermont uh our neighbor um related to
DUI arrest um of operators under the
influence of cannabis so um and again I
I'm not sure I don't know the answer as
to whether or not either Quebec or
Ontario have per se limits um and I know
that a number of states that have
commercialized have taken the step in
advance of commercialization to enact
laws that set very very low standard for
uh intoxication by cannabis in an effort
to ensure that um the to ensure the
safety of the roads and highways and the
ability to create an incentive for
operators in those States to not drive
all under the
influence any further
questions
represent thank you Mr chairman thank
you Chief uh for taking my question and
for your service I do have one question
about something you said and I it made
me scratch my head and you were talking
about the increased costs in law
enforcement in court for for the
investigation arrest prosecution and
Court time for illegal grow
operations and I guess I was confused
that because right now any grow
operation is illegal in the state of New
Hampshire except for the situation so
I'm not understand how that changes what
your cost is and how that adds an
expense to law enforcement because in
theory you're already investigating
those things and Prosecuting those
things sure thank you for your question
yeah that's predicated on the assumption
that uh once
commercialized that law enforcement's
Focus uh will be diverted
uh to other areas and means and that the
bar for conducting such investigations
uh involving cannabis which has already
been raised since we
decriminalized uh uh smaller quantities
of cannabis in New Hampshire uh
increases so as a result the illicit
marketeers will exploit the fact that
it's been commercialized and take an
opportunity to Edge out the legal Market
by being being able to produce uh
illicit marijuana at a much lower cost
um at just as good a quality if not
better than what the state can sell at
at a much lower price so in other states
and other areas it's a simple economic
equation supply and demand and cost uh
and we anticipate a significant increase
in illicit grow operations if
commercialized here in New
Hampshire also yeah I'm not sure that
answers my question but
okay any further
questions thank you thank you Mr Shar
thank
you
they're recording
those okay I have two cards here from
the banking
Association
uh first is
from Chrissy
Merill New Hampshire
bankers and neutral on the
bill Europe
thank you Mr
chair um chairman major Vice chair
brammy and honorable members of the
House Ways and Means Committee my name
is christe Merill I'm president of the
New Hampshire Bankers Association the
New Hampshire Bankers represent 37
member banks which employ nearly 6,000
employees um Mr chair we're here today
because um we are neutral on the policy
of weather or not cannabis should be
legal but we strongly are opposed to the
State Bank portion of the legislation
which um is in section five starting on
pages 9 through 11 um Mr chair I
understand you'd like um testimony focus
on Revenue we've not yet had the
opportunity to speak on the public bank
is that permissible or should I focus on
the revenue
sections since banking is a good is a
big part of this both okay thank you Mr
chair I appreciate that um we are
opposed to the State Bank proposal um
for several reasons um first off I'd
just like to say that we do not believe
a state bank is needed um we I listen to
the sponsor today and I understand that
this language is intended to be a back
stop to ensure that banking services are
available in the event that financial
services are not found in the private
sector we do understand the perception
that Banks do not Bank cannabis due to
the federal prohibition um however
finsen the financial crimes and
enforcement Network they have issued
guidance for financial institutions
seeking to provide services to marijana
related businesses which outlines a path
to do so um and I I do have copies of my
testimony that I provided to Jennifer um
and in that I can email it if it's
easier there is a link to that finsen
guidance right on your testimony if you
summarize it we have copies of it okay
very good um so one of the other points
I wanted to mention as to why we don't
think a state bank is needed um I've
also included with my testimony you'll
see a chart by finen um that shows that
there are over 600 Banks and Credit
Unions that are in this space around the
country um and you can look at that so I
want to make a very important Point um
we read the legislation to mean that as
it's drafted the state of New Hampshire
would be the customer um in in un with
that understanding and discussions with
our members um if this legislation is
passed the state can expect to Access
Financial Services from banks in New
Hampshire so we don't believe a state
bank is necessary for that reason um I'd
also like to just point out quickly that
we believe a state bank is Not Practical
and there are a lot of logistical
challenges to making this work um the
state of California they in 2018 they
completed a study I've also given that
study to um Jennifer's available if you
all would like that um and in their
study they reached the conclusion that a
public Bank is not feasible and would
Inc I'm sorry is not feasible and would
unavoidably incur a high risk of
criminal penalties and face other legal
impediments that cannot be eliminated um
I'd like to point out that in California
they looked at all types of public Banks
they looked at Credit Unions they looked
at um cannabis Banks only they looked at
cannabis Plus banking they looked at
fintech Solutions and in all of their
research They concluded that a public
Bank was not
feasible
um moving on so since uh so I wanted to
talk about why I why a State Bank um has
logistical challenges and there are two
really key points um because the
revenues will be derived only from
Cannabis the lack of diversification
ends up with a high concentration risk
based on the California study they have
two very important points as a result of
that high concentration risk first a
state bank will likely not be able to
get FDIC insurance
um currently for if you're a bank and
you would like to have a New Hampshire
Charter the banking department has to um
they require FDIC Insurance second um
another big point which I think was
referenced in some of the questions
today is um we believe that they would
not be eligible for a master account
with the Federal Reserve um for those of
you that are not aware of who may not be
familiar with that a master account with
a Fed Reserve is is required for the
day-to-day business of banking and it's
really crucial um and I do I know Mr
chair you've asked me to just be brief
um I do want to share a quote from the
study which I think really underscores
the importance of this point um so from
the study it reads um to be clear
without a master account issued by the
Federal Reserve the bank cannot function
it would have no ability to issue checks
or otherwise make payments other than in
cash and no ability to transfer funds to
other banks in short it would be in the
same predic ment currently faced by the
Cannabis businesses that it's supposed
to help the public bank would be a
network of cash vaults that would
provide customers with the ability to
transact businesses only with other
customers of the bank with no ability to
transact business outside of the public
Bank Network the public bank would be
holding large sums of cash that cannot
be invested or loaned without great risk
all subject to seizure by the federal
government um I really can't articulate
it any better than they did and so um
just another point I'd like to add is my
understanding is this would be one
physical bank and um in discussions with
our members we they believe that this
really is going to require additional
infrastructure um meaning additional
branches and cash Services throughout
the
state um getting to the financial
picture of a State Bank um the bill
provides 10 million in capital to start
it and I it's not clear to me but in the
fiscal note that I saw dated I think 12
1321 um I did not see a reference to the
$10 million in capital for um to start
up the bank and I'm not sure in if in
the sponsors estimates if that 14
million he's referencing includes the 10
million for the State Bank um but just
to in in discussions with our members
and also looking at the California study
I'd like to point out that it's it's
likely to cost significantly more um
than the 10 million to get the Bank off
the ground about how much um I will tell
you representative major that one of our
members h a sort of a back of the napkin
rough estimate and would say $50 million
um we don't know what that is exactly
but one of the things that I'd like to
point out is you know if you're a bank
and you are not deploying your funds
through your lending you do have to have
certain Capital requirements and so
because presumably that deposit base
would continue to grow they'd have to
maintain those Capital ratios which
means the state would have to continue
to inject funds into the bank to
maintain those Capital
ratios um we know that we now have 37
states that have legalized medicinal
marijuana and 18 states that have
legalized recreational um and so we
really believe and it's likely that the
St the states will force the federal
government to address uh cannabis on a
federal level in the near future um in
in the states that I mentioned before
with the the 37 and the 18 we're not
aware of a single public bank that
supports the Cannabis
industry the safe Banking Act um we're
very supportive of that and that would
give protection to Bankers um they would
give regulatory protection when Bankers
work with marijuana related businesses
where it's legally permissible by the
states um that legislation has
bipartisan support it supported the
house the US House five times and it's
still very much in play this year um and
some believe that will be addressed one
way or another in the next 10 years so
given the momentum on this issue around
the country and nationally you know I we
just have to ask the question is this a
Sound Investment for the state because
of the the expense to run a state bank
and to start one
up um Additionally the there are
significant legal and financial risks
for the state the state employees the
managers anyone
affiliated with the sale manufactured
distribution or dispensing of C cannabis
are exposed to significant liability and
they can be prosecuted under federal law
um and the funds could be S they could
be subjected to seizure by the federal
government I know that came up
earlier um I've also included it's
attached to my testimony the um the
Attorney General in California they he
issued um a one-page memo and in that
memo they conclude that it's it's simply
too risky for them to move forward and
so I've included that for you as
well um particularly re relating to um
the financial picture you know one of
the points that we wanted to make is um
the private sector they leverage funds
and if there's a public Bank um we don't
believe that's going to happen it's it's
not clear in the legislation if it's
intended that the public bank would
actually be in the business of lending
but it does say it has the powers of a
depository Bank um so we assume that
it's not intended um and so there would
most definitely be a loss of opportunity
into our community
every single day our banks um deploy
funds and they support um homeowners
they support business owners by
providing access to Capital and this
would be a missed
opportunity a state bank would be
diverting These funds away from
supporting our op um our economy and
deprive the state of tax revenue which
local banks
pay um and then just on the history of
State Bank proposals uh by our count um
it's been attempted six times in the
past 15 years here um in New Hampshire
and every single time the um legislature
has decided that that is not the
appropriate course of action for the
state um around the country between 1917
and 2017 there were 29 public banks that
have been chartered there are only two
that are in operation today um and those
are two I think pretty extenda
circumstances um so I think the evidence
shows it's just not
necessary and then lastly um we believe
that this is a is a slippery slope um I
understand that um it's this is really
supposed to be a back stop but I'd like
to point out that even though it talks
about contingent Financial Services I
did not see an actual contingency Clause
um typically it's certified by the
Secretary of State um I didn't see that
in here um maybe I missed it but um as
it's drafted it would put a State Bank
in statute and we really believe that
even though it's very narrow in scope
today it's very easy to expand that in
the future um and we believe that would
that would compete with Private Industry
so um in closing we don't believe this
is necessary and believe it faces many
log logistical challenges um so for all
these reasons we would urge the the
committee to reject the State Bank um
and to amend the bill by removing the
relevant sections so I'm happy to try to
answer any questions you may
have representative Bry followed by
representative elme okay thank you Mr
chair thank you for your testimony uh
yes on page 11 of the bill on line 11 is
the $10 million figure okay that's being
requested but did I hear you correctly
you're saying that that's not really a
what it's going to take to fund this
it's that's discussions with our members
and looking at the California study we
do think that's on the low side and what
do you think it would be you said did
you say 50 million 50 million one of our
members did sort of a just a rough
estimate on what they think the capital
is going to be necessary and as I said
if if those funds are not continually
deployed into the community and if you
assume that deposit base continues to
grow you're going to have to continue to
inject funds into the state bank to make
sure you maintain the appropriate
Capital ratios okay and one one other
question Mr chair so when you when you
quoted the study was it California study
that's correct is this the study we're
talking about yes I don't know if all
the members have
this I think your associate Ryan your
associate gave this to me the other day
when I saw him in and I had 25 five
copies for you do have copies for
everybody okay thank you if they'd like
yes all right thank
you representative Aly followed by
representative Murphy thank you uh Mr
chairman on page 10 starting line 17 is
what you were looking for uh they would
not um they require first that liquor do
an analysis which I think would take a
year on and find out if local banks
would be interested and upon receipt of
the notice that they have not found any
uh the business Finance Authority shall
be authorized to incorporate own and
operate a single-purpose depositary bank
which I think you've covered quite well
what that would mean but I did want to
ask you I think I remember that the
reason so many private Banks were able
to get involved in the
marijuana uh area was that somebody in a
major Federal Institution decided that
if you didn't have more than 15% or
something like that of your loans out in
marijuana that you would be
okay um I'm not familiar with that
exactly but what I can tell you is um
it's it's referenced in the California
studi then one of their conclusions is
to let the private sector get into this
business and they they expect that it
would continue that the private uh
banking system will continue to Bank in
this space and part of the reason is
because it's a it's a a bank can decide
how much percentage of that portfolio it
will be that they would like it to be
whereas if the state goes into the
business and it's 100% of um their
portfolio then it's obviously a high
concentration
risk yes just short followup but that is
the state of California defi deciding
for itself but this was uh a major part
of the banking apparatus of the federal
government I'm not familiar
representative but I do know that um
what was known as the co memo um I
believe was issued by attorney us
attorney general Cole that talked about
um law enforcement not going after the
banking industry or other Industries um
and then I think there were different
people that said to ignore that so I'm
not sure if that's what you're
referencing I'm I'm just not familiar
with that representative I'm sorry this
was about four or five years ago but I
do remember there was a specific
percentage that if you went above it you
were in trouble and if you didn't you
were fine okay okay you're all set yeah
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for your
testimony to take my question uh the
sponsor mentions that the state bank
would be Plan B a backup system you list
about 40 or so banks that are members in
your organization would the majority of
those Banks be able to serve as the bank
for marijuana you know related
businesses um they would be able to it's
it's a it's a business decision as to
whether and that they they decide to um
I think based on the revenue projections
will be really important to um I think
that will determine how many banks are
necessary I think you're going to
probably need several I don't think
it'll be just one um I think it will
probably have to be several but um any
of the banks any of our members has the
ability to do so it's simply a business
decision but um as I said I have um they
are the banks Our member banks are aware
of this legislation they're aware of the
proposal um and as it's proposed with
the state as the customer we do believe
there will be interest and then we we do
believe there will be banking services
available in the private sector so so
what you're saying is that they have the
capability of doing it do you know if
many of them have said signal that they
would be willing to do it
yes repr that's that's what I'm saying
is we have had members tell us that they
would pursue this if this becomes law
thank
you further questions represent lion
thank you so again if I'm if I want to
just be really clear on what you just
said was that under the availability of
banking services line on page nine where
it talks about um the commission will
create a study and the study will look
at whether or not there's financial
services and on the opt the only rate
way a State Bank gets created as as a a
belt and suspender solution is that if
the study says there's no banking
services available and and and you don't
think that would be the outcome of the
study the study would be that there are
banking services readily available to
people within the state of New Hampshire
under this if this legislation would
pass that's correct and is it it's my
understanding there's already one and I
don't want to use the name of it but
there's already a bank being used by
some of the
atc's um in the state of New Hampshire
that is that is controlled Within State
of New Hampshire so right off the bat I
can think of the mere fact we have one
bank that's already doing it the study
would find nothing and the contingency
plan would never be hit is that correct
that's that's my belief and and we would
ask that we I guess we would just say
that the the section isn't necessary um
and that that Banks could handle it and
um it it may be a technical point and
maybe it's a question for OS but like I
said it does refer to contingent
Financial Services um but I believe
there are sometimes an actual section in
the back near the effective dates that
contingency and effective date and it
gets certified and that kind of thing I
didn't see that in here maybe I missed
it um but as it reads it would simply
put the section into statute so we would
we just think it's a dangerous
proposition to do
that Bernstein thank you Mr chair thank
you for your testimony and taking my
question on page two where you refer to
the safe Banking Act there's one
sentence in there which is sort of in
congruent with everything else you talk
about how there's B partisan support and
then the last sentence says that there's
a lot of momentum around this issue but
the sentence that really troubles me
some believe this will be addressed one
way or another within 10 years yes what
happened to all the momentum and
bipartisan support how do you get to
that 10
year all I can tell you I think in
talking with our members we have been
advocating for the safe Banking Act for
several years and um we work very
closely with people in Washington um on
federal issues
particularly as it relates to this and
they believe this is the best session
the best chance we've had in a long time
to pass it so the statement is that it's
commonly believed that within the next
between 1 to 10 years that this will be
addressed either by more and more States
re legalizing this in one form or
another and it's going to force
Washington to do that so the the the
bigger point that um I was trying to
convey representative was that given the
high cost
um to the state of New Hampshire to
start this up and then maintain this um
would it become irrelevant or moot if it
is addressed at the federal level and is
it a Sound Investment for the state okay
I appreciate your answer thank you
sure further
questions repr preach thank you Mr
chairman uh and thank you for taking my
question uh I believe the two Banks one
of them is North Dakota I don't know
what the other one is but uh what do you
attribute to their success because they
have been successful over a number of
years yes um thank you for that question
I wrote it down because I knew someone
would ask um yes in 1919 it was the Bank
of North Dakota and I believe they have
one location and now it's uh it and they
were started because there were no other
banking services available to them um
the other one is a newer one within the
last five years it's the territorial
Bank of American Samoa um in my
understanding is the Bank of Hawaii left
and they had virtually no banking
services
available followup followup uh what do
you attribute to success I mean just
because they there's no other Banks but
and what what was their Capital to start
with if you know I'm sorry
representative I don't know that um I
could try to find out but um I know that
in working with some of my colleagues
because as I said a state bank has um
that's a that's an issue that is often
visited um here in in our state house um
and talking with some of my colleagues I
understand that the Bank of North Dakota
has said don't follow our model so um
I'm not sure how you would gauge success
but I and we'll see how the the
territorial Bank of America Samoa is um
if they truly if that really is the only
provider of financial services I would
say that's why they are
successful further
questions saying none thank you very
much thank you the next
is
emmaa
grian
okay all right thank you from the New
Hampshire banking Department she's the
chief Bank
examiner uh no position taken on the
bill and you have somebody else with you
I do um so for the record my name is
Amelia galerian I'm the bank
commissioner for the State of New
Hampshire and uh with me is Chief Bank
Examiner Wells
okay thank uh we're from the New
Hampshire banking Department thank you
for taking our testimony today um so um
the focus of Our Testimony is obviously
going to be on uh the sections of the
bill related to the availability of
banking services that start on page nine
um I don't want to rehash too much at
chrisy with the bankers Association did
a good job and a lot of my testimony was
kind of going to overlap with what she
said so I'm going to try not to rehash
that um we are we have no position on
the underlying policy of this bill um
any commentary we're going to provide is
going to be focused on the feasibility
and any technical nuances related to uh
banking regulation um a high level
summary of um what we're about to talk
about is um number one um you likely
don't need a public or State Bank to do
um what this bill is trying to do um and
two if the legislature
um makes a policy decision to establish
a State Bank um it's likely going to
cost significantly more than this bill
explains or or
anticipates um so first and I don't want
to belabor this point because I think um
the bankers Association just testified
to it but um as you're aware several
States including our surrounding states
of Maine Vermont and Massachusetts have
already legalized marijuana and none of
those states have required a state State
Bank to to bank the marijuana business
um as um Christy merell testified
there's finson guidance out there that
that um provides a pathway for um
private Banks to bank this business um
so there's there's nothing um
technically preventing them from doing
it
um in in anticipation of this uh
testimony Chief Bank examiner Wells did
reach out to um our his counterpart in
Maine just to kind of find out um how
that works in Maine um and I'm H we can
answer any questions about that I don't
want to belabor it though too much
because I know this is not policy a
policy driven uh committee um but we do
have that information if you are
interested um and I you know I I think
it's reason reasonable to anticipate
that if New Hampshire moves this bill
forward um New Hampshire chartered banks
will likely move in into this area of
business um so that's kind of the first
point that I'm not sure that a State
Bank is going to be or a public bank is
going to be
required um so moving on to the more um
kind of technical aspects of it and the
financial aspects of it um like I said I
think this is going to cost way more
than this bill anticipates if you decide
to move it forward um like how much uh
well that's a good question because as
established nobody's really done this
before um so right now the kind of going
capitalization rate for a plain vanilla
private bank is about $20 million give
or take that's set by the FDIC under our
law if you file an application with us
you're required to obtain FDIC Insurance
the FDIC with their regulations um
really is the driving force setting the
capital amount um so in our experience
about $20 million for for a vanilla Bank
this Bank obviously would be um very
different than anything else out there
so likely that number is going to be um
much higher I think in the California
study they had 65 million as the capital
requirement but again it's hard to
predict exactly because California is
much bigger than New Hampshire um so
that's the capitalization part of it um
moving there's other costs though that
are associated with establishing a state
bank or a state Chartered bank with us
um so so first off there's an
application process which this bill
anticipates um that somebody would file
an applica the organizers I guess would
file an application with us I think the
it's the business Finance Authority I
think is the anticipated organizer um so
they would file an application with us I
don't have a figure for exactly how much
it costs a private entity to file an
application with us all I can speak to
is how much we charge for it so that's
kind of I'm not sure sure if that's
something I can work with um the bankers
Association to see if somebody could
give a ballpark figure for that but it
is you have to hire attorneys you have
to develop a business plan there's um
significant accounting costs that go
into it um it is not cheap to form a
bank um our fee for forming a state bank
is
$155,000 however um we have built into
our statute that um it's kind of like
the think of the $155,000 as a retainer
that you file with us and once we we
charge our time so we track our time so
um Chief Bank examiner Wells as he
investigates an application we'll track
his time and everyone else in the office
tracks their time and once we exceed
that $155,000 we start billing so
basically at the end if somebody gets a
charter they also get a bill for us for
whatever is in excess of that
$15,000 um the uh provision that enables
us to charge for that time is relatively
new um it just came into effect on
October 9th so we don't have a lot lot
of case studies and how much that costs
we do have a denovo bank pending right
now um but it's pending we're working on
it right now so I I can't give you an
exact figure for how much that's going
to cost um my anti my suspicion is it
will cost more than $15,000 to Charter a
denovo plain vanilla Bank um probably
something like this I'd imagine will be
a complicated application it'll probably
take the FDIC a significant amount of
time to process that application it'll
probably take us you know
correspondingly at some time to process
it um what kind of time
table so ballpark um I'm trying to think
so we again we've never tracked our time
before so this is a relatively new fure
month oh no so um half year uh well um
so I can tell you under our statutes
there is a time frame for processing an
application um so um somebody files an
application with us we have 30 days to
determine it's substantially complete
when they file the application with us
they also file them with the FDIC the
FDIC similarly has they call it
something else but it's that same
determination period of initial 30 days
I can tell you we're pretty good about
meeting that 30 days we're going to tell
you if something's missing um the FDIC
if it's a complicated Bank sometimes it
gets kicked to DC and it can take
significantly longer than that um those
30 days um once an application is
substantially complete we then move into
our substantive review phase which is
what um Todd and his team do um they
conduct a complete investigation into
the application um and um produce a
report um that's reviewed by the office
um so that time period is 60 days on our
end but again that could be extended if
we need more information and I think
it's probably reasonable to expect that
in a very um different application like
this we would need um it might take
longer than 60
days but again we have teams of so it's
man hours that we track for the billing
okay um so you know that's that's um
kind of a ballpark of the cost so again
those are I was thinking as I was
listening to the testimony we just
completed a fiscal note worksheet for
this bill and we focused on the going
forward costs from our perspective so
like or I guess they would be Revenue so
we're a self-funded agency were funded
through fees and fines that we charge to
the entities that we regulate and at the
end if we have um an O uh shortfall in
our in our amount we then charge an
assessment of everyone who's chartered
or licensed with
us um so when we were completing the
fiscal note worksheet we were focusing
on what we would charge to like examine
a bank like this what we would charge to
Charter it but there's other cost that
the state would have to look at which is
the cost to file the application with us
and you really need all those experts to
do that so I'm not sure it occurred to
me as I was listening to this testimony
I was like oh I don't know we didn't
really note that in the fiscal note
worksheet and it's a little strange
because we're a state agency that
doesn't rely we get no General funds so
this would be like taking money from the
general fund and paying us um for what
it's worth it's a little unusual I'm not
sure if we've had a situ well I know
we've never at the bank we' never had a
situation like this um so I think that
covers
capitalization um the
application um I did want to mention
although um Miss Merl mentioned it that
the Federal Reserve is unlikely to issue
a master account to this bank which
would basically make it unfeasible to
trans to transmit funds or wire money um
basically what is a master account
sure so very important element with the
with the financial system is just the
ability to to transmit funds so if we
think of just a general scenario uh
retail banking for example uh quite
often customers can pay in cash they
might be able to pay in uh check uh
debit card credit cards so that usually
is going to require an account at a
financial institution by that retailer
by that company that business and so
most often and what what I'm aware of
occurs in in these types of businesses
we'll call them cannabis related
businesses um I just want to also
clarify that a lot of the information
that we have as a department relative to
these types of businesses comes from our
communication and our interactions with
our other Regulators state and federal
Regulators so the reality is we you know
we do not generally see scenarios where
New Hampshire chartered Banks and credit
unions are actively banking these types
of accounts so but but but again to to
be able to to accept that money and then
to to go and collect through the
financial system there there needs to be
an account at an an in an insured uh
depository institution and they can
process those payments and quite often
the the Federal Reserve is going to be
through the automated Clearing House is
going to be really just that Central
facility that that that allows that to
happen so that's called the master
account
right I I wanted to just add one other
thing relative to the application and
this is an important element so
commissioner galeri talked about the
likely uh initial capitalization
required for a depository institution
from the standpoint of uh from banking
Regulators uh federal and state capital
is absolutely important and we've heard
previous uh testimony this afternoon
about you know what that is whether it's
Capital ratios net worth ratios the
reality is those ratios um have to be
maintained at a certain level per the
federal statutes and as that
organization grows as the the assets and
then the underlying liabilities the
deposits of that organization grows
there would be an expectation that
additional Capital would be there to
maintain those important Capital uh
capital and net worth measures capitals
as you know I'm talking to the house
Ways and Means here so it's it's capital
is a Ultra imperative to absorb it's a
to a cushion to absorb losses it can
margin growth and the The Regulators
this is these are very important
measures and I want to also mention from
the standpoint of the application uh the
FDIC has been very clear as they process
and as they look at applications for
Deposit Insurance for what's known as a
new a denovo depository bank they want
to see profitability from that bank
within the first three years and so if
there's and there's got to be very
detailed Financial projections that get
reviewed very closely by uh by the by
those approving Regulators uh if if
those financials aren't there to show
profitability within three years it it's
pretty much a fatal a fatal
scenario and I think just to add on to
that one thing that like and I think the
California study that you guys have does
do a very good job of explaining this
basically any change in the federal
landscape will potentially tank this you
know so if the feds if the federal
government makes this legal you won't
need a State Bank anymore right so then
the State Bank goes out of business and
all the money that you've invested is
gone um but if they suddenly change and
start Prosecuting the this situation um
same same scenario the the bank that
you've just created is is out of
business um so it is a pretty risky
Endeavor to um start a public bank and
should not be taken lightly
um
uh another another issue that I just
wanted to flag for everyone that is very
unique to this bill um so the AG is
going to be on the board I believe
believe and also um everyone who works
for the State Bank is indemnified and
will be represented by the doj in the
offense that something goes wrong um one
of the things that could potentially go
wrong is the banking Department could
bring in enforcement action if we're
going to be the regulator um so we'd be
um but the doj also represents us I
don't think there's anyone here from the
doj but that's a cost coming at you from
both sides um that I don't think we were
quite sure how to um C in a fiscal note
um it would be like the state bringing
enforcement action against the state
being defended by the state um so that's
kind of a an interesting little uh
conundrum that I just wanted to
highlight for everyone um that's a
little unusual um very so I we're happy
to answer any questions anyone might
have I think that's
everything um represented
hunt
unencumbered sitting sitting there
waiting waiting for for it to be burned
away um because there's going to be
that's like they talk about Todd can
probably speak this a little bit we
expect to see a capital burn when a bank
is first started up and it's to cushion
that burn you're paying for employees
you're paying for all sorts of stuff um
and in fact so what we do is we as the
chartering Authority in New Hampshire we
accept the the applicants application to
the FDIC for Deposit Insurance we accept
that as they say the application for a
New Hampshire chart or for a denova
depository bank I know that just from
experience one of the very specific
questions in that FDIC application is to
to inquire of the applicant is any of
those initial capitalization funds were
they loan from elsewhere does the app
did the applicant borrow those funds so
that's something that's a very specific
fact element Andor and as we maybe you
can push it back just do the trick um as
as we said earlier I think 20 million is
probably not going to cut it so um it's
going to be significantly more than
that okay uh representative spillsbury
followed by representative Bry thank you
Mr chairman yeah I your comment about
the um the board of directors um was
something I was going to hit there's
only three
individuals and uh the conflicts and
entanglements are inseparable uh which
takes me back to other language that had
me scratching my head on page
10 uh in lines 19 through 25 there are
two
sentences that I think I I can't exactly
reconcile them but I think they
illustrate the public private tension uh
in creating a Public state-owned public
Bank the single purpose depository Bank
shall be created as a body corporate and
politic having a distinct legal
existence separate from the state and
not constituting a department of state
government having the powers and
jurisdictions etc etc and then the next
sentence goes on to say that it shall be
deemed uh and held to be the performance
of public and essential governmental
functions of the state and uh you know
somebody might be a explain it to me but
that just sounds like um there is no
distinct separation between control and
operation yeah and I that's why I wanted
to point out the the line um and I'm
sorry I'm not going to find it very
quickly but the one about
indemnification in RSA 99d um because
that's basically if you're a state
employee um and the doj would be better
to explain that comes up on page 11 uh
down on lines uh 16 through 19 yeah the
the and I'm I don't want to say it
incorrectly but my high level kind of
understanding as a state employe is the
doj will represent us um in certain
scenarios and um our actions are sort of
indemnified I'm probably misstating that
because I'm not the expert in it um
luckily I've not been sued too many
times so I don't have to know about it
um but that is a conflict there it seems
to be that they're expecting this
employees of the State Bank to sort of
be state employees sort of um but then
that sentence I don't know there's
something I don't know quite how to
reconcile that representative
Bry I just want to say hello to Mr Wells
who was uh on the commission marijuana
commission several years ago on this
when we were looking at at legalization
back then um but you're you're here
because this is a this is going to be a
uh a state charted bank now if this was
going to be well do you do you cover
federal chared banks as well no just
State Banks correct and uh of your
members I thought I thought I heard that
none of your members within not members
you know in that umbrella of State
charted banks are there any that are
interested in uh in banking I know way
back when the answer was no banking uh
cannabis right I will tell you I have
not had that specific discussion yet
with any of our institutions and and as
was alluded to earlier that would be a
bit business decision by those New
Hampshire chartered Banks or credit
unions uh I think I think it's very
likely it's possible that some of those
would be out there what I deal with is
is the here and now and what what I you
know per my understanding of the New
Hampshire chartered Banks currently we
have 16 and of the nine New Hampshire
Charter Credit Unions none of them are
actively banking what would be known as
marijana related businesses now I just I
I want to say that the term I I agree
the term should probably be can abis but
from the standpoint of uh state and
federal Regulators one of the the big
elements the big focal points of the
examiners as they look at these programs
of those institutions they go back we've
heard finsen was issued referenced
earlier the financial crimes enforcement
Network they have guidance out there
that that currently uh is very
reflective of the Cole memo that had
been issued under the the uh New
Hampshire Department or excuse me the
the US Department of Justice and so the
the uh
pretty much permeating the uh the the
bank speak from The Regulators and the
law enforcement is they talk about
marijuana marijuana related businesses
suspicious activity reports and then
there's marijuana limited marijuana
priority and marijuana termination
reports that are issued as part of those
suspicious activity
reports uh representa Aaron thank you Mr
chair thank you thank you for your
testimony today so if I understand you
would be seeking to have um line 10 from
page 10 all the way to line
19 on page 11 of this bill stripped
out um that's line 10 of page 10 all the
way to line 19 of page 11 well so we're
not taking a position on the policy if
the state were to decide despite I you
know obviously there are public Banks
out there there's two in existence um
under very different circumstances than
what's being discussed so I think that's
a policy decision of the state whether
or not to establish a State Bank um all
we're testifying to is that there's
significant problems with how this is
drafted um and if the state were to do
this it would have to probably look
significantly different from this um to
make it work if it was even workable
thank you
further
questions saying none thank you thank
you next
is Paul
merti from
conqu representing East Coast cannabis
yes sir yes representative um we just
want to pass out some things um the uh
you guys been talking about infused
products we just want to let you know
that these are in our jars we man
products but the bullets aren't in them
we wanted to show you what it was like
without the THC in it so this is this is
what we sell uh with THC in it uh to uh
customers that come to our store in
Elliot main a recreational store that's
open um and I wanted you guys that you
know I was going to leave them you can
just throw them out after but there's
nothing there's no THC in this is what
you'd be buying in a store with THC in
it you were
buies a
child
those are gummies and we sell them
mostly to believe it or not to people
over 50
sleep um we'd also I you guys could pass
these
around talking out in the middle in a
minute okay and uh just wanted to show
you we're so we're a we're a vertically
integrated cannabis business we have
60,000 Square ft of cultivation licenses
so any of the questions you want to an
ask about cultivation after or anything
else the stuff everybody's been talking
about that the medical people there and
the adult juice cannabis people here
we're cringing when we're listening to
this because it it's it's so far from
what the real business is like that
we're we've actually done it uh we were
on the uh if anybody's interested we
were on the cover of the Portsmouth
Herald February 3rd last thir Thursday
with our business and uh you know well I
will uh I'll stick to my I'll read the
testimony and uh myself and and uh Ryan
here is also a partner of mine in East
Coast cannabis he's one of the founders
so anyhow we will restrict Our Testimony
in ways and means to financial matters
in the bill and structural and legal
problems to assess risk and
profitability or loss if this bill were
to pass everyone mistaka believes the
Cannabis industry is a gold rush
evidently the state of New Hampshire
agrees by considering this bill let's
start by looking at the stock history of
the biggest players in the Cannabis
business over the last few years canopy
Holdings in Canada which we've talked
about Canada the largest cannabis
company in the world their stock is off
by 85% from highs acreage Holdings one
of the larges cannabis companies in the
US their stock price is off almost 80%
of highs Mary advisers another very big
cannabis company headquartered in
Massachusetts was trading just over $5 a
share at its highest point and is now
somewhere around 74 cents fluctu dayto
day losing
85% something to consider before jumping
into investing many millions of New
Hampshire taxpayer money into a risky
State Venture we will identify just a
few issues in HB 1598 that make it
unsupportable and believe me there's
many more structurally in the Cannabis
industry the model submitted in this
bill simply won't work not just the fact
it will be challenging to make a profit
for the state but worse the supply chain
of products won't work here's why the
bill proposes 15 private licensed State
cannabis cultiv to grow the Cannabis
products for 10 State Stores I have
spoken with six successful commercial
cannabis cultivators in Maine and
Massachusetts including our company some
of the biggest ones in the industry but
not one of us would accept a contract to
cultivate with the state of New
Hampshire under this bill unless the
state agreed to buy our entire crop
regardless if the state stores are
overstocked or the state buyer doesn't
want the product or for any other reason
we cannot grow expensive crops for the
state that if the state buyer doesn't
want to buy those crops for any reason
we will have to pay to destroy what we
just paid a million dollars to grow
since the state is the only buyer we
would spend Millions to set up
cultivation businesses for State for the
state only to have potentially destroy
what you just spent Millions to grow no
one would do that but on the other hand
if the state agrees to buy all products
grown they will be the ones with
millions and spoiled crops they have to
pay to destroy this is a vegetable it
spoils which of course will bankrupt the
entire program also what a cannabis
cultivation gets paid for their product
and what sets the market price is state
by state and prices are determined by
state supply and demand and two-way
negotiations between countless buyers
and sellers just like the Liquor
Commission buys all of their liquor but
this bill instead proposes proposes a
single state approved buyer to negotiate
and set State buying prices for any and
all qualities of product the model is
untenable to the cultivator since the
fate of their expensive crop and the
price and terms are going to to be
dictated by their only state buyer who
also controls the renewal of their
license that is no way a free an open
market and won't work in a free and open
market the next issue in this bill only
allows cannabis flow to be old sold at
the stores like we've covered before but
cannabis and fuse products which won't
be legal for adult use represent about
half of adult youth retail sales just so
everyone knows in our store that's 45
minutes from here we sell 50% cannabis
infused products now you might wonder
where they come I'm getting to that it
is like selling is like having a bar
that doesn't sell beer that's what this
this bill's about worse cannabis plant
trim and substandard cannabis flour
which is very expensive to produce have
their oils extracted and made into
cannabis infused product this accounts
again for 50% of cannabis products sold
in retail stores a large about quart
siiz job
of cannabis oil is worth $10,000 so you
have an idea but this bill specifically
excludes the legalization of infused
cannabis products to the adult use
Market thereby robbing the state stores
of 50% of their gross sales and
bankrupting all the cultivators because
the most expensive product that they
produce that makes up 50% of cannabis
products sold in retail stores will have
to be paid to get destroyed by the
cultivator because it is illegal to sell
except to the state under this program
something the Bill's author nor the
state was even aware of I am sure
regarding legal matters I wrote to repa
boss who is the primary sponsor of the
bill which I wrote I am curious how you
plan to sell around the inherent
problems with the state selling cannabis
which I have seen legal discussions
about many times the consensus legal
opinion is that it is a nonstarter
because a state employee can't be
subjected to Breaking federal law think
about it the next president we elect may
choose to actually follow cannabis laws
and have the FDA and Federal Marshals
make an example out of all 10 of the New
Hampshire State adult used Cannabis
stores who who own the only cannabis
business in the US who won't be paying
any business profit taxes to the federal
government under 280e my partner Ryan
will talk about that in a in a couple of
minutes what an absolute disaster that
will be if all 10 State Stores get
raided At Once by Federal Marshals and
the da who are cuffing and arresting
state employees for breaking federal
laws state cultivators and manufacturers
could be R also be wrapped into this
action also there is also problems with
wrongful termination Let Me Explain If
you hire somebody to be what we call a
bun tender a cashier to sell cannabis at
the counter and they think about it and
they walk in and then when they get a
chance to sell it they say to the boss
of the store I'm not going to sell this
I'm not selling something that's federal
legal I could get in trouble if we fire
that employee that's wrongful
termination because we can't force them
to violate a federal law uh you might
not want to be the governor who signed
that bill uh repa boss the author of the
bill responded to
me I quote I would be surprised if the
federal government took any action to
enforce federal laws on can and single
out just New Hampshire I was very
surprised at his answerer and I
submitted to you a handout and if you
look at the handout okay let me explain
this to you so in case you wonder if the
feds are going to come to come for us in
Florida Federal Marshall sees more than
7 207,000 used unrated dietary
supplements containing katum for those
of you who aren't who don't understand
what katum is they sell it in stores in
New Hampshire it's a supplementary diet
diet product and it comes from a tree
it's an evergreen tree grown in like
Indonesia and it's basically a
replacement for painkillers and it's
very very addictive so what happened was
one of the go federal government doesn't
like it even though it's totally legal
and it's been made legal for topical use
and now it's being consumed all over the
United States in giant quantities and in
Alabama there was one guy that owned all
the stores just about and they decided
they were going to make an example out
of him so they went into his stores the
FDA and the Federal Marshals and they
arrested him and they took all his
product and they noticed who was
supplying it it was bug big supplier in
federal Florida then they went up there
with about 20 Federal Marshals and FDA
and walked in the front door pulled the
owner of the company out and made him
fire all the 50 of his employees They
seized all his goods and they they put
yellow tape around it and they told the
owner that if he even touched it or
anybody was allowed in the building that
they'd put him in federal prison and
that he was going to have to pay
$250,000 to throw it out now if you're
wondering why I have all the details of
this to tell you it was my brother it
was his business so when a when a
representative abas said he'd be
surprised I can tell you something my
brother was surprised if I go see him
right now almost a year later that look
still on his face and so so anyhow I
wanted to cover those issues we'd be
happy to answer questions at the end but
I'm going to let the last part of it my
my partner Ryan uh take care of take us
out do you have a copy of your testimony
you could I I I do and I'm going to send
it to all you I've been sending a lot of
what you guys are talking about to uh
representative abrami you know that's
one of I was so familiar with a lot of
it so thank you so just narrowing down
and focusing on really what I saw
throughout the budget so as an operator
of a vertically integrated adult used
company uh I think your budget is the
budget in this bill specifically is
fairly unrealistic as far the as far as
the assumptions that are being made uh
you know from inventory only being at
70,000 can you move the mic closer is
that can is that good there we go I
think that some of the initial concerns
with your budget is for instance is the
initial inventory so for instance you
allocate $70,000 per store we're opening
a store another store in two weeks and
we'll have roughly 200 50 to
$300,000 on hand as we open wholesale
correct uh on the wholesale front
additionally some of your additional
costs that you lay that are laid out in
this budget from Furnishings point of
sale to training are all significantly
I'd say under budget probably by about
two to three times what it would really
take um some of the other broader
concerns of what I saw throughout the
budget is it really comes down to the
buying process of how it would work so
as the as representative boss said that
you know someone may investing 5 to 7
million but in a market where it could
cost anywhere from $500 to $1,200 a
pound to produce if the state decides to
say well we want to be competitive and
we're only going to buy it at X dollars
now you're putting the pressure on the
cultivator that they must be able to
produce at a price point that may not be
either sustainable or profitable for
them as an
entity um so overall I think that the
entire budget has substantial issues on
its initial assumptions and just to harp
on one other element which was I know we
heard a lot on the banking front but in
multiple St States banking Credit Unions
all of those Services have been
available to the Cannabis industry uh
it's not easy uh to say the very least
but those services do exist often times
it's through a credit union uh the fees
are expensive uh transporting is done
often times by you know you as a company
can do it or you hire third party
resources to handle that um but that's
just kind of an initial Glimpse at at
that aspect one other element to touch
on was
uh what the um police chief mentioned
and according to the uh this was a study
done by the Department of Justice um
back in 2019 the purpose of the study
was to evaluate what does marijuana
legalization and decriminalization how
it impacts the states their overall
analysis concluded a few points one was
that legalizing the recreational use of
marijuana resulted in fewer marijuana
related arrests and court cases two
legalizing marijuana did not have
noticeable impact on indicators in
states that bordered those legalized
States and three there are no noticeable
indications of an increase in arrests
related to the transportation
trafficking offenses in those States as
well so all of this information we will
be able to provide which directly
contradicts
our respectfully the Bedford police
chief uh on literally every issues and
their and their reach out of the hand
into into the budget it it's cont
contradicted by the federal government
who isn't a fan of cannabis to start
with
so any anyway any questions any
questions questions representative BR
yeah thank you Mr chair thank you for
your testimony um you mentioned a few
things uh shelf
life what is a shelf life shelf life
first of all it's cured let me let me
clear something else up
representative uh I'm
sorry rep representative of brami's uh
um explanation which he gave me also
that basically what was going to happen
just like it happens in liquor stores is
let's say we decide we need a particular
strain of cannabis that was selling good
in our shelves and now I want to go back
to the cultivator and I want to say hey
I want to order 500 lb well we're not
producing widgets and gigs were're
growing in specific rooms of specific
sizes and let me tell you how it goes so
they'd come in and they'd order the
Cannabis well first of all we don't have
empty rooms waiting we have millions
invested in these Ventures so we have
cannabis growing if we didn't have the
right strain we'd have to and strains
are proprietary to each supplier
generally speaking there's some
commercial Plains but they're
proprietary so what we' do is we take
the order we'd wait till the room is
empty then we'd cut clones off from
other plants we'd put clones in the
ground it would take a couple of two or
three weeks to grow the Clones we'd move
them into What's called the veg St stage
okay and the veg stage takes a few weeks
to a month they grow the plants bigger
the veg stage happens when we put the
lights on 18 hours a day what the plant
perceives is summertime to grow then
what happens is when the plants get big
enough after a few weeks we put them in
budding stage which the only difference
is we turn the lights on for 12 hours
instead of 18 hours okay cuz they think
it's the fall and it's time to Bud and
put their seeds out for the fall and
then
after that couple months there we cut
the plants and then we have to cure the
plants which can take 45 to 60 days then
we trim the plants then we got to
package the plants and by the time we
Supply his order it's going to be 6
months later and the shelf's going to
have something else on it and maybe he
don't want it and I just spent 10 $2
million growing it cuz a new strains uh
come out um and but directly to your
question of shelf life which was really
generally that you're looking at once it
gets into a store there are some broad
ranges but I would say four to 6 months
is what we personally stand by because
you can have degradation of product you
can have those imp you misorder then
you're you're out or the store is out
because it goes spoils it's like milkco
spoil well correct I mean the idea of
yeah exactly right I mean you you but
the idea here too of by not allowing
infused products you also cut off the
ability to use call it some
unsatisfactory product that the consumer
now want visually to put into those
other products yeah go ahead what he
means is before before the product
spoils we could do what we call oil it
we we basically yeah we basically
extract the oil out of the plant before
it spoils it and then we use it for
cannabis and for fuse products which
aren't legal so we'd have to throw it
away we just throw the whole thing away
this model that we're talking about here
it you know basically folks the truth is
everybody that we've showed this to in
the industry almost had a laughing
session it's like impossible to make the
you can't move this you you can't
reinvent the wheel you know we are pan
proponents we'd like nothing better
we're from New Hampshire than to see
this state to have us and Matt Simon
come in here to testify against a
legalization bill it's like we can't
even believe we're on the side of the
prohibition that's coming in here but
you guys don't get it if you put this
bill through I'm telling you we think
it's going to collapse we think the
whole thing's going to collapse and we
as a group and our investors don't have
any interest being a supplier under this
circumstances for this bill and that's
and that's basically our opinion but the
takeaway number one from your
perspective is that we're going to have
trouble attracting B uh Growers here
you're under the current situation I
talked to six of probably the top 10
growers in Massachusetts I'm talking
about companies that grow metric tons we
have 60,000 square fet that translates
into about $60 million of of cannabis
yeah yeah I think the part of where it's
unattractive is understanding what is
the buying process what's our risk in
this if I'm going to put up five six
seven million dollars right I need to
have some kind of safety in there to
safeguard that level of an investment
for something that is going into a
controlled Market rather than a free
market and letting the consumer decide
okay I know we're running late so one
one more that that what is the typical
age again for people who buy Edibles is
it the the older crowd the younger crowd
is who who buys the Edibles so so we
have found in specifically in our stores
that it generally errors on the side of
older say again older so probably I'd
say 45 plus uh but the the size of the
market when you're looking at the
infused I mean you could easily have 25
to 30% of the market that would want
Edibles and one other key element of the
concept or the idea that medical
patients may not you know want to have
their medical card is we deal with a lot
of veterans specifically and a lot of
veterans don't aren't interested in
necessarily having their information in
a system one more can I ask one more
question this because it has to do has
to do with the
atcs I'm assuming that Maine has you're
working in M you do your shops in Maine
correct you have atcs in Maine as well H
how how do they work together are the
atcs allowed to uh broaden out and also
have recreational no so how how is that
working out how what's happened to the
atcs in that store has there been any
harm done to them so yes so that there
is so so if they were medical they still
needed to in essence have separate
licensing so if they wanted to have
adult use they'd have to go down that
specific path and Most states that have
both had a medical industry and then
they had the adult industry later on
generally the medical industry starts to
decrease because you know there's just
the in essence just call it you know you
have to go get a card you have to go
through these extra steps rather than
just being able to go in with your ID
and buy whatever product you would seek
any further
questions and another thing to clarify
the Reps because nobody's clar ify to
you they're mixing up can yes can
medical patients go into a store and buy
infused products or flour or anything
else yeah they can but there's a big
difference between medical and
recreational and here's what it is the
gummies that you got that I gave you
right there right if we had loaded them
with THC we would have put 10 milligrams
of THC in it okay but that's not a lot
of THC not enough for a can a cancer
patient and so in the medical industry
we're not limited we we 10 milligrams is
what's in would be in those jars in in
medical store you can have 50 milligrams
in a gummy you could have a 100 there's
there's basically no limits you're
treating a patient based on their
condition and you may need an excessive
money so to say they're going to even to
think that they're going to go in the
stores and to buy things it's it's just
a totally different thing and to give
you some idea how big the medical is in
Maine there's 3,300 compassionate
caregivers and every one of them can
grow cannabis you know and and plus
there a lot that have stores and if you
wonder where your black Market's coming
from I can tell you for sure you know
that's and you know that's what's going
on it's a different model in main than
we it's a different model tot thank you
thank you I'm okay thank you thank you
thank
you important feature of
this is the Liquor
Commission they're going to be
responsible for stores and operating the
stores so we have somebody from the
liquor commissioner here commission here
and aan Moore is
it yes sir thank you very
much and and you'll fill out a pink card
before I have it filled up now sir ready
to turn
then uh thank you for the opportunity to
be here sir um before I really take any
questions I would just like to offer a
few comments uh previous bills on
legalization of cannabis have suggested
creating a a separate commission to
oversee the various responsibilities
associated with legal
legalization uh the commission takes no
position on which organizational
approach to the legalization would be
most effective if a bill were to become
law and the commission does not endorse
this bill nor takes a position on the
policy questions that are part of the
bill
so with that being said Mr chairman I'd
be happy to take any questions about our
fiscal worksheet or any of the
information how we came up with the
model that we came up with uh I'll be
happy to do that sir if you could go
over your F uh the fiscal
worksheet uh excuse me essentially we
engaged in a uh once uh representative
uh Abus uh U file this legislation uh we
were approached uh obviously by the LBA
to uh work up a worksheet on this um and
with this uh the the commission chairman
convened a group of uh his managers and
division heads and said if we were to
have this responsibility how would we
approach it what would it look like how
would we do things uh there's a the
first um consideration that the
commission had was to make sure that
nothing
um associated with a bill would
compromise the state's ability to keep
its brand identity for its state liquor
Outlets uh that's a very important uh
part of the revenue to the state of New
Hampshire and um the approach was there
was no interest in putting for example a
cannabis Outlet in a state liquor store
the approach was to keep them completely
separate distinct brand identity
and so therefore the budgets that were
built were built around that concept of
having a separate yet distinct operation
If This Were to become law and that's
how we approached this um we used the
figure of 10 stores simply to come up
with a a number a rough number as a
place to possibly start and and clearly
that is part of a an exercise it it it
uh it certainly influenced the propos
proposed budgets that we would put
forward and therefore the number of
personnel for example that you would see
uh I think our estimates for all
um aspects of personnel needs whether
it's from Administration to enforcement
to store operations had roughly 70
people in it now clearly if you have 10
stores you'd probably need this a number
of people to run it if if the policy
questions came up and said well we we
only want to appro create um 5 million
10 million then obviously these things
would be paired back and those numbers
would change so the the fiscal
worksheets we've provided to you sir are
really based upon uh that model of 10
stores with the Staffing and
administrative needs and enforcement
needs to uh to carry out that mission
okay questions from the
committee representative bney yeah so
we're talking about the fiscal note in
the in the back of the bill in terms of
the cost of running the store yes sir
you you estimate for the 10 store 7.8
million startup costs first that's the
first thing yes and then the annual cost
and that I'm assuming that the number
here the 3.3 million is is the annual
cost for the 10 stores yes sir okay
so so uh
$337,000 if you divide by 10 per store
correct yes and some of this is is is
obviously based on estimates we the
commission really has no experience in
this area and so we're we're trying to
forecast and project uh what would be
what would be needed um one of the
things that I'll I'd be happy to point
you to is on page 11 of the bill um
lines 22 through
28 um and we
would probably indicate that this is not
written properly to indicate what it is
that we'd like to do because we have no
experience the commission has no
experience in this area uh the chairman
felt that it was important that if this
were to become law that we would uh
provide an RFP for someone who would
fulfill the roles that we would we've
been calling inside a negotiat somebody
who knew the business somebody who could
provide advice to the commission someone
who could provide training um advice on
purchasing um somebody who has the
skills and backgrounds in this area so
that um we would be able to carry out
the legislatively prescribed mission on
page 11 you'll see the Bold language it
says the commission may select and
retain additional investigators through
a competitive bidding process approved
by the governor and executive Council um
the use of the word investigator there
is is it's just not the right word um as
you probably are aware liquor
investigators are law enforcement
Personnel who are hired under the
state's Personnel department rules and
have a completely different function
than what would be prescribed here so we
feel that that that wording is an error
and uh that would need to be uh flushed
out and changed if this bill were to
become law before it became law if
that's what you
decided representative Brony okay thank
you yeah I I I saw that um I did I did
speak to Aiden offline ahead of time
just to get a sense of where you were
coming from and also to ask for the
revenue side of this which we'll get to
in a second
so but the cost the 3.3 million doesn't
really include well it does include it
doesn't include the product costs it
does doesn't this is just the employees
the the plant the heat the lights and
all that yes um so it doesn't include
the product cost but it also doesn't
include any the overhead from The Liquor
Commission itself I mean the pration of
the uh perhaps of the uh commissioner's
time your time uh then we have to talk
about and I see uh Mr abanian sitting
here
enforcement uh I'm assuming
enforcement's going to have a role is
that correct in your model yes
sir and but that in your in your numbers
is is cost is that
cost in these numbers the enforcement
portion a pration of enforcement time uh
thank you representative sorry about
that um for the model that was presented
to us in the Bill yes but what was what
I have been listening to with other
factions um um more
privatization is going to create more
venues which is going to create more
oversight and and for a lack of a better
term a heavier lift so and we we would
make our model mirror whatever model is
presented to
us yeah I guess follow up follow up I
guess guess I'm trying to make sure we
have the cost here and then our best
estimate of what the revenue is going to
be because we're all about the net you
know what's the that so so given that
point what we were presented in the
original bill is a representation of
what's in the
LSR okay if it expands from there of
course everything else is anything so
you fail you the cost of enforcements
are in this on these
estimates the cost of the Personnel
attached to it yes okay thank you thank
you um and then are we going can I can I
lead off with the the question about the
revenues the sheet that you handed
out so um what I what I glean from that
when I look at it is it looks like you
the average per capita you came up with
kind of like a third of the way down on
the first page is $
uh that's that would be Revenue per
capita or net revenue per
capita no excuse me uh that would be
yeah that would be Revenue per capita
uh net uh again net revenue per capita
so that if we take that 35 am I correct
in that first off is that the number we
should be using are you referring sir to
this this sheet yes yes um and you're on
page one page one on the first
uh you say per capital numbers that the
total
$355 Capal $35 yes
sir so if we take that times the let's
what the what's the latest census uh
1.36 million people in in New Hampshire
something like that let's assume that's
the number if we multiply it times to 35
that's uh that would be an estimate of
uh 48 million in change 48 million is
that 50 I just said the numbers on like
yes so okay so do you think that's the
transfer that's your best estimate of
the what you think the transfer would be
to the to the state from Liquor
Commission to the
profit that's the best estimate that our
Chief Financial Officer could could
develop uh based upon what we know and
looking at the surrounding states and
what they've done
um certainly there's some questions
about pricing as you've as you've heard
uh and discussed and how those prices
are uh set representative Aly I believe
asked a question about pricing and uh we
would need to If This Were to become
statute of course we would need to
proceed to Ru making where a great deal
of the detail on how this would be done
would be flushed out and of course uh
public notice and comment uh for that
process and according to the bill we we
would have a very tight timeline uh in
which to carry these out um it gives us
some pretty hefty uh timetables to
follow uh to bring this online If This
Were to become law so one more followup
I let others do so so the way she got at
this number your Chief fiscal officer
yes right of liquor is she took a look
at all the states
here and I guess looked at what the per
per capita was of
taxes right not because this is a unique
model we're talking about here but of
taxes and came up with the $35 is that
correct yes sir okay that's all just
want to understand thank
you represent line thank you simple
question you were talking earlier about
page 11 line 25 where we improperly use
the word uh additional investigators
would an appropriate phrase for that be
Market
Consultants uh could be anything but
investigator anything but investigator
thank you uh and and that what we're
really looking for is as again to to
find a if if this were to become law to
find a person who who would have that
expertise um we envision putting out an
RFP um putting out the criteria the the
needs the experience that a person would
need to have bring this to governor and
Council for approval uh a completely
transparent process so that the person
who is uh selected If This Were to occur
uh would have the the uh experience
knowledge uh to Aid the Commission in
making sure that this was carried out to
the best of our ability so Mr chair so
if I can just follow up so if I change
that line to read the commission may
select and retain Market Consultants
through a competitive bidding process
that would meet your goal to be able to
find a market consultant who knew the
industry and would be able to advise you
accordingly on how to proceed I believe
that would be sir thank
you thank you representative elmy
sorry uh for one
thing uh the this survey is trying to
use the tax revenue there and all of
these states have different forms of tax
revenue and I've got questions about
whether three of them are also adding a
sales tax on top of the marijuana tax
that uh that are in this list but uh
wouldn't it be better to start from
sales in each
state even though probably the price
differs in
different different places too or to
start as they started with the Dr last
time as uh the amount consumed per
capita which I think has to come through
public public health
research on because the model that he's
trying to use is totally different from
what all these other states are doing
and he's claiming that this is going to
provide a greater ability of
profit than we would get than we would
get if we followed the traditional tax
models
I'm afraid uh representative I I'm not
sure I have the background or experience
to provide you with an opinion that
would would uh be meaningful in this
area I think there's a couple of
different ways of looking at it
certainly if you uh would like us to try
to get you a different
analysis of potential Revenue I think um
you know some of this is based upon this
is the best we could provide
based upon the models that exist within
the states and our model the model
that's being proposed in this bill of
course is certainly different than any
of these so anything that we would do
would would
be our best guess best estimate if you
will um and if you feel you would like
to have this um estimate provided using
different criteria we'll certainly try
to get that to you um I think it would
be helpful to have look at it a couple
of different ways to get an idea of the
range your range is 50 million
which I calculated considerably less
than that just from Colorado a number of
years ago uh
but on their uh the sponsors range is
260 to 360 million so that's pretty
different uh but also my other question
was about you do a really good job with
what is pretty much a non-p perishable
product that you can buy anywhere in the
country and you figure out what are the
best uh the product that is going to
sell best in New Hampshire stores and
you find a way to get it except for the
one that I want most at this point but
anyway tell us tell her what it is
representative we'll get I have told a
number of store clerks and they say they
just aren't doing it but uh
so and but you do a really good job of
that and you've outcompeted Total Wines
which is quite
quite remarkable on but this is based on
an Agricultural Product which is as the
previous people said perishable it's not
being grown outside so it's not quite as
erratic as regular agriculture but it
still can be somewhat
erratic and
um and with limited you have to be
limited to inside people who are growing
inside of the
State uh are you saying that the price
point that you that you'd have to use
which is key to
what what the revenues would probably be
uh would be something that the market
consultant would have to try to figure
out so the market consultant would have
to understand uh cannabis growing quite
a quite well in the North in in the
north part of the United States I I'd
say that's a very fair comment
representative that you know the
commission does not have the experience
in this area and would need to rely upon
this person whomever they may be to
provide um solid guidance and Direction
on how to where to acquire it how much
to pay for it what the price it at uh
every aspect of it that
um that we we are not aware of now um as
you pointed out we have over 75 years of
experience with alcohol and all that all
of that but this would uh while the
model might be similar and its
appearance and the fact that it's a
control type of product uh we don't have
any any experience with this area so we
would rely on that negotiat or that
other advisor to give us a direction in
that thank you thank
you question first first of all anybody
else have question may may I ask Sor may
I Mr chairman before may I ask
representative Aly if if if you would be
willing to provide me with the type of
assessment you would like to on will
we'll present that to our Chief
Financial Officer see if we can bring
you back some different figures and
using different criteria if you would
like
thank and I think of course she will say
how how would they like us to look look
at it what from you know from a what
perspective to do the calculation so if
you would be willing to share that uh
we'll make sure we try to get you the
best estimates we
can thank you Mr chairman represent
Ames thank you
uh so right I think at the beginning of
your testimony if I remember correctly
um you uh said something about how in
entering into this new um field you the
Liquor Commission wanted to
keep clearly in
Focus it's primary the business that
you've worked on for 75 years and you've
developed a standard and a success and
you didn't want you'd want to be sure
that whatever you did didn't undermine
that um and I my question to you if I've
got that right is uh what concerns might
you have what what uh what might
entering into this new
Venture um do to the The Venture that's
right now everything for
you well I believe sir that uh under the
direction of the commission chairman mik
the and it and his staff the commission
has worked very hard to um set up and
show the consumers that New Hampshire is
a good place to visit and that we have a
great selection of family-friendly
businesses a place where for example uh
visitors might bring their children in
and and and see the stores are set up
with uh I think Tastefully Etc um and we
don't know what how the public would
receive now uh having these two products
in one location uh um that it may it's
it's possible that uh some members of
the public who have enjoyed shopping at
the liquor Wine and Liquor Outlets might
say I'm not going to in there I I I'm
not going to go in there they're selling
a product that I'm opposed to personally
that they say we're not we're not going
to stop here now and I think um the
concern is that we want to make sure
that the brand identification of the
liquor uh and wine outlets is not
tarnished or compromised in any way that
would have a negative impact on the
revenues that the legislature relies on
for that so so therefore the decision
was made uh if we're going to be tasked
with this then we're going to uh develop
a separate location uh separate
locations
um separate identities uh and and taking
from the models I know it was discussed
in the budgets about advertising and a
few other things I mean the model that
was presented to you was kind of the
model that is from liquor you know this
advertising there promotions this things
of that nature and certainly it's public
policy if if if you decided that that
was not appropriate then obviously the
bill would be amended to or the uh I
don't believe the bill actually has
anything to do with that in there so um
but that's that's part of the decision
our fiscal worksheet shows an
appropriation of 50 .8 million I believe
is what it is that we were uh providing
with the cost to start up um as opposed
to the 14
million so there's certainly a
difference there um that would be need
to be made up someplace
so thank you sir further further
questions so thank you Mr chair um I
think we got to remember now now is when
we do the revenue and I did talk to your
CFO about this and I said you are you
going to estimate based on with Edibles
or without Edibles which is well for now
it's going to be because she was
confused too as to whether Edibles were
in this bill or not and because all the
comparative data has Edibles in it so
and this bill certainly doesn't have
Edibles other than a minor amount that's
going to be sold to people with cards
which is going to be such a small Manu
portion of any sales and I don't even
know why we'd have a product on on the
shelves because it just create more
problems for you guys
so I I I think with any analysis we have
can do we have to kind of agree on a
percent of sales that's Edibles and try
to adjust somehow I don't know how we're
going to do that but I think we have to
say there's no Edibles in this bill and
therefore the revenu is going to be a
lot less and just for the record and I'm
going to talk about this in work work
session the the Cannabis the marijuana
commission that um I chaired we we
estimated any the average was around
45.5 million is what we thought would
come to the state same ballpark of where
where you are and that that number
included Edibles just like this does so
I don't think your estimates are that
far off but we'll discuss that in work
session thank you Mr
chair thank you any further questions of
the Liquor
Commission
thank you thank you Mr chairman thank
you committee
members I
um for the committee let me ask a
question we
have we have five more pink
cards um that
oppose two that
support
Joe Hannah it doesn't
indicate Joe are you supporting or
opposing okay what' you say trying to
figure it out he's trying to figure out
that one was just spoke
right okay um I'll put this one last
that came in
last what I would like to do was is
called Heather Murray Brown who's an
opposing
she represents the
therapetic I didn't say it right
cannabis Medical oversite
Board and uh you asked for 10 to 12
minutes if
defitely if you could
summarize because uh we are
running
and I will also be submitting um part of
this testimony through email as well so
you can have an electronic copy thank
you but I'm here for two reasons I'm
here first and foremost
to give a statement that was developed
by the
therapeutic uh cannabis medical
oversight board for the that you know we
we work with the HHS and uh work with
the legis islative body on um giving
education advice and so forth and
relevance to the therapeutic cannabis
program um good afternoon and thank you
for the opportunity to share our
thoughts with the committee my name is
Heather Marie Brown and I am the
co-chair of the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board and fill the
seat of patient
representative recently the board took
up the discussion in regards to
legalization in the state of New
Hampshire and whether or not
we whether or not we should issue an
opinion on the subject the board voted
on this matter and our response is
provided the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board also known as
the TCM o feels that even if
recreational Cannabis is approved in New
Hampshire that it is important to still
maintain a therapeutic cannabis program
we cannot as a board stand behind or in
good faith give support for any bill
that would have a negative impact on the
program and most importantly our
patients we believe there is a way to
have both programs operate without
impacting each other or the people they
serve on behalf of the TCM o I thank you
for your time and if you have any
questions to ask me in this capacity has
a board member I would be welcome to
answer them for you before I add my own
two cents as a
patient and personal
citizen thank you for Testimony
questions represent
Aaron thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming today so my question is do
you feel that um the bill as it is
written would financially be a detriment
to your
program I personally most certainly do I
I I see a lot of problems with this bill
probably one of my biggest issues with
this bill is that you the the state
would take on the responsibility of
adding very low dose and possibly lesser
quality edible products to their shelves
that would only be available to
Medicinal patients
um I heard this word used earlier and
the more I thought about it the more I
sounded it sounded appropriate but this
build literally will poach therapeutic
cannabis patients it's giving a patient
just enough to get them through the door
to go ooh ooh ooh and then when they see
the flower that would ultimately be
available and because it is being sold
taxfree and controlled by the state of
New Hampshire that flower would in fact
I believe be much less than what
purchasing that item would be at our
dispensary our dispensaries are
nonprofit but has many of you know they
are subject to so many rules and
regulations set forth by the state of
New Hampshire none of those would apply
in this particular bill because of those
restrictions because of those rules and
regulations it forces the dispensaries
to have higher operating costs which in
turn means that they are having to sell
their products for a considerable amount
more money than what they should have to
um you know so to open up a recreational
store that is already going to be able
to sell cannabis at a much cheaper rate
and then throw the fact that you're
going to have lowd do Edibles in there
to try and attract medicinal patients in
the
door it literally puts the recreational
program and the therapeutic cannabis
program in direct competition of one
another I truly feel and I am a patient
and I will tell you that cost is a huge
factor and although I have added
experience with cannabis and and I know
that my best choices and options when it
comes to Quality when it comes to safety
when it comes to dosing when it comes to
protections is through the therapeutic
cannabis program I can tell you that
there are thousands of other individuals
in the state where their primary focus
each day is how am I going to pay for my
mens how am I going to pay for my flour
how am I going to pay for my bills and
if they can determine that oh I can go
get this product so much more cheaper
through the recreational model then
ultimately they would leave or could
potentially leave the therapeutic
cannabis program without having the
realization that they're actually
leaving the program and going to a
facility that would not be able to
provide them education that would not be
able to provide them guidance that would
not be able to provide them products
that were adequate to suit their health
and medicinal needs a and you know
that's a disservice to them that's a
disservice to us and it's so sad because
you know for us to sit here and think
well you know I'm always going to do the
best that I can do for myself no no
you're not if it means the difference
between having your therapeutic cannabis
and making sure your lights stay on you
you're going to make sure that your
lights stay on but you're also going to
figure out a way to get your therapeutic
cannabis so if that means that you know
can I remind everybody that the policy
has been has been voted on we here to
talk about the revenue and no I was just
answering her question but so to your
point Mr chair I was just wondering to
see whether there would be a financial
impact on our therapeutic cannabis
program which the state has something to
do with versus um you know how that
affect how that would be affecting I
think what she has said y thank you and
just to clarify and make that a lot
shorter yes it would have a financial
impact on the program itself and I
believe that yes it would have a
financial impact on the dispensaries as
well any further
questions thank
you and and can I just can I just um add
on has has myself as a personal
individual really quickly um I also
believe as an individual that the way
that this bill currently is written will
actually impair Eep economic growth and
development for New Hampshire residents
and that in some areas it will create
discrimination and uh
preference preference issues because it
only allows for so many cultivators it's
only allowing sales to be handled by the
state a and it's just limiting a New
Hampshire citizen from being able to
move forward economically which in turn
if they can move forward economically in
theory they're putting more money into
the state into retail and increasing the
revenue that the state does
collect any further questions say none
thank you um the committee has been here
since N9 o'clock this
morning and uh I think we're going to
take one more
card and so we take Kate
fry from she's not here
[Music]
anymore she left she left okay and she
left us the her
testimony so I can take one more
then this be frank k n a a c
K uh
ACLU and support of the bill and you
said two
minutes we have to come back for 9 o' in
the
morning
I don't
know what do you want to
do the problem is we have we have people
have other commit
commitments and they need to eat before
they get to this six o'
meeting so uh go ahead Frank uh thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
for the opportunity to testify my name
is Frank kak on policy director with the
ACLU of New Hampshire uh just quickly uh
three points to make uh one we really
like the fact that this revenue is going
to go towards supporting mental health
and substance use treatment as many of
you know New Hampshire's prisons of
jails have become de facto mental health
and substance use treatment institutions
because we failed to adequately fund
those services so we think it's an
important first step in addition just
quickly talking about some of the costs
and both the costs associated with um uh
that are projected as well as some of
the um the costs that are not included
in the the fiscal note uh one one point
to make is that uh each of the 1494
arrests that New Hampshire made in 2020
required a judge a clerk law enforcement
officers prosecutors back in 2013 the
ACLU conducted a nationwide economic
analysis on the impact the fiscal impact
of marijuana prohibition and we found in
New Hampshire that we were spending
about 6 $6,500,000 each year in forcing
prohibition alone in 2020 we had about
half the number of arrests and the
methodology is such that we can
basically divide that in half so last
year in 2020 we spent about $3.25
million enforcing prohibition of
possession alone in New Hampshire and in
the fiscal note it it it assumes that
there's going to be increased costs and
we heard this from the chief there's
going to be increased cost around
increased crime increas traffic
fatalities and if you'll note in the
fact sheet I handed out with footnotes
um six
through uh 14 that the the um the the
projections or the the assertions made
by the chief are actually not true not
supported by data uh we multiple Studies
have found that there's no increase in
youth use U multi uh there's been little
or no effect in crime rates including a
multi-year study in Colorado in
Washington which found that it actually
improved crime clearance rates um
multiple studies again have found that
marijuana legalization had little or no
effect on traffic accidents and
fatalities and then there's also
substantial evidence that marijuana
legalization assists with reducing the
opioid epidemic that is so serious here
in New Hampshire so again I think it's
important to look at you know what we
heard in the r versus the reality and
again um what we also heard not in
testimony today but from the chief when
it was heard in criminal justice was
there'd be a spillover effecting
crime and I just want to point out so
going from the most recent State
regional state to legalize which was
Vermont in 2018 Massachusetts and new H
and Maine were before that Mr chair
point of
order yes we're starting to stray into
policy and away from finance and and
funds if we could kind of get back on
that because everyone's time is valuable
oh sorry I was talking about this in the
context of the fiscal note assuming that
there'd be additional law enforcement
costs and I just wanted to give some
data around that but I I'm happy to to
move on and I think additional and the
intangible costs you you had indicated
two minutes on you I'm I'm happy to stop
there then
sir if we can wrap it up sure I think
just the intangible costs um you know
the cost of marijuana rest if you're on
Student Financial Aid you lose your
student financial aid it's harder to get
it's harder to get employment again
those are intangible costs that I think
will impact the bottom line I think it's
important for this legislation to move
forward and I appreciate your
time
okay all right rather
than not hear from
everybody we have one two three four
more car five more
cards we can limit it to three
minutes maximum for questions and
speak that'll give everybody an
opportunity so
um conine
Bloom from Prime
ATC oppos the
bill
thank you very much for the time to
speak um chairman major Vice chairman
abami and committee members my name is
Keenan Blum and I serve as the president
and CEO of prime alternative treatment
centers of New Hampshire established in
2016 Prime is one of the not for profit
alternative treatment centers that is
licensed to provide therapeutic cannabis
to registered patients in accordance
with RSA
126x we have approximately 55 staff
members and we operate a production
facility in Peterborough and
dispensaries in marac and
chiester our ATC has had only one focus
and that is serving registered patients
here in New Hampshire generally we
support legalizing cannabis for adults
21 and over and we believe adult use
cannabis Market should be responsibly
regulated following best practices and
lessons learned from other states
unfortunately we cannot support HB 1598
in its current form because it ignores
key recommendations from New Hampshire's
bipartisan study commission that we
believe are essential to success to a
successful cannabis regulation
policy we have a number of questions and
concerns about the bill today I will
refrain from commenting on certain areas
of policy such as the emission of Home
cultivation and the proposed Rec
criminalization of infused products
because I understand that such issues
will likely be considered outside the
scope of today's hearing instead I will
focus my testimony on issues that are
directly relevant to the Bill's fiscal
impacts first restricting sales to 10
state-run stores rather than allowing
Private Sales would limit consumers
access negatively impacting potential
sales and revenues in Most states that
have legalized adult use cannabis
medical cannabis businesses have been
instrumental in helping to Pioneer Adult
use markets may I interrupt you since
you have three minutes can you summarize
because we can all take this and read it
later I will do my very best to thank
you
um in this regard hb1 1598 represents a
dramatic departure from policies that
are generally worked well well in other
states when the New Hampshire bar
partisan study looked into this they
spent significant time and effort
evaluating all of these different
policies including visiting the atcs at
least ours and speaking with with us for
hours and asking questions thank you
um what they came up with is that any
future legislation to legalize and
commercialize marijuana should consider
a pathway for the atc's licensed and
therapeutic cannabis to transition from
not for-profit charitable trust to
for-profit entities and participa in the
adults adult use
Market our staff has been assisting
patients for over 5 years we have
developed great skill at this and we put
every bit of our effort into it we would
like to be able to participate in this
market and to take these skills and
things we've learned and try to assist
to make the adult use cannabis Market in
New Hampshire something that works
really well and is beneficial for the
people of New Hampshire both from a for
their private use and from a budgetary
perspective um our my second point was
just that HB 598 would produce Revenue
but at what cost to patients and the
therapeutic cannabis program
um in general as others have pointed out
taxes are the difference between a
medical or therapeutic program and adult
use adult use is generally taxed very
high the therapeutic cannabis program
and or medical program is not taxed
usually at
all
um as a nonprofit our ATC does not
currently produce revenue for the state
except for paying for the program we are
EXA from the business Enterprise tax and
business profits tax and there are no
State Taxi Le taxes Lev in the
production and sale of therapeutic
cannabis we do pay a lot of federal
taxes and we would like to begin paying
state taxes as well but only we can only
do so if the legislature allows us to
reorganize and begin serving the adult
use
market so finally although we feel we
have no choice but to oppose the bill as
currently written we would be more than
happy to review any proposed amendments
and reconsider our position accordingly
we agree with the overwhelming majority
of granted Staters that cannabis should
be legal and we would like to work with
you and other policy makers contributing
the knowledge and experience we've
gained in the last five and a half years
of this process so on behalf of our
staff managers and and directors at
primeatc we thank you for your time and
consideration and um if there's any way
we can assist please uh don't thank you
for summarizing questions let me just so
what you're saying is and I yes correct
we that's was in the in the commission
report that if we were to legalized and
when we talked legalized and
commercialized we talked about free
enterprise we weren't talking about this
model and we gave you pathway we suggest
that there be a pathway for the the
atc's to also participate and divide
their stores medical and and uh to be
able to
compete in in the market but with this
bill there's no possibility to that so
the the atcs are standing out there all
by themselves and at the mercy of
whatever happens in the market uh is
that correct and is that's what you're
trying to say correct well yes and we
have a very small medical program in New
Hampshire with less than or about 1% of
the population whereas many states been
as much as 5% like Massachusetts was
until recently generally you will see a
reduction in that program and we are not
in a place where the margins available
or the amount or or our business can
take say our our uh our sales being cut
in half and still survive that is not
something that we would be able to
manage so you would see likely a death
of that program and a number of
different a number of patients say
patients under 21 or may not who may not
find the appropriate products or more so
guidance and education in the model
proposed here they would be completely
without help or without Assistance or
the appropriate
products any further questions say none
thank you thank you the next is a darl e
a m
r uh representing New Hampshire cannabis
Association and support part of the bill
and if you could just be I will be
definitely brief I know it's getting
long in the teeth here uh essentially
I'm here today just to uh talk about
essential services in U respect to the
fact that if we want revenue for the
state we've got to make sure cannabis
businesses can do business um I want you
to know I reached out to the CEO of a
credit union she lives here in New
Hampshire um she is the CEO of a cred of
a wholly owned subsidiary of the credit
union that does Bank can abis I have
some information from her uh she has
told me she can Bank New Hampshire
cannabis businesses she can Bank retail
stores even if they are state run um but
only if the language of the bill does
not require FDIC insured institutions
because as she told me the credit unions
oper operate under a different FDIC
insured Federal equivalent so that was
something important for her to note that
as long as you don't limit it they can
Bank us uh they have locations in
Massachusetts and New Hampshire and also
employees could use those branches uh
I've got her contact information here
along with a couple of handouts uh that
I will email to the committee uh so that
you can talk to her if you have any
questions uh I also wanted to just
brooch the pro the uh the area of
financing many of you may not know but
this is what I do as a day job
connecting cannabis companies with
sources of capital um it is available
borrowers do have to qualify it comes
and flavors of credit unions Banks uh
hedge funds private investment funds uh
Real Estate Investors development
companies management companies and
Equity investment firms so I want to
make sure that was clear uh in terms of
credit card and merchant processing
right now they direct touching uh
cannabis companies cannot use the credit
card rails to process transactions they
can use pin debit they can use cashless
ATM although that might be going away
and there are some workarounds that do
involve credit cards that are coming to
the Forefront including a company in
California that has um brought their
solution to the state that is both Fally
and state compliant um I'll give you
some information on that I also did
reach out to a patent and trademark
lawyer um you know can New Hampshire
cannabis companies protect their brands
and any strains that they create the an
short answer is yes in two ways both the
name of a strain or the business and
also the genetics of a strain uh Matthew
Miller from mg Miller has also okay me
giving you his information if you'd like
to reach out to talk to him about that
and then I would just also include the
fact that we have people that can
provide insurances for the businesses um
just about any essential service that
they're going to need to operate already
exist and so some of the challenges that
I think that we're looking at in some of
these bills U might already be solved
and so we wanted you to know that and so
I will send all of these out uh in an
email to the committee and I also put my
business card over here if any of you
have questions reach out and we can get
you in touch with the professionals okay
okay we would appreciate the information
thank you for being
brief the next is Mark Hall from the
Department of
Safety uh opposing the
bill good afternoon Mr chairman I
promise you I'll be brief um I realize
your time is valuable um my name is Mark
Hall I'm a field area Captain with the
state police I'm here on behalf of the
Department of Safety in opposition of
the bill and although I have many points
that have some of them have already been
addressed I'll just stick to
um what what could be the fiscal uh side
of things as far as a law enforcement
impact um with the legalization uh this
this definitely would have a significant
impact on on law enforcement in
particular I know it's already been
addressed with increase in impaired
driving introducing uh what's now a
controlled drug into to into our society
would would uh certainly uh that's the
potential uh result is increased in
impaired drivers increased in uh traffic
crashes and fatalities uh due to um
driving Under the Influence um certainly
we would be looking to increase the
number of drug recognition experts that
are in the field um to uh combat this uh
issue um and also an increase in
training in in Manpower
um to deal with any investigations that
might come with this uh
legalization I'm open to any questions
if you have
them thank you for your testimony
questions from the
committee see none thank you thank you
sir the next we have Dan
Stockwell
stwall uh
constituent oppose the
bill
I'm from New Hampshire um I've been uh
and um I just first of all just want to
point out um that in New Hampshire this
year there there have been um according
to the USDA
33 Growers of of uh hemp producers in
New Hampshire um and that's a
combination of commercial and personal
Growers
all licensed to grow
outdoors um and uh some under Greenhouse
some outdoors and this has been
happening all over New Hampshire over
the past year um and uh these plants are
visually and and and uh smell wise
identical to um flowering marijuana
plants cuz they're grown for the CBD FL
flow um and uh as far as I know that
hasn't caused any major disruptions in
the state um to have these plants
growing all over the state um and my
point is um mainly the cost of um
prohibition is is a Taps us
resource-wise and uh all the states
around us
um their their
legalizations um
the what they did number one right out
of the gate was legalized possession and
growing of the
plant and um and as far as I can tell I
mean we've heard um these statistics
from law enforcement that are
um quite honestly um smoke and mirrors
the the sky hasn't fallen in any of
these states around us and um and the
the um enforcement of the prohibition is
Major costly and and I would submit that
um putting forward any
legalization program that doesn't um
legalize or at least decriminalize the
growing of the plant for personal use is
a major mistake because you're going to
be
um um making it status quo to have um
people have
uh uh
marijuana
and and that's just going to
there's there was 33 Growers of these
marijuana Lake plants and then there's
going to be there's going to be more
next year USDA licensed and the New
Hampshire's as far as I know not connect
collecting any revenue from those um and
so they lost big time Big Time there but
the but uh personal growing is is a um
is a business sector in itself for for
supplies and
consultation and uh and it's also
keeping a lot of Revenue State side
because that's number of New Hampshire
people that aren't going outside in New
Hampshire um the other thing that I just
want point that I wanted to make was is
I attended many of the meetings on the
uh legalization Committee in
2018 and there there was um you know the
determination that it would be ill
advised and inappropriate for the Liquor
Commission to to um be a regulatory body
and have any hand in in uh cannabis
control um and I think that that was on
Target and and uh a lot of work went on
into that committee and I think that
that should uh a lot of those the
advisements from that committee should
be double checked before we go forward
with any
legalizations thank you for your
testimony any questions none thank you
and the last
card is from The Honorable Dr Joe Hannon
uh doesn't indicate support or
opposition but he's a public member of
the New Hampshire commission to
study he was on the marijuana commission
marijuana it was on the marijuana
Commission in
2018 thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee um thank you
for being here at this weary hour and
for being so patient um I I do support
legalization so I don't want to discuss
the policy issues of it but I do have
some issues and questions that I think
uh might you might want to consider when
considering amendments to how this
should be implemented uh like um
representative aramy was saying there
were uh we had a commission that studied
it and we had lots of recommendations I
don't think they're being taken into
consideration in this particular bill um
if you're going to judge whether we're
going to have a state Monopoly versus a
private sector uh option way of doing
this we have to look at not just is this
going to make money for New Hampshire if
we sell it from the state we have to
look at it um from the side of how much
money would we make if we sold it from
the private sector we're missing we're
not paying um enough attention to the
fact that we'd be getting business
profits tax business Enterprise taxes if
there was a uh some kind of model where
people were able to go to a bar or some
kind of place where they could safely
consume it in some way and an edible or
food Arrangement there could be meals
and rooms taxes applied to it other
sources of revenue for the state
um we also have to um look at the state
pension liability of new employees that
the state would have to hire and fund
those pensions through however long
they'd be getting those pensions um um
we have to examine the legal and
economic um risks of assuming um the
state Monopoly I mean what happens if if
Federal Law changes and we're kind of
screwed here we're just stuck with this
big business that we have to fund and
we've got a bank and all this money
we're spending and pensions and now we
can't do it uh times can change I'm not
saying it's likely but it's possible um
we heard testimony about the potential
impact of becoming of um of harming the
medical cannabis
economy uh there was a law enforcement
officer previously testified about how
the illicit Market produces about 250%
of what actually needs to be sold in
this country so it would not be unheard
of for a business that wants to compete
a black market for example that wants to
compete with us they could flood the
market and keep us from selling anything
they've got 2 150% more than they
actually need in this country so you
know I don't know how that would even be
uh a viable option the most viable
option will be allowing people to grow
for personal usage um like the alcohol
Uh current situation Hampshire you can
have home brew of beer and wine uh that
was discussed in the commission it was
something that liquor enforcement they
although they like to go after
Moonshiners and people that are selling
it for profit they don't even check on
people growing it for for you know
personal consumption use under the legal
limit there's just it's not a concern um
another impact is um the the economic
and social impacts that be that will be
lost uh for potential business owners
employees from economically
disadvantaged groups and those who've
been harmed by the current and past drug
policies uh some states have uh you know
quotas or you know different measures of
getting people that are at disadvantaged
or poor who had been harmed by past drug
policies to open cannabis businesses and
that does not exist in this uh this
legislation uh we have high energy costs
in New Hampshire so it does take more to
grow things indoors we don't have a long
outdoor growing season we have increased
energy costs there's an there's an
environmental impact there's an economic
impact of that now we're not allowed to
import or export or transport transport
across state lines currently but if that
changes any growth industry in any uh
local growth grow IND growing industry
in New Hampshire could be seriously
impacted and we need to have the
flexibility to adapt and and that leads
me to my final Point um a free private
Market is the most Innovative and well
able to adapt and provide what consumers
actually want we're basically saying you
can't have Edibles you can't have this
you can only have this much THC you've
got to have it in this package we're
going to put on this shelf we're we're
it's like we're selling uh government
cheese and ESP special store putting a
big sign saying look how wonderful we
are giving you this but all the places
around us are selling like 42 types of
salad dressing and we can't do that here
you know we're we're trying to limit
ourselves and limit our our capability
and the the unlimited potential of the
people of New Hampshire to to do what is
right for for us and our citizens and I
uh I I look forward to working in the
and helping with any work session that
would amend this bill to make that a
reality for New Hampshire and make a um
make it better so I'd be happy to answer
any questions I'm sure there aren't
going to be a lot at this hour so I'll
be around in the future if you need
anything we thank you for testimony and
we definitely will be having a work
session and we'll get it scheduled any
questions representative could could you
email the committee the testimony you
just gave is it a it kind of scribbled
stuff down as other people were talking
and made it up but I can maybe type it
up uh if I have some notes too if you
don't mind justs even bullet points yeah
I can I can almost read it I'm I'm a
retired doctor so it'll be hard but I
have a friend who can help me I have a
secretary secretary I could ask thank
you thank you questions I don't see any
questions thank
you I'm going to close anybody else want
to testify for against House Bill 1598
and I'm closing the hearing on 1598 I
want to remind the committee that
tomorrow morning at 9:00 we start
another session of the economic
briefings Mr chair will those be uh
available to watch on
[Music]
YouTube yes like the streaming yes
okay so tomorrow morning 9
o'clock uh we have a number of
economists in the morning and and we'll
have presentations in the afternoon the
last one will be scheduled for 2
o'
a